foreign
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
tenacious tactics and clever Novelties
were on display at the sinkfield cup in
St Louis missed winning chances allowed
for daring escapes that resulted in
early draws Frenchman alereza ferrugia
rebounded from his second round loss by
defeating LaVon aronian in a brilliant
game however all eyes were on Rising
Star Hans Neiman who continued to show
that he belongs after a shocking
dismantling of reigning world champion
Magnus Carlson to steal Soul lead in the
event can the young Phenom keep his
winning streak alive round four of
thrilling chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
of the Saint Louis Art Museum as we are
waiting for the players to arrive and
create their own masterpieces over the
chessboard let's go to the studio and
start the action with Yasser Peter and
Alejandro
from the home of Chess in America
welcome to the singfield club the
flagship event of the Saint Louis chess
club and the final stop on 2022
granchester
welcome back to round four and I'm Peter
swidler as usual and with me is yasa
serial one the one the only the Yasser
Peter I wanted to say the same thing
about you as well hello everyone and
Welcome to our live coverage of round
four of what is turning out to be an
extraordinarily eventful event as we had
a large number of decisive games in
round three including a stoppage of a
53-game unbeaten streak by Magnus
Carlson Peter do the honors and tell us
about the current standings absolutely
as you can see there on your screen uh
currently uh the American youngster Hans
Neiman the very very late moment wild
card last moment wild card for this
tournament is uh leading the field with
two and a half out of three arguably
underscoring from from the positions he
had in the tournament he also had a very
very good position round one which he
did not win Right Wesley so isn't clear
second having beaten Fabiano caruana is
a you know in a very intricate petrol
yesterday
and then there's a number of people on
50 most of them with three draws out of
three and uh yeah with only one draw out
of three right and then the uh the
American Duo of Karana and daronian and
the azerbaijani uh Warrior of are
currently below 50 and our format Peter
uh the format is a 10 play around Robin
with the feeder time control in place 90
minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game and the
half a minute increment starting from
the very first move draw first as usual
for example is chess club events not
allowed right and you have the the usual
scoring system of a point for a win at
this point our schedule Peter uh the
schedule is this is round four so we
have today and tomorrow uh and then the
rest day uh and uh after the rest day we
play the four rounds uh that will get us
to the conclusion of the tournament
there you see it there you see it on
your screen and on the topic of tie
breaks if players are tied for first in
this tournament those tie breaks will
happen immediately after the round on
Sunday the 11th and if the GCT points
also somehow end up died that playoff
has a separate day dedicated to it on
Monday I don't know how likely that is
but it will become clearer when we get
closer to the end of the tournament fair
enough and the world can Rejoice because
in studio we have our good friend
Alejandro Ramirez good to see you
Alejandra Peter Yasser what a pleasure
to be with both of you one tournament
we've had so far 19 year old Hans
Niemann in the lead and he certainly has
a challenge ahead of him today because
it's the other 19 year old of the
tournament that is also been making
headlines recently remember Alvarez
affruja comes from a dominating
performance in the St Louis rapid of
Blitz won the tournament with four full
rounds to spare and yesterday he caught
on fire played a magnificent game
against lemonade with a white piece and
sacrificing his night early on and just
putting together a brilliant attack but
has nema's chess has been nearly perfect
only missing a little bit there of
technique to win against lebronian in
the very first day Jill really played a
great game against Shakira Mama Madeira
from yesterday's performance against
Magnus Carlson well we all rejoiced
watching that one and Hans the early
leader of the tournament it's the two 19
year olds facing off against each other
not a lot of experience between them but
this is definitely going to be the
matchup of the day and speaking of Hans
he had the opportunity to get some
autographs and a little bit of Spotlight
as he had his win yesterday to tell us
about it we have women's Grandmaster
Anastasia karlovic thank you Alejandro I
recommend to everyone follow our Saint
Louis chess club and grantchester
accounts social media accounts if you
want to see more from the tournament of
course we have some backstage content
and I followed Hans Neiman yesterday
after the interview and we could see him
sign in autographs with his fans and
many people were congratulating him on
his victory against Magnus I had this
great opportunity to follow his the last
hour of his game against the World
Champion and World Champion doesn't lose
the games every day and it was a really
really tense match and you could feel
this this pressure in the playing Hall
you could see the pain on the face of
the world champion who was literally
annoyed with what was happening on the
board and who hear any noise in the
plane venue so it was a really
interesting match and I'm looking
forward for the today's round Peter yes
sir how are you doing well I can imagine
Anastasia that you were very busy with
all the social media and as you say the
background uh reports thank you for all
don't give a follow do give a follow to
those accounts exactly and Peter do the
honors of today's pairings besides the
match-up of the youths absolutely what
can we expect as we see them as we
already see people sitting down at the
boards yeah the pairings for today
Magnus is White against
the one iron is White against anir
Dominguez in the North American Clash
then of course the pairing that
Alejandro has already highlighted
definitely the the pairing of the round
for me Hans uh having the white pieces
against her as a ferocia uh Yankee is
White against Wesley so a pairing that
over the years has not been very
favorable for him but having the white
pieces is good and also I think
eventually he started winning games
against Wesley for a while it has been
really really problematic for him but
he's gotten on the scoreboard so far
recently so to speak and then of course
a very very mouth-watering prospect
there at the bottom of our list Fabiano
caruana playing White against mvl over
the years they played some fantastic
games in particular I think with this
color pairing absolutely when MBL plays
an idorph and Fabi tries to refute the
entire opening in one game and let's go
to the playing Hall where I can imagine
that all the excitement of the buzz of
what was a very eventful round three
carries on as we see Hans getting nicely
wandered what's he holding in his hand
there here there's a hotel key card on
the right and a pack of garments
actually the other way well spotted I
mean it is yes a pack of chewing gowns I
don't do it and a shot in the background
there also uh entering the playing area
and uh
they're checking that is that the
chewing gum we got to check the chewing
down there I don't need that we need
revenue for this commercial yeah what
kind of chewing gum we got what's up
friend yeah we need to we need to know
yeah uh there he is there waiting
awaiting the arrival it was like a boxer
stalking right like in his Corner okay
Restless tiger exactly Restless tiger
pose there by the Reza
unleash the inner Kraken
there you go
as opposed to the the outer Kraken yeah
the lesser-known outer Kraken right so
everybody getting their one it seems
like that chewing gum seems to have uh
stimulated Chris to make sure that he's
he really doesn't have anything else
well that's the arbiter's
responsibilities right to Jack from top
to bottom
David Cedric right now I recall he's
been at our our tour Arbiter has asked
for increased security and this I think
is a radio uh potentially I I would I
wouldn't know but that's going on
because that that's a that's a very
serious bonding that just took place as
here he is our tournament leader Hans
Neiman getting ready to do battle
and there you go
um I'm told we have breaking news uh it
would appear that uh a certain world
champion Magnus Carlson has decided to
not play today's game
and uh oh my goodness the clock is going
to be started there's a 10 minute rule
that if you don't show it by 10 minutes
you're forfeited
and yeah I'm sitting here I'm here
sitting here going to play in a bit of a
kind of a stunned silence I don't really
know how to react to this I'm you know
there will be some developments I assume
but for for now yeah this is
obviously not not great but uh not much
we can say until we have to let the
situations uh the the the team of Magnus
explain what is going on in the world
champions uh mine is the last 10 minutes
to show up so 10 minutes for him to
change his mind exactly but that is the
news that we are getting of course we
still don't have the full information on
the reasoning and things like that but
we'll get it to you guys as soon as
possible uh but studying development I'm
sure but I do I do know that uh David
Sedgwick at the tournament or
International Arbiter is called for
Greece security measures as we see
chakriar
uh sitting down yeah it's so it's very
much unfun and fun for shark you kind of
feel for sure who had to prepare for
this game and you know any game against
of course any game against the world
champion is is you know going to be an
important game in the tournament I think
in particular Treasures chances to play
against the best of the world he was on
our on our couch here so to speak
explaining how much he still loves chess
and how much it is important for him to
play to play interesting chess uh so for
him there you know sitting and you know
probably coming to the realization that
the game might not actually start on his
board so one is not that great a very
very stunning developments everybody I
think you're hearing the Arbors are
announcing the withdrawal of Magnus uh
for well the forfeit I want to say will
will determine the withdrawal later and
there's his opponent chacriar
saying my gosh I came to play the world
chess champion and he's not here yeah uh
today is uh you have to assume this this
day will sort of reverberate
for for a bit because you don't you
don't see this very often and uh
absolutely whatever the reasons are it
will it will be a very very big talking
point uh going forward but for now we
all the information we have is what
you're seeing on your screen right now
this game is not a game today exactly
Magnus will have 10 minutes to show up
it's unlikely he's and we expect that he
will forfeit his game
um
like this has happened in a tournament
of this caliber helped me out guys with
some some chess history
yeah I I don't know I'm
we could have done some research if we
if we knew but you're right oh my
goodness oh my goodness
um
okay
well I mean in the absence of uh Magnus
may I suggest we turn our attention to
the moves that have been played in the
games and uh we will keep everybody
informed
as we know what's going on we do have in
the game of Fabi versus MBL as you
mentioned Peter these two Gladiators
when they sit down they have brought
some great stuff absolutely F2 F3 f2f3
is a kind of a version of Bishop B3 uh
specifically against mvl I wonder why
it's required because I don't think mvl
is a huge Knight G4 player the reason F3
came to prominence I think in like the
late 90s to early 2000s was very
specifically to play the bishop B3
systems while also not allowing the move
Knight G4 for black uh at all okay and
uh this is why it's being played in
generally transposes to Bishop three
lines even though black has options to
uh you know deviate into some things
which have a standalone importance uh
but good to see you good to see them
playing the neither because mvl recently
has been playing some more solid
openings as well we could have we would
have had another patch off today for
instance but no no Petra I just wanted
to I should have started with our
Marquee matchup of Hans and Neiman our
tournament leader and alireza as these
two 19 year old surge uh to prominence
in the world of Chess I have got uh well
I've got on my analysis board I think an
up-to-date uh and d2d3 in the two nights
defense I I tell you as a kid I don't
know did you have that experience the
fried liver attack and did you study all
of these stuff not particularly somehow
this this passed me by because I uh this
would have been very very interesting to
me as a kid from the white side I think
I would have greatly enjoyed looking at
this right but I used to be a like an
extremely boring uh you know call a
opening player D4 and uh there wasn't
really much much of a discussion for me
in that respect and as black I used to
just automatically Play Bishop C4 Bishop
C5 so that also didn't really come up
very much d2d3 by the way and Bishop to
Bishop C5 Bishop C5 appears to be on the
board yes
um after D3 black has a bunch of other
options as well I think even other as
himself has uh occasionally played uh
the lines with d6h6 and G5 those types
of really really sharp newfangled ways
of playing but
transposes back into classical Italians
which is of course also
please
chess club and hopes to be back doesn't
give any more specifics than that but
he's not just forfeiting today's game
he's withdrawing from the event wow and
that is going to have a change up in the
standings I believe that the grand
Chester regulations do say that if a
player has not completed 50 of his games
then the games that he has played so far
will be annulled that means that none of
those games matter for the standings the
one against uh Hans included they do
count from raiding so Hunt's still over
2700 and minus does lose those seven and
a half or whatever points that was but
uh Hans basically moves down to one and
a half out of two instead of two and a
half out of three and all of the other
players that played against Magnus as
well they have only played two games so
far instead of the full three uh
including young yeah Jana is now tied
for the lead so to speak with only two
games played but Jane is on plus one
having beaten alireza and the loss
against Magnuson run one right now
uh yeah Wesley Steel on plus one so we
have as I understand we have a three
three-way tie at the top right now with
uh with Hanson plus one Western Plus One
and Janam plus one
yeah uh breaking developments all around
yeah we we're going to be somewhat
struggling to catch up and we we
apologize for this likely haphazard
nature of today's stream but one of the
things not really up to us to a large
degree yeah one of the things is we
start the show I always ask you about
our current standings and we're gonna
have to completely revive those current
standings because of a breaking news a
tweet from the world chess champion
Magnus Carlson yeah he has withdrawn
Alejandro what was the Tweet exactly if
you please I've withdrawn from the
tournament I've always enjoyed playing
in the at St Louis chess club and hope
to be back in the future
that is what the world champion has
tweeted so that definitely leads to
brief and to the point brief to the
point definitely no confusion about
whether it's just this game or the
entire tournament he has withdrawn
and for us that means that there will be
no more Magnus Carlsen games in this
tournament all the games that he has
played so far annulled they do not count
for our standings or points but remember
they do count for rating
also in with Magnus now taking
essentially last place then the whole
Grand Chester I mean if we want to go in
that direction there's a there's a bunch
of people in this tournament for whom it
is a good financial news but right but
it I assume uh you know even for those
fighting for the GCT tour uh uh Victory
uh this news cannot really come as any
kind of a positive you you never want to
see uh these things happen and uh but
again I just want to reiterate that
earlier as we were starting the show
David Sedgwick our International Arbiter
and tour director that called for
enhanced security measures after all
anybody who's ever visited the St Louis
chess club and watch the Players as they
entered see that they're very carefully
scanned and wanted but now uh even extra
measures were taking place including
some even delay of our broadcast I
believe that's also one that is that is
one of the security measures uh just to
be it just to be absolutely absolutely
ensuring a safe playing venue for the
players absolutely and uh well uh the
withdrawal of Magnus I'm still kind of
uh processing people yeah it's it's
going to take a while but for now you
know we have the statement we we know
for sure what's happening in regards to
the tournament everything else uh would
be speculation and I think speculating
on behalf of Magnus is absolutely not
not our place here no uh so we're going
to be avoiding avoiding doing that uh
for for the remainder of the broadcast
and I'm sure you understand I'm sure our
audience certainly does I'm sure you are
all of us and let me go to a game that I
don't see very often aronia left has
been doing this linear now this is a
sicilian but it's not the open Sicilian
that we've all come to know and love
this is actually do we call this the
Grand Prix attack no I think the Grand
Prix is always three or four no you have
to with F4 with F4 yeah I think it's
very much connected with the idea of not
developing the G1 Knight at all right
until you have played f2f4 and then you
can aim for or
for some uh some kind of an attack on
the king side and this is a much much
slower setup with white and it has
honestly to my reasonably strong
surprise has gained a decent amount of
traction strong players have been doing
doing this recently because I'm sure
it's the same for you like our
understanding as you know old school
players school players uh was that you
know once white decides to do something
like this against the Sicilian you
absolutely forfeit any chance for an
advantage exactly and black is instantly
completely fine I suspect it's still
true
yeah but what it does is it avoids the
heavily theoretical lines that uh you
know Lanier could have could have played
and it gets you a position where you can
maybe try to you know use the fact that
it's a reasonably unexplored structure
with you know so far all the pieces
still on the board uh to try and to try
and outplay your opponent in some kind
of a you know slow maneuver during fight
let's get Alejandro to join in this
discussion between Lavon no it's not not
for now I think we will yeah we'll we'll
have to wait for a second for for
Alejandro to chime in on this we'll
we're left on our own oh no oh no on our
own devices a283 I understand this move
uh very uh well why it wants to preserve
the light squared Bishop the threat of
Knight C6 to A5 yeah hence we see the
move A2 A3 but you know more or less
following up on what you were saying old
school players like ourselves say what
is white trying to achieve I understand
it when the knights on B1 you may want
to go see 3D from computer Knights on C3
yeah it's it's a really kind of a
strange hybrid of you know a little bit
of everything the the the kind of a mix
uh the kind of a picture where white is
trying to play uh play a mix of
everything I'm not sure I thought yeah
93 actually does surprise me uh a wee
bit because as you're saying like
systems where you play an IBG 2c3 rookie
one you try to push for G3 G4 you're
basically trying to play some kind of a
you know like black is playing the
Sicilian and you say uh sort of no I
don't care I'm playing you know a
Spanish Italian setup exactly whatever
you're doing I'm doing my my thing on my
side of the board here but I apologize I
have to interrupt you on this one but I
do see it officially on the screen yes
that Magnus Carlson is as inspired the
10 minutes that he has to make his
opening move he didn't do it shakri or
mamid arov wins by forfeit and
furthermore through a tweet we
understand that
world champion Magnus Carlson as we've
drawn it's not just this game it's not
just this game
entire event
so that is done that's that's uh an
official deal now going on and we will
wait for further developments and as
soon as we know anything we will sure I
like this move E7 E6 yeah uh another
option would be to play B6 Bishop B7
first but the 65 pretty much always is
going to be a decent idea it's powerful
black so
one thing you could maybe question is
that if that's your plan against the
setup from White uh do we actually need
the bishopon G7 but the combination of
the two is still fine I don't think it's
a mistake of any kind uh because
obviously if you're playing E6 you could
have played E6 and development
but I think you know in Sicilians if you
can fiancato that Bishop to G7 uh off
the bat straight off the bat it pretty
much always is a preferable feeling
outside to having it only seven and then
perhaps having to play rookie here
and get it slowly slowly but the bishop
on E7 it is tucked away Behind These
pawns on D6 said C5 I like the bishop on
G7 for a completely different reason and
it has to D to do with the Knight on C3
Knight on C3 is not going forwards full
stop it's just not so this Knight on C3
is going to re-maneuver often times it
might find that it it should hang out on
the king side vis-a-vis E2 to G3 well
then I've got my Pawn on G6
weight welcoming the night to a lesson
square of G3 let's just go around the
rest of the tournament hall for just a
quick second and let's just drop in yeah
this is very exciting because this is
once again I believe the same line that
we've been discussing like I think
transposed yeah no I think it's it's
true yeah F3 the very early
transposition of F3 English B3 right and
now we're back in the territory where
all of those very exciting uh Dominguez
mvl games have happened exactly the one
that I think won the prize last year and
the the one that they drew I believe in
Rapid that wasn't the Bliss it was a
rapid I'm pretty sure because the real
at some point had time to think in that
game he said it couldn't have been in
this game uh so mvl continues to defend
this perimeter uh saying that he does
not believe that he is worse here uh I
think uh yeah Queen E4 sorry Queen A4
Bishop D3 beat takes C4 has has been
played in I believe both of those games
and then Queen or G6
and uh great news everybody we Rejoice
Alejandro you're back your board's
working yeah we had a couple of
technical glitches there but we do have
our boards working and this is good
because we have this very theoretically
heavy line my question is what is favi's
New Idea going to be here because
it seems like one of those positions
that you can kind of work out and what
we're going to be wondering is where
exactly is he going to deviate you guys
were mentioning this incredibly
important game between Dominguez that
they just played it so where is Favi
going to find a new idea because for the
moment I still expect Maxim to play them
with Queen A4 and transpose back into
exactly those positions well Dominguez
has played this three times in the last
year and a half surely mvl knows uh of
two of them because he played it he
probably also saw that game live in
Zagreb between Dominguez and sarich so
he must be one of the best verse persons
in this particular line I'm curious to
see where team five has found a new idea
here all right we're keeping a close eye
on that yeah and an interesting yeah I'm
glad you're bringing this one this one
up versus Wesley so because it's a
curious one specifically because I mean
it's the most topical line of the
Catalan right now the the mainline
catline with detail xc4 twin C2 B5 dg5
takes uh C4 the so-called open Catalan
yeah Queen City and uh Wesley in in the
past I think was more of an ACX player
in this position absolutely but but B5
is of course the move to make uh uh like
in in the last I don't know a year two
years and the interesting thing about
this position is that Wesley has just
beaten young in this line in Bucharest I
believe for the white pieces with the
wires with the white pieces which is
which is always kind of funny when
people play the exact same very very
specific subline of the same hope not
just the same opening with colors but
the exact same subline of an opening
against each other within like half a
year of you know less than half a year
between the two games Jan also had this
against uh uh Hikaru Nakamura in the I
believe yeah this was their game in the
rapid and Blitz this is the whole Queen
A4 Queen A1 game yeah that was uh which
Wesley doubtlessly was watching I think
it was from here at least yeah
and because now I'm kind of wondering
how did the queen get to A4 yeah it was
some maybe it was Bishop E4 no I think
it started with Bishop D5 we'll get uh
Alejandro in here to tell us uh what the
databases uh tell us uh you know are the
winning I feel I feel very ashamed that
I can't remember the exact move order
but yeah the queen definitely went to A1
and I'm trying to reconstruct how he
could have gone to E1 A1 and I'm not
entirely sure but it it should have been
from this line because it normally is
help us out Alejandro
wasn't that with the with btx A6 instead
of Knight C3 or am I misremembering
that is you're not being helpful
thank you thank you guys let me show you
the spot there yeah my database doesn't
have rapid games included so yeah that's
the problem here and yeah I'm I'm going
to try and investigate because yeah I
obviously cannot rely on my memory at
the best of times and today really does
not seem to be the best of times uh no
it's not I see you're loading and again
for those of you joining us late shame
on you but a huge breaking news in the
world of Chess as we uh tell you that
Magnus Carlson has withdrawn not just
forfeited and lost his gamer today but
he has withdrawn from the sinkhole cup
his results are annulled the games he
played will be rated uh but this is just
completely stopped
ourselves as we yeah we are now we're
learning how to breathe here because
yeah this was not the the expected start
to the show today for sure not the
broadcast I was expecting that's for
sure
um by the way one thing I I find
intriguing between Jan and Wesley is
that Jan actually has a very poor score
with Wesley Wesley somehow has his
number I think it probably is from here
by the way I think it's 96 Queen A4 97
very simply I think we get there I will
I mean sure 97 93 96 Queen A1 I think
this is how we get to that position and
that once again this was the game that
uh Jan played against
that still doesn't work
yeah our questions is uh well let's see
what happened go ahead uh
ih4 okay so Queen A4 here and after 97
young Queen
yeah the car in position Rook d196 Queen
if already on the board uh Hikaru played
97 here yes and Jan replied to it with
H4 first ah H4 first well first Knight
B6 Queen A1 this is how we get there and
again this was from their their duel in
the Rapids portion of the St Louis rapid
and Blitz just and the final outcome was
it it was a draw but yeah it was
borderline winning out of the opening
with himself yeah he was he was
incredibly unhappy because yeah he got
he got an important novelty and and got
a very very good position against a very
strong player and then failed to
capitalize and this is one of the worst
feelings in chess actually yes when you
have an important interesting new idea
in a very topical line you actually get
to show it in a tournament that matters
against an opponent that matters right
and then you don't win anyway I know
this is this is a very very uh
unpleasant feeling for for chess player
and there we have on-screen nepo appears
to be staring off into the empty space
trying to recall his variations but I'd
like to turn it over to Alejandro who's
been keeping a careful eye on the Lanier
versus a Fabi uh pardon me the Fabi
versus mvl duel
well it looked like a linear
gameplay
this is probably against fbl and we
finally have the new idea at least in a
human game this move Rook C1 was
actually very logical it has been played
before in corresponding games quite a
bit of course all every single one of
those correspondence games ended in a
draw but that's because well and just
are pretty good at chess there is some
Firepower to this move Rook C1 which is
very logical it depends upon that black
just threatened it also moves The Rook
out of the reach of the queen here on A4
so that for example on Rook C5 which is
one of the best moves the queen can go
either to E4 or if you want to play like
an engine play Queen B7 and hit the
bishop it asks exactly where it goes and
this could be a very relevant line uh
Bishop d8 is a bit unpleasant just
because uh the bishop is not
particularly well placed there and after
Bishop D3 we get very similar variations
to the main line the one without Rook C1
except that after B takes E4 again this
idea of Queen E4 attacking both H7 and
here I can regain C4 in certain
circumstances I don't have to do so
immediately but uh White should be a
little bit better and actually after
Rook C5 I was mentioning the other
possibility is to go Queen E4 hit the
Bishop from this side and then prepare
Bishop D3 directly and this is exactly
what happened in the game Rook C5 was
played Queen E4 was played and even
though rookie 5 is certainly playable
because the engine prefers rookie 8 and
I expect mvl to be very well versed in
this line nobody plays Rook C5 so
quickly unless you're just remembering
your variations I expect rookie 8 to be
played after which play might continue
Bishop D3 hitting the pawn on H7 no
choice here but to play the move G6 and
then we'll see if you take on B5 which
doesn't seem to me like the most
ambitious idea or rather just snapped
the pawn on F4 if you play H5 uh there
is this move for rookie five but perhaps
this is another way of keeping the
tension up unfortunately for white
there's not great squares for the queen
in this in the scenario because after
Queen takes F4 here you have Bishop
takes G5 now to the pawn on H4 is not
defending this Pawn on G5 this is the
point of Rook E5 and after rookie five
the queen would have to go somewhere in
the queen said the engine's saying that
perhaps the move Queen B7 still promises
some chances for an advantage for white
you are still attacking on the queen set
B takes C4 brings my Bishop closer to
the attack lots of intrigue in this
night off always fun to see this little
nuances that create our positions for
these players to play and you know that
Fabiano is an expert on this he likes to
work with a team of seconds that is
heavy in theory That's Heavy in finding
uh theoretical Novelties from
correspondence games and this one
doesn't seem to be an exception
thank you Alejandro for that indeed I'm
trying to get into the mind of Fabi for
just a second here Peter yes Queen takes
F4 I regain the pawn but I'm looking at
this I'm expecting to move Rook E8 just
as Alejandra suggests that's the engine
theoretically recommended moved by the
engine and I'm thinking if I'm Fabby I'm
seeing this pin down the e-file and if I
don't believe that h4ever is going to
get your checkmated how about rookie one
well there's always rookie five right I
think that's pretty much Queen 61
degrees yes
that was the forcing line but there is a
problem
exactly yeah okay so this this will
probably get us nowhere because of this
terrible and you have to continue for
one more move yeah rookie four will
maybe give white a winning Advantage if
not for the fact that the 65 exists
because if the buoyancy Force survives
the bishop on D3 continues restricted on
the other hand if that Bishop would have
gotten to the C4 Square exactly black
pretty much resigns because yeah it gets
to Z3 and then the F7 for Pawn Falls and
uh and so on so Queen C6
yeah then we just passed for a second
because again there's this kind of
temporary tactical Nuance you can't
really move and I don't think you want
to pull my Bishop to here now on the
other hand Bishop G7 that's the moment
there will be a check on the A8 right so
I need that I need a useful move here
for black my initial reaction was I want
to play Queen before but that also
allows to intake C8 because the Rook 28
will not be hanging after we after we
take everything on E8 okay uh I beat hc4
no longer wins me any attempting
precisely I do have Queen D2 here which
is sort of awkward but I'm much less
happy about this because let's say even
let's perform exactly right with the
bishop on the Fate Bend and Bishop G7
even unavailable now and unavailable for
the foreseeable actually I am I am
extremely worried that the bishop might
actually get to C4 right yeah this is a
very interesting continuation I'm trying
to guess where fabby's uh prep might
might lie and I thought it might be here
this the the the e-file I'm also
somewhat curious I uh I was perhaps not
paying enough attention I don't know if
Alejandra explained why rookie 8 is so
much more precise than the immediate
rookie 5. I guess you just feel that
rookie 8 is always going to be a useful
move and rookie 5 might not be a useful
move in some positions but since the F4
Pawn appears to be falling anyway why
are we why are we not playing rookie 5
straight away I guess why just takes on
a four and I think the larger point
there is that maybe uh not maybe
certainly the bishop 27 is very poorly
placed it needs to be on the long
diagonal truly so we are actually making
a serious argument that rookie 8 is
maybe a more integral part of our
planning here than rookie five we will
play rookie 5 with Forest right but what
we actually want to be doing is playing
rookie eight followed it up hopefully
with G6 Bishop f8 Bishop G7 and once it
lands there then your queen then you're
in Clover yeah yeah exactly you're in
Clover exactly as we're speculating on
all of this uh Alejandro clearer web so
we Reinventing the wheel after rookie
eight has as those correspondence games
that you mentioned uh uh followed this
terrain yeah rookie eight uh
distribution D3 transposes into a bunch
of games the ones that get to this
position exactly there's only one game
did go rookie eight rookie 5D engine
doesn't like because as you said Queen
takes F4 is playable and the engines
just aren't liking this position for the
black side there's no exact reason like
for example after rookie 8 they just say
that Bishop D3 is super strong in this
position the idea being that if you play
G6 here yeah kind of unprompted you have
this move Queen H2 and then H5 and H
takes a G6 and unlike some of the other
variations with after H5 you don't have
Bishop takes G5 with Tempo so if you see
this variation after Queen E4 and play
rookie 8 First bishop D3 G6 yeah you're
kind of waiting for me to play H5 for
you to play Rook E5 because as I
mentioned then Queen takes F4 Bishop
thanks G5 hitting the Rook if you take
on F4 immediately I don't go like a move
like rookie 5 or anything like that we
go with Peter's plan you play Bishop f8
Bishop G7 and then put the bishop on the
correct diagonal so rookie five
encouraging the queen to take the pawn
on F4 is not good until you can take
your the pawn on G5 yourself
wonderful thank you for that indeed and
as far as our Rook E1 goes our idea of
rookie eight rookie one and queen C6 has
that been seen before in that one it
should be 3g6 uh yeah I mean there will
be more than three G6 and Rook H1 right
yes yeah it has never been seen the
engine doesn't think it's a bad idea uh
we see a line like rookie five Queen C6
and you mentioned Bishop C8 right it's
perfect
and rookie four yeah I thought maybe
rookie seven or rookie six yeah uh
rookie seven or rookies you can even
take only four the agents are saying
it's okay you have to think with the
bishop that's clear and then put the
other Rook on E5 defend this Pawn Rook
C5 maybe at some point yeah we thought
Bishop D5 might be scary here but I
guess the machine is just not worried
it's not worried it's one of many moves
actually Queen A5 seems to be okay
rookie 2 seems to be okay I can see
black gets just about enough counter
play in this position just to go through
a sample line this seems to be a
Perpetual somehow
check here check here check yeah it
seems like a perfect natural right yeah
I will believe that
um so a lot to calculate when you don't
know the variation but it seems like
Black's resources are just about okay I
do love how white can try a bunch of
moves and they all seem a little bit
dangerous Rook H1 or you could play H5
you can play Queen to B7 and they all
have a little bit of poison there
lovely thank you for that Alejandro I
did forgot about Rook takes B2 yeah
Bishop G7 is so important that black
suddenly develops a lot of counter play
and one game one game we've completely
ignored so far is the actually well not
ignored completely but we've it's it's
updated somewhat since move four uh this
is a kind of a slow based Italian here
between uh Hans and alireza where uh
Hans is playing in the
I would say that although Bishop B6 is a
somewhat rare move once again every time
I have to talk about the uh the all the
Joker piano move orders I feel like a
complete uh you know uh imposter
syndrome is strong with this yeah
my my brain's turn to Mush too uh trying
to explain why Asic sometimes they play
Asics and then
and this is what I I opened my mouth to
say that I'm surprised Hans played A4
and allowed a seven and five A5 in one
tempo but that's with the bishop already
on B6 so black at least invested the
tempo in Bishop B6 provoking a four
quote unquote provoking before A4
uh but generally speaking you you I
think with black you enjoy uh having the
pawns on A4 and A5 when you only spent
one tempo on A5 right and uh the bishop
B6 will generally get rerouted to C7 you
play C6 you play Bishop C7 you start
pushing for d65. everybody's trying to
make the central break suddenly yeah and
uh these positions are I think generally
very very close to to being dynamically
equal but they are very intricate
because if if one side actually manages
to you know uh assume Primacy in the
center like get get g65 or d3d4 uh from
the white side and prevent the counter
break exactly you do get a very pleasant
spatial spatial Edge and those positions
aren't always very easily equalizable
let's jump to Alejandro and he can bring
us up to date on the theory of this
position Alejandra only a few gays have
reached this position but one of them is
pretty high level like Huang Liam
playing against a Shakira Madeira who
had no game today tamashesky also
depending on the black side of this one
it does seem that black has good chances
for equalizing and you guys went through
most of the correct ideas here the games
that have reached this position have
both gone Bishop B3 or even all the way
to Bishop A2 but I have the feeling that
in this particular Italian Black's doing
okay D4 played seems to be the number
novelty of the game the engines at least
my kind of weak engine says that after
takes on D4 takes on D4 and either D5
which is a very typical break in this
kind of position especially with the
Knight on A3 as opposed to C3 where it
pressures the D5 Square you would have
to consider both e takes D5 Knight E
takes D5 which to me at first glance
looks like the better version of this
isolated pawns for the black side better
version again because this Knight seems
to be slightly off place from where it
usually should be I have to watch out
for Queen B3 ideas but I don't think
they're that scary at this position or
after it takes D5 go E5 and as I'm
explaining all of these things other SSS
I'm not interested in any of that
immediately place the move Knight G6
ring forcing the defense of the pattern
E5 also a very typical way of dealing
with the D4 break and challenging white
to find a move now that you have to move
d4 sometimes you can Retreat the bishop
on this diagonal instead of this
diagonal while you're retreating the
bishop because this Knight on A3 is the
one that goes to wants to go to C4
especially after you've played the move
d4 it has to be time proper properly
because as we've mentioned Pawn takes
Pawn takes D5 breaks exist also
sacrifices on e4 followed by D5 exist so
it's going to be very Tempo dependent
but alireza seems to be familiar with
what he's doing Knight G6 played on the
board relatively quickly absolutely and
thank you for that now
uh we started our show with our current
standings we're gonna update our current
standings and for those who are you
joining is light shame on you but we do
have breaking news as world champion
Magnus Carlsen has forfeited this game
and withdrawn from the tournament
I will have to ask our Graphics
Department I was going to say yeah we
need an asterisk on the people no you
can keep the standings up actually I do
want to see them yeah it's a good
graphic it's a good graphic but we do
need an asterisk on the people that I've
already played the three games the three
games against Magnus Carlsen because
those don't count I believe that Tiana
polonyachi Hans Neiman and well
obviously Shakura mamadiarov right and
why am I missing one
I don't think it impacts it impacts
shark because that already is a non-game
I don't think Shaq got the point from
today but yeah we we sort of like some
of those people play two games now that
Magnus has withdrawn and some and some
something played three uh so uh but the
standings are as follows with uh you
know it's still Vizio yeah still a kind
of a quirky situation where uh the field
is on an equal number of games in some
cases exactly that's exactly what is
going on some people have played uh
we'll have a free day coming up yes yes
like Shack rear has had a free day today
Lavon aronian uh with a single draw that
looks so strange well a single draw out
of two games yeah exactly not out of
three yeah
and uh Knight G6 was played very quickly
in the game between uh Ali raise and
Hansen even and for me the bishop has
always been nice on the A2 diagonal
Peter but listening to Alejandro
Alejandro is making the point that the
bishop can withdraw to E3 and even to F1
why would White Water withdraw as Bishop
on F1 uh well I think it's it's twofold
first you are actually getting it out of
the way
finished guys
and Wesley so found a repetition early
on and that game is over we have three
games left yeah what is going on here
Wesley Wesley showed I think a very kind
of Cutting Edge equality against the
idea that uh Jan came with and it
involves a peace sacrifice as well so
it's not it's not that easy uh What uh
requester shows so again up until this
moment Knight D7 was was it h2h4 before
Queen A4 no it was 97 H4 yeah and
instead instead Wesley goes Queen B
deviating from hikaru's play in that
game okay Jan plays Knight C3 Queen B6
understandable protecting protecting his
pieces E3 is also a very logical move
protecting the pawn on D4 because of
course because we have Wesley on the
screen before we continue the analysis
yeah Wesley looks like a easy day at the
office for him yeah and as you can see
there are the the improved uh have
somewhat enhanced security measures are
now also including uh perhaps sort of
random checks after games which
definitely wasn't the case yesterday
yeah uh these are these are new new
protocols in place
and that is our International Arbiter
David saturate had called for these
increased protocols as you say yes
Knight E5 it looks like white is
achieving a lot of progress this year
because if you if you take only five
your position just collapses the pawn on
D5 will fall and here comes this very
very beautiful tactical option from from
Wesley which I'm sure both of them
actually knew about I'm pretty sure that
Jan was just kind of hoping this will
not get shown on the board
visual move yeah sorry and it's just so
stunning because uh if you take on A7
the endgame is just not better for white
at all because there's this Pawn on B2
which is kind of backward and it's
difficult to like there's a lot of
pressure against it already and the
black structure is very very solid the
bishop on C1 is very passive so that's
not very attractive if you go back to
situ you'll give black attractive
opportunities as well so you take on C6
go back to C2 yeah like before I would
assume when that comes Bishop D6 and
yeah you've really solved a lot of your
problems but Queen takes C6 would be six
and your queen is caught and even more
interestingly as you will see in the
game you can maybe even rescue it but
that doesn't help either uh because one
thing that was I was curious about there
you can play Bishop D5 here which seems
very strong for a second exactly because
after you get a pawn yeah okay after
after Bishops after Rook C6 Knight C6 I
thought we win the seven Bishop with
check but I guess Queen A4 is very
strong here that would be my
understanding we need for 97 king of
fate and suddenly white has a bunch of
pieces hanging on the board like Devon
is hanging E7 is hanging what is this
because
yeah Bishops
uh how many pawns before my taxi for
them yeah and then a five and I can't
work is completely fine okay so Bishop
D2 as you said yeah maybe Knight E4 here
I'm the the thing about this position is
that if you don't know what's happening
it might be interesting for a second
from the White's perspective because
right if you do somehow establish
control if I don't know if you're
exactly if you get time to play [ __ ] P1
Rook C1 Bush B2 perhaps start pushing
the pressure on the C4 Pawn right but
I'm assuming both of them just know it
doesn't work like something like Knight
G5 here followed by Queen C2 or
something it might just be extremely
painful an initiative uh suddenly on
blacksided and uh you know when you know
the answer you're just not going to
entertain those kind of gambly
possibilities and and Hyun made a very
cute move as well he played after V6 the
move B2 B3 seemingly creating the threat
of Queen A4 and also if you take on C6
now there is there is no Queen A4
meaning that we can take on C6 take only
seven and be reasonably happy about
things make sense yeah and then and then
came the stunning the really visually
very stunning move by black hello
hello you think your queen is getting
away no
and this is the repetition and this is
the repetition I'm my feeling is both of
them actually knew this is a draw right
but from yarn side first of all Wesley
as I mentioned is not really a Quincy to
be five player yeah at least not every
single time and secondly perhaps he
hasn't looked at this position as as
in-depth as
uh as he could have done but now today
it's one of those games you occasionally
see in very very strong tournaments
where uh a player with the white pieces
comes to the board with a question the
question gets answered exactly as it's
supposed to be answered and everybody
goes home remarkable remarkable drive it
strongly reminds me of a piece of advice
I got when I had just gotten my
Grandmaster title from Grandmaster
Michael Steen he said yes sir pay
attention to those quick draws
you'll learn something there's something
and this is a quick draw no it
definitely had content very interesting
game it's you know it it progressed the
theory of the Scotland a step further
right and sort of publicized something
which I assume a bunch of top players
would have known right but now it's out
in the open and okay I guess this
chapter perhaps can be closed because
now black has once again showed that
this line is just very solidly holding
so I'm I'm just you know I suspect that
it will not get you know profit by the
white Scotland players again like
something else will become the the focus
will will will shift a little bit to
something else those Grandmaster garage
Alejandro uh with two results uh in the
history books what have you been oh it's
called your eye well this one is
definitely going to keep catching my eye
the game between Fabiano caruana and
Maxima Sherlock because Maxine decided
to very quickly play this move Rook E5
without first stopping by the move
rookie which honestly looks quite human
Queen takes F4 was played quickly by
Fabi and then a very unexpected move I
did expect something like rookie in
anyways the engine was throwing the move
Bishop d8 to improve the bishop somehow
awesome so fond of that one but I didn't
even consider this move F6 on the board
by vaccine by Sherlock a little feisty
you're trying to open up positions for
the Rook on f8 for especially for the
bishop on E7 you actually want to open
up the king side but hold on your King's
on the king so yeah right this king's
not on the king side who's benefited
from opening the king size especially
the light squares that are now alike
swiss cheese for this bishop on F1 it
seems a little sauce to me the computers
think it's just bad we'll see how it
progresses uh you don't want to play
Bishop D3 and give on g5s just so easily
then just don't think this is bad for
white but they don't see the reason to
do it right away it does require a lot
of calculation even this after Queen D4
the engines are starting to warm up to
my Pawn sacrifice but you don't have to
do it you can just Retreat the queen to
D2 if you take on G5 well I'll just take
back you cannot take on G5 while you can
but after Queen takes D6 white seems to
be a little bit faster than black
because this Rook is hanging in Bishop
D3 is coming with an important Tempo and
this queen is currently a little bit
offside from where it really wants to be
you may might be wondering what happens
if I take uh here yes Queen takes E5 is
fine but even stronger this move Bishop
D3 attacks this Rook you can imagine
that Bishop takes H7 is absolutely
lethal you can't tell out that move
especially with the bishop on C1 hanging
so you won't have enough time to defend
that record E5 to show the audience
Bishop F4 for example is made in four
Bishop takes check king of seven check
here and after Rook Hade here Queen
takes a f8 is just an example of how
dangerous White's attack can be on the
light squares because I was allowed to
play Bishop D3 takes H7 and you don't
even have an F Pawn to cover any of
those positions Queen D2 is one way the
engine is also very adamant about the
move Queen D4 take on G5 and then just
take on G5 completely winning for white
is what they say [ __ ]
Bishop D3 giving plus five no way to
defend this position the queen is just
too far offside and again you want a
pawn congratulations but as what did
Fisher say yes sir about this uh he
spawns on the king side considering it
was the exact mate
that's it that's it and as we prepare
for an early break again the breaking
news has been that Magnus Carlson world
champion Magnus Carlson has withdrawn
from the sinful cup but before we go on
a break you've got to tell our audience
what they can get absolutely Boutique
and Peter today is a new item every day
is a new item but this is a GCT women's
card and cardigan and Justin men's
jacket uh super soft women's great
pocketed cardigan features the GST logo
on the bottom left pocket or a
lightweight cotton zip up a gray jacket
with buckets which also features the GC
uh uh logo on the front left and as is
everything else all of these items are
available at
cubicstl.com I can tell you women's
Grandmaster Catherine in them Silva
absolutely loves her cardigan it's yours
we'll see you on the other side of the
brink
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
[Music]
you may have heard about St Louis's
world-class Museums Art History Science
even Magic
but you may not know we have an entire
Museum dedicated to play with a 10 story
slide and a ferris wheel on top
don't let all this family fun Slide by
you
who's kids it is St Lou is always
exploring anybody
[Music]
we're the Corey family Welcome to our
show
[Music]
you guys gonna see this
is our show now go start yours
[Music]
St Louis University celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of St Louis SLU
attracts students and professors from
around the globe
in 2015 slew partnered with the St Louis
chess club to start a top-tiered
Collegiate chess team on the very first
year of the team's Inception slew
obtained second best university at the
Pan-American Intercollegiate chess
championships
higher purpose greater good
St Louis University
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to day four of the
singfield cup and the Very turbulent
date has been so far but indeed there's
still a very interesting chess in
progress to which we will get back to in
a moment but for now we have two uh
games uh results already known Peter
let's take a look at where we stand we
have five results but one was a forfeit
Peter yes and that one uh we no longer
even see on our screens Magnus Carlson
if you have not been watching any chess
news at all in the last hour and a bit
has withdrawn from the singfield cup
effective immediately starting from this
round so his game against rachem and
jarov will not count and also his
previous three will not count for the
singfield cup and the only promise she
Drew uh a very quick but a very
important theoretically game in the
Catalan against Wesley so that's the
other result of the base so far quite
topical and of course now what are these
nine players uh going to be fighting for
Peter
uh the price founder as you can see uh
this this graphic uh is is still the
same as it as it ever was right uh with
Magnus I assume just taking the taking
the the last prize I don't know what the
arrangement there will be I wouldn't
want to speculate this is all very very
Uncharted Territory for I think pretty
much everyone here uh but in general
this is a very very uh lucrative tour as
you can see with a hundred thousand
dollars for the winners for the winner
and the 350 000 total price fund for uh
the classical events in the GCT and in
this event we are very fortunate to have
the sport once again of Brian take us
through the brilliancy prize Peter
absolutely uh we are very grateful uh to
the support and uh generosity of prime
minister of Key West Florida who uh for
at least the second year running I
believe it is a second year right
exactly is providing an additional five
thousand dollar prize for the best game
of the tournament uh which will be
judged by ourselves your commentators
here yeah uh yes sir Alejandro Anastasia
and myself there are some early Front
Runners but there is still a long
tournament to go too too early to say
how this will come out absolutely and
turning it over to you Alejandra what
has caught your eye of the three
remaining games
sure we'll get back to to Alejandro I
wanted to ask you quickly about the Fabi
game because Fabby could have played
Bishop D3 Queen D4 Queen D2 all of those
moves but he chose one that to my eyes
looks really good as well Peter yes I
think H2 and and during the break we
were discussing uh
apologies this position a little bit
among ourselves and yes rookie 556 looks
extremely dangerous and also as we know
from checking with engines it's just
wrong you can in positions like this the
engines very rarely are incorrect about
assessments because it's just a very
sharp very concrete position but but if
you don't know the answer and Fabi
probably doesn't know the answer simply
because rookie 5 and F6 is not the right
reaction so you don't you don't really
check those moves as carefully as you
would have checked uh the best play for
black after Queen E4 he doesn't know the
answer he knows he's probably better but
uh the moves that Alejandro was showing
24 Queen G2 Bishop D3 to an extent they
all have one thing in common you
completely ignore the fact that the G5
Pawn is hanging you are offering it up
and then you just you end up attacking
yeah you end up giving mate as as we
know but he doesn't right and for him uh
I think the move Queen H2 is extremely
logical because you're saying yeah you
can take on G5 if you want but H7 will
be the hanging straight away straight no
waiting no wait no waiting we get there
we get there instantly on the turn and
uh
it's a it's a problematic position for
black as a kind of a Counterpoint I will
say that with the queen on the D file
black would not have had an opportunity
right now to play B takes E4 and D6 D5
Maybe
but I hate that I hate that too I hate
that I don't know like this is a this is
a point of difference because the queen
on H2 doesn't control the D5 square
right but developing the white Bishop
from F1 to B3 that looks suicide I'm not
I'm not unhappy about this why and the
other point with the move Queen H2 is it
kind of perhaps F3 F4 yeah all of those
all of those makes the whole issue of F7
F6 questionable Alejandra we think this
move Queen H2 is a really good move over
to you well the position is this bad you
can have many moves that are good guys
and queen H2 is just one of them as ugly
as it looks B takes E4 according to the
engine is the best move in this position
but what else because otherwise I'm
playing Bishop D3 and you need to find a
useful move that helps your position
retreating the queen doesn't really help
your position because where are you
retreating it to the rook's already as
good as it gets on E5 you might as well
wait for me to play F4 and kick it out
you cannot take you just cannot you
can't do this right H7 is indefensible
right so how do you improve your works
like if you play a move like rookie 8
I'll either kick you out or play the
move simply Bishop D3 I'll slowly start
pressuring your opponent H7 and it'll be
very difficult to defend imagine this
queen was not on A4 and I played them
with Queen C2 that might already end the
game right because H6 creates too many
weaknesses G6 will be met with H5 and
where is the black counter play let's
say that we put the Rook on a slightly
let's call it more active role I don't
know maybe it's on the B file maybe I'll
sacrifice it on B2 then just really
don't care they play Bishop D3 anyway
and they're still saying try to find a
good move here for black at some point
that'll actually take on B5 and open up
my Rook to the seventh rank uh via C7
right terrible position for mvl I think
he didn't quite grasp how difficult this
position would be after F6 based on any
queen move even the move Bishop D3 was
dangerous but any queen move that
prevented F takes G5 with the tempo is
seemingly just too dangerous for his
position
thank you for that uh one position I'm
sorry but for me I really don't like
lavon's plate whatsoever in this
position in this game I think that you
know for for for the way I play chess
the way my Approach for in the game uh
is concerned
I just love everything there is to love
about Lanier's position your take am I
wrong I don't think you're necessarily
wrong I don't hate it I don't think
white has achieved much but I think he
is maintaining uh he's maintaining some
kind of like this is the kind of a game
he wanted to play today and I think in
that respect he shouldn't be very
disappointed with the outcome of the
opening because he got the position yeah
I don't think I don't think he is even
trying to lay claim to any kind of an
advantage he just says we have 32 pieces
on the board by pushing Ruby one before
B5 which is what he spent uh with three
times
in the past a little little while it
gains some space on the queen side it
also I wanted to say it perhaps stops
some of the counter play but linear is
actually trying to give the lie to that
statement right by just by playing a7a6
I like a7a6 by the way this is a good
move I think because now you're a bit
like you're in a bit of an awkward spot
as to as to what you're supposed to do
against it
and all like all of our options are are
a bit Yeah if we play A4 we go a b a b
Rook A8 and you start liking the
exposition I think a lot more because
it's it gets a bit it's very concrete it
gets a bit awkward yeah but maybe maybe
you can actually do this Mickey can play
Bishop B3 here for instance and say that
you don't really have that many squares
uh on your file if that's a passive
Bishop on B3 by the way this whole B2 B4
B5 weakened uh the uh yeah but I think
the three squared D5 D5 is incredibly
topical we're never taking it no of
course not you're never taking because
you do not want to see it might land on
your doors I'm not sure we're pretty
much always playing uh E5 in response
then I will have to go to E8 which is I
think is a good thing for white there's
just no other squares right and now the
big question is how we proceed here yeah
Bishop G5 is extremely logical right but
honestly because of the bishop on B3 is
so completely killed off in all of these
positions maybe I can actually play this
with black my initial reaction was this
is not going to be that great but if we
continue that line Bishop G5 I will play
F6 there's no other legal movement
exactly otherwise yeah if we'll take
with the bishop right we will invite you
to trade I will take maybe with the
queen even okay the knight from E8 like
ideally might even go to D6
yeah
is kind of bugging me a little bit I was
gonna Force the night to go yeah I think
it's clever yeah but still like with
that Bishop somewhere in the game the
one that is on B3 if that Bishop was on
any kind of a sensible Square F1 yeah
you you I think you'd be a lot happier
here with white exactly right now just
yeah it's a very it's a very strange
position with a very unusual uh bone
structure and the other thing that I'd
like when I'm black in such positions is
to play the movie five and uh so that
when I do play the move D5 you do not
answer yeah this is this is very
concrete because obviously you could
maybe shut the position down yeah
absolutely this exists also you you do
have to calculate uh sort of Tempo by
Tempo if perhaps I can uh control in the
center by maybe I'm in time with like
Knight F1 E3
and stopping like after you play five ah
sorry maybe I can find a way to play
night of funny three before you play 65
but the 65 is coming very quickly so I
don't know I don't know if I do have
time for that
okay well definitely keep uh yeah this
one a6a4 in the meantime has already
been played so we we I think we are
assume we're getting here at least eight
Bishop B3 looks very very logical and
then we'll have to uh discuss and again
um uh Bobby uh enjoying what we think is
simply a tremendous advantage and uh our
youths are hard at work uh intriguing
moment for me right here was this moment
when uh Hans captured on E5 D4 takes E5
and almost well I'm not going to say
immediately immediately but rather
quickly Knight G6 uh recaptured on E5 I
always thought that the night was
heading for uh F4 and explain to our
audience Peter why Ali Raza was so happy
or quick to capture I think I think the
point here is uh
and this sort of ties in with something
we were about to discuss and then didn't
because other things came up right you
were sort of asking uh or maybe not
asking but saying like why why is the
bishop retreating to let's say D3 on
particular F1 right in all of these
positions I think it is two very very
efficiently blunt all of those types of
counter play with like 9604 or Knight H5
1996 H5 F4 because with a bishop on F1
all of those things are kind of empty
they don't really do very much
and uh if you look at let's say here uh
and Magnus has been very much a
proponent of this approach I don't know
if we can do it immediately but even if
we look at these end games my problem
here is that the only four is hanging
but let's make some random modes like
Bishop B3 oh sorry
exactly what what you're doing yeah GED
uh Queen G8 and actually I can make a
move I wanted to make I'll play [ __ ] B3
here because Knight E4 loses to Bishop
B6 and that's a cute tactic by the way
yeah because now we understand why the
bishop also controls A6 in case of a
trade so you can't take only before you
play I guess Bishop P6 right and I play
Knight fg2 and then I I want to play for
B2 before and just gaining space on the
queen side these types of end games are
not off are not always entirely equal
they they have been known to rather
quickly become unpleasant for black
because you have those you have those
nights sort of stuck on the king side
not doing very much and if you compare
this position with let's say we take
only five as a residue with the Knight
on E5 on move 14 right right
and white does the same you go neither
three take C5 I apologize yep uh we go
GE yeah
okay and now we traded off one pair of
knights I think I think black is happier
here than in the previous position
because I think the the addition of
knights on F3 and G6 should be in
White's favorite and in my understanding
uh and I think this one is easier easier
to manage for uh for the black side we
didn't see in fact see that Hans wasn't
eager to capture on E5 but did play
instead to move Bishop F4 we saw a trade
and now we have uh D5 and again you're
just kind of knee-jerk reaction uh Ali
Reza looks like he's equalized
yeah the bishop on C8 is still more
passive than the bishop on F1 in some
positions like if we just go like in the
most natural fashion we take on C7 take
on D5 right I assume you take with the
Knight because the the isolating
position doesn't look doesn't appeal
doesn't look that great and here we play
um
I want to play Bishop D3 somewhere but I
don't know if it's immediately necessary
like okay Bishop D3 yeah it's not much
but sometimes it's a little bit of
something like it's a uh it's a kind of
a position where you still perhaps have
to show some Precision although of
course obviously if black does manage to
let's say Play Bishop B6 rook ae8 and
nothing bad has happened to them uh in
the meantime right yeah yeah the margins
are incredibly small I haven't killed
you on the king side either with
something as Brute Force direct as Rook
H5 but yeah okay we can start trading
here but like Bishop D7 I would guess
right just start slowly getting stuff
off the board because the structure is
very very solid like structurally we
have nothing to worry about oops but
yeah we'll see we'll see what Hans
thinks about this because there are also
maybe some sharper options available
along the way and let's invite Alejandro
into our discussion uh by the way after
D5 no trades on C7
D1 immediately uh as a Hans achieved an
advantage of any
uh sort Alejandro I think the jury's
still out there the engines are giving
between a 0.3 and 0.4 Edge but that's
more or less what Peter's saying right
it's not fully equal but it could get
there very soon Rook D1 a very logical
move as you are pinning the pawn against
the queen it's of course the top engine
move as well it's I think much more
direct than taking on D5 or taking on C7
simply because it keeps the tension in
the position the force is white uh sorry
black to make a couple of choices first
for example a move like Bishop P6
doesn't force me to take on D5 just yet
with actually only encourages your
knight to jump into the center here are
the move Queen G3 is possible according
to the engine Rook D4 is possible but I
would expect uh instead for alireza to
take first on F4 take on F4 and then
play Bishop E6 uh somehow I found this a
little bit more human and on take on D5
you can take with the Knight hit the
bishop directly you're also preparing to
play them with Queen B8 and get out of
the pin that way threaten the exchange
of Queens the engines think it's a
little bit better for white but the most
are a little unnatural playing Knight D6
is a bit unnatural in my opinion the
Knight might get is caught in the wrong
spot even the move Rook D4 which is one
of the top engine moves it doesn't look
super easy for me to find the move Rook
before there's so many other moves in
this position that I would consider uh
so this is the current situation after
Rook D1 basically alireza has a choice
of what they're taking on F4 first or
playing Bishop V6 first hard for me to
imagine any other really logical Moves
In in this situation a quick question
for for you Alejandro could you give me
a number numerical count on the Lavon
versus linear position because to my way
of thinking I just much prefer Black's
position
I've actually got a little curious on
why you say that yesterday I saw you
analyze this position with Peter I
understand some of your reasonings but
at the end of the day white does have
space it's the white is pretty solid in
this position perhaps you could argue
that Black's more flexible uh but I
don't think I would prefer black that
much the engine does agree with you
slightly it gives between 0.21.3 so
minus 0.2 or 0.3 okay so it does prefer
black is like a little little tiny bit
but uh I guess uh you know you can see a
little pinch I can do something with it
you know okay very good uh thank you for
that and again uh since we saw the move
Queen H2
Maxine is beginning to realize that life
is not that easy uh Peter yeah it's a
difficult position to play and uh you
know uh I'm sure he's not enjoying this
uh I don't know if he realized by this
point that you know it could have gone
even worse right but even this position
is just uh very very unfun for black
because your issue is Once after hg5 has
been sort of taking off the board and it
has been taken off the board because as
Alejandro and and we are you continually
pointed out we want to open up the H
file yeah you don't want to be playing
into uh into the attack there by uh by
taking but if uh if you can't take on G5
your previous play makes very very
little sense and F3 F4 Alejandro is
saying Bishop D3 is the largest threat
but I would argue that even the very
simple F3 F4 followed by like where does
The Rook go if it goes to E3 I can play
Queen G2 and continue chasing it and it
once again will not have good squares
let me take a stab at it I I don't like
it for mvl but let's just uh yeah I want
to switch I want to go with four here
what is attempt to go for you yeah let
me just switch oh three three that's
gonna hurt yeah yeah why have we played
FC like people you keep on returning to
the fact that we played we played F6
voluntarily yeah I want to play F6 F7
exactly yeah oh dear oh dear oh dear
okay let me try it on purpose let me try
it again let me try Rook E5 to uh C5 I I
want to take obviously I understand yeah
I'm curious if Queen E2 is not just
winning on the spot for instance like
Queen E2 I mean you have rookie five
sorry I'm losing my mind you can you can
actually go back and then I mean it's
very good for why he has played Rook C5
by the way you did manage to guess so at
least guess at what he will eventually
settle on potentially it looks horrible
no disrespect to your move but it is it
still looks horrible I don't want to
claim it how dare you offend me by going
it is my move yeah uh rookie pie of
course what I'm Dreaming uh is that you
would allow me some type of play which
you would never ever allow yes this is
of course yeah Rook C8 as well maybe
made in like five there exactly let's
not go there I mean the funny thing is I
suspect at least part of the solution
here for white might actually be 22
rookie five and then a better Square for
the queen which you know what it is it's
Queen D2 yeah
we even know the solution uh but since
he's already not played Queen D2 once
right it might not be such an easy
decision for for 5B although you can
take it from the other side as well and
say that
he's sort of really being forced into it
now because he I think he understands he
is better yes he's definitely not
repeating right so if he doesn't find
anything stronger here he might play
Queen it too I think mvl blitzes out
rookie 5 and responds because everything
else does appear to be basically losing
on the spot exactly and after rookie
five five he will not play to H2 because
he's just come from there he will look
for a better square and he might just be
forced by events to to produce the best
move in the position because everything
else has been attempted exactly and
Peter uh would it be uh completely
vulnerable to suggest that F4 takes
Queen but I'm worried because I like I
really don't like the idea of allowing
uh anything I'm not entirely sure of
what but I'm I'm allowing something here
like Rook B8 maybe I'm allowing well E7
is saying yeah I know but I wanted to
maybe see if I can find some some mating
attacks on the green side Ruby 18 takes
E7 C3 or whatever it probably loses to
Rook H2 so I'm not expecting this to
work but uh right let's see oh C2 so I
can take twice yeah I have I have more
pieces yeah more pieces
and then we should count to be sure
right yeah uh okay uh I don't like this
but I mean F4 is a logical move I I
don't hate it at all I think I think we
generally just very much want to play
three or four but this is again the
computer uh
uh killer Yes but I think in a way it
might be easier to find Queen Zito now
because of that thing that I described
the basically like after Rook C5
if Queen E2 is sort of legitimately the
most obvious move and then you can
return to the question of whether maybe
I have better squares right
um we'll see we'll see how Fabi
approaches it his play in this
tournament has been uh uh sort of good
and patches and very shaky in fact he's
he played a very very nice game against
laneier and then failed to put it to bed
exactly and he showed you know
definitely played
decent chess yesterday in in parts of
the game put up as is very very usual
for him put up a very very Valiant
defense once he was in trouble but also
made some questionable decisions coming
out of the opening I would say uh so
yeah it would be excellent for him to to
actually get onto the scoreboard here
and uh yeah it's a kind of a position uh
that he generally would enjoy a great
deal but it does require Precision
little misfiring
um Alejandro by Fabi but nonetheless he
still has got is is he still has a
wonderful position well the guy knows a
little bit about Theory and in this
position I was playing around with it of
course you got the correct answer
Queenie 2 rookie five Queen D2 I don't
know if humans necessarily play like
that another good move in this position
is to play Queen D2 immediately since
that indirectly defends the pawn on C4
let me show the audience why take on C4
would be kind of silly here because
after Bishop takes C4 check you cannot
take on C4 because Queen D5 checks Fork
on the king and The Rook that just wins
the game so going to do immediately but
I was thinking why not Bishop H3 I like
my Bishop targeting the light squares
I'm not so sure that I'm worried about
despondency for because I thought I had
to move Rook he1 targeting the bishop on
E7 if you move it back in this
particular position you just lose to
some combination of Queen takes D6 or
Bishop E6 check first so you have to
find some moves that analyzes a little
bit with the engine it still thinks it's
dangerous for black it's not as bad as
some of the other lines we're looking at
because you at least got a pawn back but
I think 5V has more than one option to
put real pressure on Maxine's position
it might not be the most engine approved
variation but it might be very human to
just sacrifice the part of C4 in certain
variations now if he doesn't want to do
it he's definitely going to have to find
the move Queen D2 at some point either
before or after he plays Queen E2
because the otherwise well he has to
shed a pawn for it
thank you for that uh Alejandro and I
want to go again to uh the match-up uh
between the 19 year olds Hans and Ali
reason we did see the move Bishop E6 no
captures on F4 no captures on C7 and one
of the things I like about this move for
uh black actually Peter is
I'm not 100 sure my knight capturing on
D D5 was exactly Bishop takes looks very
legit so yeah I was wondering if perhaps
uh the engines were suggesting including
Bishop takes a four is important because
maybe in this position it is somehow
smarter than in some others to play 45
but e45 I think like just doesn't work
because of Knight D7 here very
specifically very specifically Knight D7
not 94. against 94 I found some idea and
promptly forgot what it was but I found
I found someone
nice 19 D7 because you are threatening
now in this case we haven't unpinned the
G5 Pawn right so the Knight is now
hanging and you would like to play 96
but I have 1965 straight away which this
is what it solves my Pro I mean yes I'm
a pulling up now my problems are
definitely very much solved right uh
black is just much better so it's not
that I wonder I wonder why honestly the
more I look at this the more I think I'm
curious whether the engines don't just
think black is fine right why isn't this
just entirely okay for black
well let's ask our resident
engine Chief
Alejandro why isn't black just fine I
think black is fine but the angels are
still giving this small small pull it's
one of two moves Rook D4 is one Rook D4
I know a little bit surprising wow it
makes E5 a little stronger since maybe
against 97 I will have opportunities of
taking on H6 there are several ways to
deal with this move one of them is incl
includes this craziness after Knight
takes E4
but you also have to contend with Queen
B8 as well with Queen E7 there's a lot
of moves to uh think about here and the
other move is Queen G3 which not very
logical to me because you're forcing
black to do something that they could
have done on the previous move and after
taking a new F4 here here Queen B8 this
is the best move according to the
engines takes takes because you have
this spot on A5 hanging I cannot use the
other Rook to take and then after Knight
B6 it's surprisingly awkward guys like
yeah I'm yeah I wouldn't be at all happy
with this with black I really don't want
my Rook on A7 the thing is the line
continues right because E4 is hanging
yeah because you're k6
whoa that's why I use an engine
Bishop takes Pawn takes surprisingly
traps this Knight on B6 and the engines
are saying zero zero in this complicated
wild end game at the end of course this
is anything but zero zero but it's one
of the many options and here after Queen
takes frame I was playing around with
the engine a little bit trying to find a
better move than Queen V8 because the
queen B8 going into that's not so easy
you have to see Rook A6 in advance you
or believe in the Mover K7 but what else
do you play because anything else gives
the engine says plus one and they don't
find a good Square for the queen they
don't see how to really get rid of this
pressure either on A5 or on D5 at some
point I might even consider going E5 and
start using my dark squares so maybe
Queen G3 is the most running position it
move in this position just to try to
force this bishop on C7 off the board uh
do you mind showing as the line that
Rook D4 Knight takes E4 and you call
that craziness what's the craziness
Earth takes E4 right okay if uh if you
take on e4 you lose to Rook takes d8
takes check and then Bishop on C7 will
be hanging okay so you cannot take
immediately you have to go C5 first
okay hit the rook and then you just move
the queen to B8 of course and the idea
the queen is still now out of the way so
you're actually hitting both pieces and
you kind of recover this with uh
fully uh rookie One D takes C4 the
engine is saying again
zero zero
there's compensation for the pawn but
not more than that now Rook D4 I think
it's a very difficult incredibly
difficult move to play so bg3 maybe not
as much and I don't imagine anything
else is too dangerous I mean you could
take on D5 but I think you can take with
the Knight the engine does prefer taking
with the Knight over than the Bishops
just so you cover B6 in certain cases
they think the bishop on D5 is slightly
overrated and Knight on F6 it's not
doing as much as it could in its Center
so Knight takes D5 is what the engines
prefer giving very close to equality but
again not full equality
remarkable I just love that move Rook A6
Peter I don't know
I realize aw Awakening experience there
that I didn't see that one coming so so
miscible absolutely yeah it would be
very interesting to see both the first
moves of the engine both Rook D4
is not
rubyfoy is a very difficult one yeah
that that move doesn't come it's very
very difficult and queen G3 too
optically I don't know uh is it because
I'm I'm dissuaded by Knight H5 which is
a terrible move but Queen G3 isn't also
one of those it's not it's not simple
but you can you can sort of start seeing
the reasoning because you uh like the
queen on G8 needs to be away from from
the X-ray on the G file Right Far and
Away the best Square for that Queen is
C7 right so by forcing blood to take on
F4 and establishing our own Queen on
this diagonal we're saying uh whatever
you do now you can't put the queen on
the best Square meaning that uh Knight
B6 ideas continue being present in the
position if you choose any other Square
you're you're still under some pressure
here right and uh yeah the fact that if
you don't play Queen B8 here you're just
in massive trouble I think is a very
much Testament to that but Queen B8 is
just such a difficult decision
correctly pointed out and here you can
play Rook a seven because if you don't
see Rook A6 you can play Rook a 7 using
the fact that the E4 Pawn is hanging
right and uh if we trade on D5 we will
immediately smoke out the Knight by
trading it pretty much exactly and yes
the Rook is still on i7 I'm still a bit
more a bit worried but I'm I suppose
after rookie 7 King f8 Rook C7 we will
find a way to smoke out that that
intrusion some even even that is a bit
awkward honestly just what goes to C7
and we don't have the best the best
setup in the world to deal with it no we
don't but also let's say there is the
move f2f3 in this position instead of e
takes D5
uh maintaining all the tension saying to
Black uh okay now show me how your
pieces move here now that this Knight is
now that you played F3 now you forced me
to find Rook A6 because my alternatives
are Dreadful yeah uh all of this is
quite difficult for liraza well one of
his play he's played E5 in the meantime
he hasn't played any of this he's played
uh E4 E5 which was not I mean I
mentioned the five existing but I think
Knight D7 is quite strong I wonder what
he uh what he intends here because if
you have to go let's say back to G2
I think you've done kind of bad things
to your position even if six now exists
you've helped like six or F5 exists wait
a minute E6 is a little tender it takes
Bishop takes E7 though right
I mean I'm still okay with it to be
honest with rubish for seven Queen Seven
Queen E3 I don't know
but maybe there's even something
stronger maybe we can try to instead of
trading the E5 ball maybe we can try to
round it up
play I don't know let's put it that back
play a queen E7 rookie eight or queen B8
actually a queen B8 is an interesting
option
yeah with the idea that uh there is this
nasty pin but H6 is hanging H6 still
possible because G7 actually this just
loses on the spot right because EF wins
the piece I'll shoot Queen G7 mate oh
boy
um okay uh e a five uh a move that we
kind of frowned upon I just wanted to
say that prior to this moment we were
analyzing Queen G3 and stuff we
shouldn't be that surprised that White's
for Choice after all he has centralized
his Rooks with Rook D1 rookie one there
is still a rook on A8 you can see that
so it's not all together equal equal but
the move E4 E5 uh Alejandro to our eyes
at least we didn't look at Knight E4
that much and maybe we should but after
Knight D7 we think Ali Reza will be
welcoming the move E4 E5 are we right
one of the reasons that you said that
Whitehall held an advantage because he
put the Rooks in the center yeah and you
closed the center that's not good that's
not good no E5 is not a good move after
E5 the Knight Retreats I already has
retreated to D7 I mean you could analyze
Knight E4 is actually fine for black
right but it's just stronger 97 the
Knight has to go somewhere you could
play uh Queen G3 by the way
this is interesting but it's not
sufficient after you take on C4 you can
take on H6 and G6 and we start looking
at this position now if you have to take
on f8
um obviously this is dead but you can
start thinking about this move Bishop G5
and weasel your way into the dark Square
see when I move like Queen B8 the
engine's already saying that you might
be lost after craziness like Bishop
takes C4 very engine like actually
thinking that after G6 Bishop G5 you
might even have to find the move F6
but but I'm assuming you take C4 is not
force right or is it yes completely
first uh so King h8 96 were busted King
AJ 96 is busted because C4 comes now B7
is hanging you don't have a tactic to
get out of this and you're not on time
to play Queen E7 because of C4 I'm just
opening up everything so e597 if he
finds Queen G3 D takes C4 G6 sorry
Bishop takes H6 G6 Bishop G5 it could
get dangerous the engines are still
saying this is completely fine for black
F6 is forced apparently you cannot take
on F6 because of the pin right but after
Bishop H6 hitting that pawn you have to
according to the engine you have to play
G5 only move no King H7 no Queen E8 I
don't know why I have to go deeper dig
into the variations for that and
Hereafter Bishop takes f8 King takes f8
we just have craziness on the board
absolute craziness the king's weak
there's Mayhem yeah but you do have a
lot of pieces the bishop committed I
don't know man this is difficult the
engines are still bobbing around their
evaluation Queen G3 already on the board
guys Queen G3 already on the board it's
a peace sacrifice there is a five
thousand dollar brilliancy up for grabs
here are we seeing the makings of it
brilliancy because Queen potentially
Peter I capture the Knight Bishop takes
H6 and I must say after G6 Bishop G5
wasn't the absolute first thing I was
thinking about either I was thinking
could I potentially get away with slow
play like Alejandra said I like the
weasel by the way the weasel Bishop G5
Bishop f6. but the immediate Bishop G5
F6
Bishop H6
G5 Peter yeah G5 yeah no this is this
looks extremely scary for black foreign
like I wouldn't know what the evaluation
is but I would be kind of hopeful here
with white and very worried here with
black people exactly I wouldn't
instantly think I'm I'm in in a ton of
trouble with black because we do have
the pieces of uh for the Rook we have a
decent amount of uh pieces around the
king meaning that the king is not really
defenseless here you do you do have okay
you gotta Rook at a bishop and your
pawns are a little bit Advanced but uh
White's pieces are are nicely set up and
just a second it's very scary I I mean
taking the why not but can I just uh
should we explore a little bit Peter
what about is this all of those moves
are boring me yeah absolutely yeah yeah
yeah
wow
um and The Clocks by the way Queen G3
how much time did he use to play that
move Alejandro now Queen G3 almost
instantly I think he had to plan it um
when he played B5 yeah which actually
took him
but 12 minutes okay and the current uh
clock times
for the players or 41 against an hour in
two minutes okay so Hans has played it a
little bit slower than alireza and uh in
a practical game Alejandro uh in this
position after Queen G3 prefer to play
white or black just I mean just give me
your uh forget the eval just how how do
you feel
hmm I mean
it's easier to play with the initiative
but it's just it's a piece right I mean
you're not getting anything back if
you're not for a while yeah this is the
point yeah you you have to commit to not
even trying to win any material back
until you've provoked enough of the sort
of the softening on the king side
because otherwise your your attack will
fizzle I mean I know that
I mean it just doesn't seem like black
has done anything wrong right so that I
start to think that a full P sacrifice
is valid here not like if I had Bishop
D3
I'd start thinking yes this is very
attractive instantly and yeah I'm loving
White's position but you just never have
access to this move which means that I'm
completely relying on killing you in the
dark squares unless h4h5 works yeah I've
been looking at attempts to really slow
play stuff here by just completely
ignoring uh what's going on with
material wise and just pushing for for
this but it feels to me like it
shouldn't be uh it shouldn't be good
enough
help me out here Queen E7 H5 Bishop five
I thought but then yeah I'm not sure I
want to be offering the uh the C4 Pawn
so freely because then HG suddenly
becomes so much bigger threat yeah it's
it's one of those where
Alejandra said my Rooks are on the open
file and you're opening up the center
not good not great not great at all yeah
and it's it's definitely a position
where
yeah I think I'm choosing white here I
think regardless of what the engine says
right if it's a practical game and we
assume it's a game of like zero
available information right I think it's
just very much easier to play with white
and much more enjoyable to play with
white exactly the initiative after all
winter three is a very very interesting
resource because uh yeah I was the well
as a wrong choice but yeah otherwise 96
95 is a stone cold refutation Queen G3
on the other hand what I thought it was
intriguing is that Alejandra said King
h896 you're lost we're not even going to
discuss how bad this is because C4 B7 is
hanging and you have no 95 resources on
G3 and I thought yeah maybe I can find
some position to play G7 G5 but I guess
I just made it I just get mated if I do
that there let's take a quick look uh
King h8 1996 and I thought maybe maybe
not immediately but I thought maybe I
can find a moment to play G5 and then
perhaps create a thread of Knight takes
C5 right but my issue is let's say let's
say white doesn't even have any
sacrifices here and just goes in on
Bishop C1 right I am still not
threatening to take 25 because Queen
takes E5 is a check and I assume it will
not go well for me after that I mean the
light continues because the light is
pinned but at the very least there will
be Knight takes B7 right so all of this
has to be very carefully prepared and
even if you very carefully prepare it it
probably still doesn't work right and
that means that white has like full
control yeah white has full control I
had to take the peas I'll take on H6 G6
now here is the controversy here because
we did Play Bishop G5 and provoked F6
but H4 it's crazy obviously if we could
just play Rook takes D7 put our Bishop
on F6 and our Queen on H4 Wells and the
score sheets so I understand that this
move actually is just making a killing
threat possible Rook takes D7 Bishop
ship F6 and I'll meet you on the dark's
word so we have to play F6 and then we
go back yeah it goes back because Bishop
6.56 of course is uh is very good for
for black Jews have been along that
diagonal so Bishop H6 and it's
interesting for instance that uh King F7
is just horrible here I I don't know I
don't know exactly why but it should I'm
guessing king of seven which Buffet
simply Queen takes a f8 and Bishop takes
C4 will win or something or Rook D7 E6
check might just win on the screen
that's what I was fearful yeah but
you're right Bishop C4 might be one but
this is certainly this is cleaner this
is end of gamer exactly and this is
certainly uh
um so it appears to actually be more or
less forcing G6 G5 here which is a move
you hate to make because you continue
advancing advancing the targets for uh
for white right for white to be more and
more comfortable breaking breaking your
structure or open on the king side F4 H4
is also now that you reminded me of the
fact that I do have a bishop yes I start
to think about uh almost lodging the
bishop on E6 all of these things they
look very very scary uh and even if you
take on a fade uh let's say instead of
all this day yeah you know immediately
G5 we take on a fight okay I think once
again we probably just straight up
cannot take with the queen because
Bishop takes C4 will win the game that's
my feeling Bishop C4 Bishop C4 root D7
will not hold any any time we crash yeah
like once once we get to the seventh you
generally kind of resign okay like life
teaches us that those positions don't
hold so you have to take to the king I
think yes and then you know all kinds of
things even something very simple like
Queen G3 of three here using the the
amount of spinach yeah like Bishop E5
rookie five is a very cute position how
many pins can we uh talk about the night
on D7 Bend absolute pin with the king I
like that pinage yeah so queen of three
and and like what do you play here
he takes F6 is a very strong threat if
you play a five once again I get the
feeling the bishop takes C4 wins there
I'm gonna have to close my eyes 55 maybe
yeah I I maybe underestimated uh at
least I I I spoil the pinage yeah yeah
it's a good move I for some reason it
just spoiled the porridge spoiled with
the energy yes never mind
um
correct don't even ask me Bishop D5 is
the only way for white black to survive
that position and it's zero zero
go play it yes enough three probably not
the best though right that's the best
best move yes best move yes whoa okay I
mean Bishop D5 absolutely the moment he
has yes I mentioned it and I realized it
exists I knew it was the best move but
Queen F3 I thought it was just not great
but apparently we're we're doing okay
our guesswork is on point yes works on
point but also Alejandro our guesswork
is such that we're warming to the
initiative even if the eval is zero zero
we're beginning to feel like White's the
one having the fun here and dictating
the course the game another Resident
didn't even see this coming
yeah yeah I think we'll be stuck yeah I
think he's stuck he's stuck I mean you
can see this expression when concerts
played Queen G3 and he was like yo isn't
your night hanging he doesn't seem that
word yeah that isn't it that seems to be
waking up to his tasks are the rest of
their you know it's it's it's an
expression I I believe I've seen before
and it's an expression of a man who is
sort of acutely unhappy with his lot and
uh
um
we think that Alejandra put himself in
contention or a leading contention to
win the brilliancy prize and do you ever
have this feeling that after something
it's your turn to become the student or
something like that I don't know yeah
but the brilliancy might be on the other
foot it's very possible uh I mean
alireza is not really thinking about
that now I'm pretty sure but uh we you
know we we have to we're the judges we
can definitely discuss it okay but uh
whether he likes it or not we do think
D5 takes C4 is required otherwise like
you said Alejandro the Knight just lands
on D6 we don't have F6 is that right
before H6 I guess very simply and we go
from there I don't know exactly how we
went from there but it's a reason I
think you go from here yeah yeah yeah
you keep on you keep on playing F6 a lot
of EF like what is happening here of
course for the second time of asking I
haven't actually played it yet it's very
very silly of me okay which means then
we have to take yeah we have to take we
have to play G6 to stop Queen G7 mate uh
here we already have uh opportunity h4f
for Bishop G5 yeah there's a bunch of
things all of these movements if you
will are forced uh let's try it once
again Bishop takes f8 he takes f8
because I didn't think Peter that your
move Queen F3 was the only move yeah I
thought there was uh
an array of choices is F4 a potential
Choice what did you or did you have it
besides Queen F3 what was occurring I
think if we're playing a four I would
actually maybe from a human perspective
I would prefer to postpone taking on a
fade in that case yeah I think I like my
Bishop on H6 okay if we're making some
kind of a move here that is whether it's
H4 or H4 or I would like to do it with
the bishop still alive on H6 because I
think it might be useful for me uh in
trying to develop my attack further okay
um
yeah absolutely I mean you have to at
some point and I mean you don't have to
have to H4 it does exist but right F4 is
sort of more concrete because as you
mentioned it also introduces perhaps in
some positions the idea of a four or
five which might become relevant uh
exactly in some cases yes we could get a
leadership yeah I think perhaps we need
to maybe I understand it's the most
exciting position of the round sure sure
it's uh it's one of those where I'm
pretty sure we can talk about it
non-stop for the next 45 minutes and we
will still not exhaust every single
possibility here but we have two more
games going and alireza is faced with a
very difficult decision so perhaps we
could let him you know let him stew on
things for a bit and jump back to the
Fabi game because after the move we're
still there we're still there guys there
you can talk another 30 minutes about
the others
I believe so yeah I mean I mean there
was a Structure change in the uh live on
live on okay game versus uh lay here
yeah Lanier actually after uh Bishop
Bishop B3 he played Rook fc8 he did not
play G5
yeah Levon replied with C2 C3 and
despite appearances I guess both of them
agree that D3 D4 was a plan right
because it doesn't feel immediately
obvious to me that playing D4 and
allowing either let's say the opening of
the C file or perhaps C4 Bishop C2 and
then the pawn on B5 perhaps feels a
little bit lonely but then I guess the
way to think about it is let's say let's
make some kind of a stupid move here I
don't know h7h6 excellent G4 okay and
then let's say we go I don't know C4
Bishop C2 okay and the bishop on C2
character is kind of passive the pawn on
B5 currently you can argue is sort of
stuck in only imagine yeah on on the
enemy side of the board but then you
start looking at pieces that black
actually has to attack it right and the
list is basically one one you can play
Rook A5 and that's it yeah it's still
not hanging because there's a rook on B1
right and in order to attack it with one
more piece you can maybe play 98 97 you
will get mated in the meantime yeah
Bishop E3 Queens into the threats will
start piling up even if you do end up
winning the pawn on B5 in the meantime
something really bad will happen to you
on the king's side so I I think I can
understand linear's decision to uh play
95 to I don't know if it prevents D4
altogether because I think it's maybe
even still playable it's another
question can we play D4 here Knight of
three bit queen of three
she takes D4
but you can definitely argue that
removing Knight 27 which had no moves
right isn't black absolutely absolutely
yeah and the one agreed live one took
only five and now we have this extremely
extremely solid uh structure uh on both
sides where it will be difficult for uh
both of them to actually generate any
kind of play Knight of 192 is a nod
towards the Knight on D6 being a very
strong piece I assume it gets traded oh
yeah I just didn't know which was the
better Avenue I wonder why he chose 92
and not 93 I guess maybe to preserve the
option of in some cases going to F3 but
I don't know I think it pretty much
always goes to C4 anyway just for our
viewers the reason light takes B5 here
is not that great is
ah I mean Bishop takes e66 exists but
also maybe just Bishop C4 and then take
on V6 next move
uh even if you even yeah whatever you
choose I'm very happy to make that trade
well you're happy but the engines aren't
so impressed with uh actually maybe it's
fine Bishop c496 and look at your board
work xp6 and they like this move Bishop
C6 maybe Rook C6 first and
you do have A4 for the bishop C4 the
bishop itself is a little uncomfortable
you haven't developed all your pieces
either no the bishop on C1 is still
powerful it really doesn't look doesn't
look all that great for white to be
honest here it feels feels kind of I
would be reloading okay
just to open up the Rook on B1 I kind of
feel like that Rook on B1 isn't doing
anything yeah the question I would ask
of you Peter if you don't mind is I look
at the uh pieces and the bishop on G7
strikes me as a little bit page six yes
I wanted to ask you well yeah yeah I can
definitely get on board with this idea
yeah I can definitely get on board with
this idea because if we end up in a in a
situation more or less of this I'm just
putting some moves on the position I'm
not that impressed with this bishop on
CP yeah frankly well the bishop is
someone is also very very awkward but we
will play something like Rook A5 Rook C8
Bishop C8 Bishop D7 get it over 57.
exactly and then you get into this kind
of a really heavy maneuvering phase
where nobody is really doing very much
white does have the one available
because I think if 705 is pretty much
always not great in these types of
structures weakening the E5 Pawn right
so it's only up to White to to play
prepare and play F4 in the meantime we
have an interesting development in the
caruana uh mvl game because after we
need to look we need to has been played
oh we need to has been played and VL of
course instantly replied to it with
rookie 5 everything else loses right and
Fabi has already gone back to H2 instead
of whatever else he can play here which
and we have been yeah we know but he
doesn't drumming Queen D2 into our heads
yes and then 65 Rook C5 is already back
okay he can still play quinnitsu and
after rookie five choose a different
square right uh but that would be the
last time exactly that would be the last
time he can no longer repeat after that
gotcha and I mean we know everything we
need to know basically about this
position white is better pretty much
whatever he does right along normal
lines but big Advantage is only really
achievable via Equinox
I'm looking for the this alternative way
of getting an advantage Alejandro and
the move I was attracted to was F4 Pawn
takes Queen E2 with the idea of uh Queen
E6 Channel let's just take a look at
this because I wasn't able to I remember
when when yasa showed it to me a few a
few moments ago I wasn't able to
equalize it
was the last hour okay sorry uh King h8
played by the way by other as I guys
computer said he's busted King age 96
decisive Advantage white
ooh yeah we've had that established yeah
and I also basically decides that I I
don't believe he's bluffing I believed
it takes C4 if it's being offered to me
is probably not great let me just make a
move that keeps the game
yeah yeah yeah did I just say boom good
finding that C3 Queen takes E7 Rook B8
is apparently I was showing that right
yes and here C2 uh was uh insufficient
because we have enough Defenders but uh
C takes B2
is apparently good enough you cannot
take on C5 oh this is clever yeah it
gets mated from
okay uh this we can sort of understand
my question would be then instead of
Rook H2 can I not play Queen E6 check on
B3 that was my second try King h8 B3
here yeah but I can play C2 now right uh
probably okay I just kind of you have to
take I'm trying to use yeah and I just
take back yeah okay King C2 and we run
ah yeah okay we run okay yeah that's as
far as we run and and zero zero by the
way and zero and zero zero fantastic
yeah chess is a very rich tapestry yes
maybe maybe it's also draw
in the meanwhile in the back uh
Anastasia has uh caught up with uh nepo
and
I got an interview a quick interview
we're gonna go to that interview we're
going to take a break thereafter and
we'll see you on the other side enjoy
uh yeah the game between you and Wesley
so finished in the draw tell us a little
bit about it what happened
well Wesley chose one of the most solid
lines against the cattle on the end is
also the lion Knight playing the game I
played against him in um
like knows you know
these lines more or less more or less a
draw so I I try to repeat uh the line
which I played against Hikaru here in
Rapid yeah but this probably was a bad
idea because it was pretty prepared and
he came up awesome yeah the it's one of
the computers
one of the drawers which will be the
shows sometimes it goes like this yeah
exactly uh did you notice I mean I'm
sure you noticed that Magnus didn't show
up for the game did you see his tweet
before the round or you will learn the
news after no somehow I'm trying not to
spend
a lot of time on socials uh during the
tournament
yeah I can't check it but yeah probably
probably had a reason
absolutely what do you think about his
game Wisconsin yesterday do you think it
was affected by the results
um yeah in some way for sure but uh yeah
the game was more than interesting
absolutely thank you so much Jian and
all the best in the next rounds
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in St Louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from laumeyer Sculpture Park and the
city garden to the stunning Cathedral
Basilica one of the largest Mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing St Louis is on
display all year long ooh now that's an
exhibit
St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to round four of a
singfield cup and we still have three
games going on two very very exciting
tactical uh skirmishes or personal doing
skirmishes by this point in a very very
walled off position in the game between
uh Livonia and uh linear Dominguez
absolutely Peter so we start with a
central game of the round I guess the
one between Hans Neiman and alireza
feroza in which we left the things uh
pretty much after King h8 96 and we kept
on saying that black is Wars war is
perhaps much worse after King h8 and
that the peace sacrifice after Queen G3
has to be accepted but alireza clearly
thought that white is not bluffing there
and chose to uh to play sort of more
conservatively if you can describe it
like that absolutely 95 Rook D4 and now
Bishop D6 and Knight E4 has already been
played and this the table has been
beautifully set in my view for this
exchange sacrifice it really kind of
displays itself Peter because absolutely
I'm looking at the bishop coming to D3
I'm looking at the bishop coming to E5
and this Rook swings I don't know like a
pendulum yes uh to the F4 H4 G4 squares
and
it feels to me that yeah I think you
have to play Queen F6 I would assume
it's really the only move that makes any
sense whatsoever because otherwise I
think you get mated exactly but I
haven't been able to entirely refute it
yet I don't quite know uh if if we're
doing as as poorly as all that here I I
didn't like the early Bishop E5 because
of Moves Like Queen G5 and or queen G6
but it's crazy I really want to stop
Bishop D5 I want to play Bishop D3 and I
want to play uh Bishop D3 and Bishop
Bishop E5 I thought a Prelude a very
nice I mean yes this is a huge monster I
want absolutely yeah but my plan here
with black would be to play rookie eight
I'm assuming okay I think right and then
to try to play either Bishop 5 or Bishop
D7 okay and to get some material off the
board
I'll play the uh how do you say uh
Queen a G5 still okay just a second here
I think this is maybe not that horrible
for black I mean this particular
position because I've I've brought the
Rook into the game eurook hasn't landed
on E7 and it seems like the Queens might
be coming off
and if the Queens do come off you will
always have compensation but it's not an
idea uh lethal right rookie No rookie
seven just complete there is a Queenie
one yeah could be someone I can take it
twice right so okay it looks like Bishop
E5 just second Bishop B5 Queen G5 where
am I going here
this looks
like I should
even now I I'm looking at positions with
C4 C5 Peter uh like maybe just even here
yeah but you can definitely get very
very you know healthy compensation for
the exchange but I've already gotten
that I was trying to get uh what I
thought was a a Killer attack going as
well did I misplay this it just feels
like what feels a bit slow if you're not
winning immediately after you've played
so far anyway
um
let me try Bishop D7 and I mean I can
play F6 straight away if I wanted to but
maybe bishop D7 first and I have six
Alejandra I'm a little bit struggling I
feel like White's having the fun but uh
it requires coordination Harmony of the
pieces help me out the engines do give
white a decisive Advantage particularly
in this position it needs a little
finagling but they say that the
composition is long-term they think the
rookie is actually the best move in this
position Queen F6 is certainly a logical
one they do like your move C4 yeah sir
they do think that this is a good move
they think a better move is to play
Bishop E3 right away right away two
reasons for that Bishop D4 but also
remember that Bishop B6 is actually
quite useful in this position because
sometimes you just want to Queen the
pawn so Bishop E3 might be a very good
move especially if you put any of the
Rooks on d8 you can wait a second to
play C4 and C5 because as long as you
have the bishop B6 resource perhaps your
opponed on C5 is in the way
um so Bishop B3 considers to be the best
uh and it has trouble
finding a way to defend because uh
rookie 8 Bishop D3 for example kind of
ran out of Moves Like a bit move like
Bishop D7 here yeah boom
start getting into trouble Bishop G5
coming
if you play King G8 then the H6 is
hanging you take only three I take with
the pawn and them just recovered my
exchange still up a pawn continuing the
attack so you put the Bishops like this
transfer The Rook to H4 and good luck
defending the king side yeah I couldn't
have six on the board in the meantime I
did think it was yeah I was very much in
agreement with uh with Yasser that kind
of six has to be played Bishop D3 Blitz
styled by
um yeah yep
okay I came came on not Bishop E3 by the
way but Bishop D3 instantly sorry Peter
please yeah I'm a bit surprised because
if we don't immediately refuel the
bishop 5 I don't think this trade favors
white so it's a it's an interesting
choice not the one I would have gone for
but when you see Bishop E3 with the idea
of Bishop B6 and just kind of nursing
that d-pod as well as Bishop D3 okay so
Hans clearly has a a an idea how he
wants to meet Bishop F5 so it just look
at Bishop I we gotta go Queen G5 don't
we quickly six yeah
I just missed that sorry Queen G5 right
Queen G5 now
there was a rook H4 uh how about the
engine say
Bishop D3 just bad move
bad move bad move just bad move Bishop
F5
equal
I mean there's still some composition if
you just give up the extra who does this
though why would I voluntarily exchange
the pair of Bishops right because now
you go rook d8 and unless he thought he
had
D7 here but D7 I assume I can just take
it right I think c65 is even more
painful because The Bishop's hanging I
apologize for that C5 is even better and
then you're gonna have trouble holding
on to that pawn right
um it's very strange for me to
voluntarily exchange the bishop so I
assume it's Bishop E5 what he hasn't
mind right but after Queen G5 which you
guys pointed out I don't I don't see is
there like a is there some trick here
like Rook G4
somehow this is not losing sometimes G4
F4 is winning or something yeah Bishop
takes G4 F4 is winning you have to find
Chuck
King H2
Bishop takes Queen takes and then go
back with the queen
wow and then still hear white retains
huge amounts of compensation with Queen
E4 what what is this queen E4 F5 Queen
D4 and the engine says Bishops versus
two Rooks it says zeros
but what a material imbalance what on
Earth right two exchanges uh Peter you
can't see that every day very very rare
material balance but you can see how
white is not really struggling all that
much because the pollen D6 is very but
it has to be that right like exchanging
light squares Bishops makes sense oh
yeah otherwise I don't really understand
why Bishop D3 has been played yeah it's
a it's a cute little idea okay so once
again let's go down that uh Garden Path
Bishop D3 Bishop F5
G4 and let's show Bishop takes G4 first
okay and then after four just wins on
the spot because Queen H5 HG you've lost
your queen so it has to go all the way
back to G8 if you want to keep it on the
board that is uh that's cute so we're
gonna have to F4 you have to sorry Peter
you have to go all the way back and then
Queen takes G4 and white just gives mate
because you can't really hold on to the
G7 Pawn Rook G8 Queen F5 for instance or
F6 Queen G6 and you just get swept off
the board
that it's very very cute Bishop G4 F4 is
well you know a very very attractive
little secret and we'll just uh go down
this way in H7 I guess Bishop C4 check
and then there's some kind of mate there
right there exactly Queen takes I mean
queen G6 check I guess Queen G6 it's a
matter of days like it's just completely
winning for one
and this is nice okay so okay so very
good very good very good so you can't
take the Rook right here you can't take
it but you must include Quincy one check
first so that your queen doesn't get
locked out of the G5 square and now you
take on G4 now we're threatening the big
uh Splat on G7 and now once again and
now and now the year the big difference
is we can actually return to G5 this is
what leaving the G5 Square gave us the
opportunity to come back which is a side
step F4 in a way quite ironic and then
we threaten mate yeah we can still play
Queen G6 here but I'm guessing it's not
an improvement because like Queen E3 or
queen D4 will continue chasing the young
Queen before maybe just very very strong
right so that was why we were looking at
F5 F5 and now we put the queen on G4 we
play F2 F4 and that setup is just
unchallengeable right this bishop on E5
is definitely worth a rook uh definitely
yeah and there's also a point there's
this other Bishop if we get it to a safe
square like C4
um
I've sacrificed lots of exchanges in my
life but two versus two Bishops this is
pretty cool uh Alejandro I like this
materially imbalance it's brilliant even
coming up with the concept is amazing
because you have to see all this right
right like you have to assume so even
though white is probably not worse if
you just allow the trade here with like
Rook D4 no but but who like if you're
going to allow the trade just play
something else right don't play Bishop
the thing is going to go for it yeah
that's that's my feeling as well we'll
we'll see but
Bishop B5 Queen G5 it was very much
Jack forced
heart is time an issue is are the clock
times not really not really no I think
they're playing I mean it's more 25 they
don't have too much time but it's uh
half an hour 32 against 40 basically for
uh Hans and alirez respectively and uh
move 25 not a big issue at the moment
not just yet yeah it could become one if
one of them decides to have a very very
long tank but I love this Rook G4 I like
this whole Queen C1 check Queen G5 as
well uh it was
those Queen traps were were amazing yeah
it was a very beautiful line uh quickly
did uh
ended up playing Quincy too but with the
Rook on C5 which I believe is a bit
worse than with the Rook on E5 because
of three F4 is no longer winning as a
very important Tempo but it's still good
for wise V takes C4 are played by uh mvl
in reply I assume we take with the
bishop I mean Rook takes also exists but
why would you I I have the impression
that we were here quite some time ago
already pointing out that rip take C4
would elaborate of course he goes King
h8 here and uh I mean black is you know
here maybe I take on C1 I think this is
what he's spinning his hopes on ah and
then Queen takes H4 I think if if White
had a Pawn on A3 already this would have
been lost I think like if you imagine
like a three let's let's add a three and
day five to this position
no Queen H4 and just just illustrate my
point let's add a3a5 Fair okay then I
think Rook C7 might be winning exactly
because I have the A2 Square for the
king like Queen H1 check I will simply
play King A2 and defending the bishop
only seven is going to prove difficult
it will uh and if it has to yeah
but if we do it without A3 A5 without
the absolutely artificial edition of
those two moves if you play Rook C7 here
immediately you're hoping to take the
bishop yeah you get hit by Queen H1
check and then after Bishop D1 what do
you do and yeah maybe it's still bad
yeah it's just lost maybe it's still bad
just lost says Alejandra wow just lost
indeed guys I mean take a look at this
position Bishop D1 yeah so maybe
sometimes like rookie eight might be
kind of saving things boom yeah like and
the engine say you just don't have a way
to defend against King C2 to defend this
bishop and then take the bishop on E7
yeah I was I I kind of I was gonna go A3
yeah I was assuming that because we're
currently not threatening to take on E7
due to the bishop on G1 hanging maybe
there is a difference but apparently no
apparently apparently not Bishop B3 is a
strong move actually it's so strong the
engine say that Rook takes Rook takes
Queen H4 Rook C7 is decisive Advantage
white and that you should try to trade
the Queens right now another variation
that is possible from that line Queen
takes H4 Rook C1 uh I was looking at
Bishop d8 immediately of course the
point is that after Queen takes I have
this move at least saving me for the
time being if I play Bishop D1 I can
Retreat my queen and kinda hold on for
now okay but there's this really tricky
move you go Rook C1 instead of playing
Bishop D1 forces the exchange of Queens
really nothing better kind of thing but
after tax takes G6 I think this is
hopeless right G6
you have to go H6 which means you're
playing down a king yeah you're playing
you're playing down the king for the
rest of the game and yeah those
generally end up being hopeless yeah I
would agree with you they generally end
up being hopeless but uh in the middle
of all this fast and furious uh
capturing of the bishop on E7 you stop
and you go G6 there was sort of like uh
that's a change of uh Direction and wow
uh nice variations guys uh Bishop takes
E4 check uh King ah Queen E2 played by
by Fabio they're also a very very
concrete way of playing their uh and
once again sort of very centered on on
that horrible Bishop 27. inviting rookie
five I assume and then he wants to put
the queen on a better Square yeah
interesting by the way uh again it just
make it just goes to show how pathetic a
threat after six kids G5 is just ever
going to be yeah just not working in so
many variations opening up the H file
looks great for Fabby we'll keep this
green yeah and the other one is very
very videos down yeah this one is uh is
just there I thought this was a really
uh clever little Nuance by
um Lanier in this moment because we were
thinking about Knight takes B5 and
Knight C4 coming I thought it was very
nice Rook A5 to kind of force well not
for us but like make make livon
determine whether he wants to go Knight
C4 I'm not sure maybe 94 Rook takes B5
maybe we can do it anyway but yeah it's
a good point yeah yeah so I thought this
was a nice little and yeah I like this
yeah Bishop B2 F6 and queen G3 is a bit
mysterious to me I'm not sure what it's
doing there I think he's just getting
out of the way yeah the bishop yeah
rerouting the other Bishop towards some
Square I don't know what those squares
are that's like some squares now this
one might be setting up for a little uh
Swindle there yeah Bishop takes and
Knight takes E4 so we've caught up to
the players and like you say it's a
lockdown let's go back to the alireza
game because boy yeah
he played Bishop D3 kind of surprisingly
quickly I guess he was expecting Queen
F6 so uh he had a move prepared and I I
think maybe what had happened is he
perhaps missed you and see one check
like he thought was just kind of
playable because Bishop B5 Queen G6 room
G4 one again Bears repeating is a very
beautiful immediate win for white
exactly pretty much so yeah this is
unholdable and then after Queen G5 he
saw Rook G4 and he became very happy
because he realized for Bishop G4 F4 is
definitely uh going to be winning for
him and now he is coming to the
realization that Queen C1 check exists
and the game will continue flares are
new um
wow uh I I'm telling you guys I'm in the
grip of this game at a certain
moments where you in in a tournament
round where you see on board
three
and everybody just kind of collectively
goes over there and just over there very
very nice and then those returns to
their seats this one has definitely got
my attention and Alejandro I know the
eval Isn't So enthusiastic but what say
you how do you think uh Hans is doing in
this game I like it I still have to look
at it with other engines because this
particular long-term sacrifice is
actually like looking better with Leela
then I like looking at them with
stockfish and I'm only using a stockfish
here so I want to get a second opinion
before I say that the eval dropped too
much because when I look at this
position
uh and I find like the engine tells me
all this right right
and we go all the way here we take we
take we go here and it's all fours Queen
E4 forcing F5 only move for Queen D4 we
get all the way to this position and I
guarantee that light goes F4 next move
it's visually very nice getting here is
difficult right but visually this is
very nice and even though the engine's
saying zero zero I would never evaluate
this at zero zero I'm lucky if I escape
this with black exactly like White's
position is just so sound so strong and
the only reason you can hold this
because engines have infinite patience
but I'm wondering if a different
thinking machine might decide that
actually this is just much better for
white in a longer yeah I I don't ever
see this being uh being better for black
because we play F4 we pretty much play
C4 C5 I think you see 4 C5 will be
incredibly difficult to stop right and
then the only question is whether we
have any weigh-in right there's there's
no real counter play for black for the
rest of the game there I don't really
see how any of our setup can be
challenged but yes we're done we don't
do exchanges but I'm like who cares it's
uh it's just material
right this dominating Bishop yeah let's
make some moves right on The Rook 88 we
go F4 right yep so we cement the bishop
Forever on this eternal Square Queen G6
we go C4 our King is perfectly perfectly
happy yeah and and yeah let's make some
of another Rook D7 C5 just to get this
on the board whatever whatever you
choose exactly we currently might not
have too many threats even though the
pawn on A5 is kind of like at some point
you play PC3 and you ask how happy are
you to dedicate a full group to being on
A8 exactly but but just the the major
Point here is that
it's impossible to do anything with the
setup right you just wait I mean you
okay maybe you're afraid of G4 so you
slip back so I can play Bishop C4 right
even for beat you from even dreaming of
Queen D5
yeah exactly and then we look for
improvements with one right and if we're
unlucky there are no improvements maybe
maybe actually Queen C3 or K8 holds or
queen G2 or K8 and after that we can I
can I can really eyeball that pawn but
yeah I mean are you is black happy as
you say assigning a whole Rook uh to the
defense so so you get to some kind of
obsession like this and black will be
playing King h8 King H7 right pretty
much like um maybe some other waiting
moves are slightly stronger but but you
are kind of resigned to making those
types of waiting moves for the
foreseeable right because there is no
counter play there will be no counter
play and if you give up on A5 I think
white will very easily uh open up okay
like create an additional passer and
then everything collapses like
everything goes to Absolute pieces and
as Alejandro said infinite patience
pretty good but human beings not known
for it not not known whatsoever and
you've guys already lost
pardon you already lost like this way
you played already lost like revenge is
saying plus three it's over
um they woke up to the demise or did
they do something they're very specific
that in this particular position white
can't execute two things at the same
time
if you play a four star like this queen
G6 C4 absolutely only move into position
B6
I was wondering right on time if you
take on B6 Rook oh no that's a huge
Improvement of course right now you get
one exchange back now it's only equal
after Bishop takes that five since you
are getting another Pawn but huge
Improvement and otherwise I get to move
C5 in continuing with the future threats
of taking up this Pawn uh for an
exchange and if you do it the other way
around if you start with C4 immediately
there's a couple moves here but B6 is
one of them again F4 Queen G6 is just a
transposition and if you take on B6 now
I can play F4 myself you don't have
Queen e4th running mate and I am now
attacking your Bishop I can hint at F3
one day and if you play like this oops
that's a destabilized bishop a D7 is not
on time you have to find this move but I
can run and the game just becomes messy
because after Queen H7 check remember
that you're down a lot of material even
if I start running a little bit it's not
about that it's can why can you prevent
me from creating threats and if you have
to go back to C3 you can I can play King
H rooked shade force you to trade the
queens and then we just have a weird end
game in which the computers actually
prefer black so it's about a Tempo by
Tempo thing where white actually doesn't
get F4 and C4 C5 in right because it
makes a lot of sense perfect
an absolute Stone Cold requirement
otherwise white does get on as a
complete positional grip over the
position but that was a very important
point that Alejandro showed B6 is
crucial once again let me just Echo it
is very very that Queen takes Rook takes
and then we'll see none of that The Rook
Retreats and just allows the bishop
Exchange
uh
oh regrettable those were very very in
non-standard positions I really wanted
to see them on the board but absolutely
rookie three is uh okay if if you play
Bishop D3 and Alejandro says you you you
follow it up with a rook Retreat then
the move Bishop D3 was all together well
yeah you just don't you don't you didn't
he did not have to play Bishop D3 He
should have kept the light Square
Bishops on the board with the immediate
Bishop uh E3 Bishop D3 and now maybe the
question mark move uh he didn't play
Bishop E5 which he should have Rook E3
and it's just good compensation yeah I
mean the G6 spawner is very strong I
don't think there's any question of why
being worse it's just that it's not what
We're Dreaming of we were dreaming of
amazing attack on the king side and we
have to switch to slightly different
plans now right uh black could still
misplay into an attack on the king side
but with only three pieces left and the
e-file open for uh for potential counter
play for black it feels a bit safer
Queen F5 is a move that I'm kind of
drawn to just to kind of sidestep Bishop
B5 Tempe or Rook 88 or even maybe rookie
well the one thing that I would say that
I can understand Ali Alejandra I can
understand Hans uh you know if he were
to reposition the bishop to C7 it's
definitely worth uh but it also once the
bishop does get to B6 so wait a minute I
maybe your queen F5 was maybe required
because how are you going to meet this
Peter I'm not that happy about it I'm
I'm I mean I'm not
as heartbroken as I may be like I can
simply queen of five here right Bishop
Bishop D7 defending the a pawn yeah I'm
not I'm not in love with my with my Rook
under seven having no moves but if I can
get like rookie 86 now yeah rookie 3 is
what I'm what I'm worried about because
I can always sing and sneak in the move
Bishops but but you're not winning
quickly enough and maybe I can maybe I
can actually find time to play Queen B1
Queen takes beat soon to at least have
something to suffer for right Queen
Nations
so if I don't get mated here like you
could maybe switch back to Bishop D4 and
trying to give mate it worries me
with a reason yeah 6 rookie seven and
something bad happens to me because my
queen is completely misplaced right but
yeah all of this is now extremely
concrete like it becomes a very move by
move um situation yeah absolutely okay
and a very interesting uh development I
think in our naidorf where Fabi is still
better but maybe he sold it a bit short
that's a cool move it is a very cool
move and there's a very cool reply as
well we we saw it we need turkey five
Queen D3 and we'll replied with d65
which is very understandable and he got
hit with this F3 F4 move but he can
actually take on C4
Rook takes and you have rookie three
which I think is the only move that
doesn't lose a lot of material yeah it
still loses us that Bishop on E7 which
is what I think uh Fabi is hoping for
but I think I play like King G8 maybe a
rook C8 in this position and I claim
that I'm upon down it's an improvement
for black I'm still suffering I'm pretty
sure black is still fighting for a draw
but I have a feeling it's an improvement
because we've gotten rid of that truly
horrible mission 27 which was more very
valuable but the light Square Bishop as
well I mean queen E3 in this particular
position I think I I originally missed
Queen E3 okay you're holding your
material extra material but at least
from Black's point of view King on h8 is
still so unsafe like it's it's going to
be so difficult to like create a lift
for it if you play H6 all the files get
opened if you play G6 Europe unhappy
desperately he's still in trouble has
the worst pass for uh mvl Alejandro or
still bad news he needs to find a couple
of good moves but the engine said that
his position has improved let's take a
look at what they think because you guys
got to this position after the entire
four sequence for black there's nothing
else but instead of playing the move
Rook C8 I was being aggressive King G8
okay you're threatening F4 after all if
you take on F6 this still allows you to
take with the Rook preserving the
Integrity of your structure and if you
play Queen E3 then very importantly I
take on the G5 cannot take with the H
Pawn because Queen takes F4 so you have
to play F takes G5 you trade a set of
Rooks and we and we liquidate into
something yeah and we liquidate into
this end game which is not a draw but
it's a lot of suffering still for black
I think but the engines say eventually
you will make it into a draw yeah
compared to getting mated by move 30
this is uh
yes a market Improvement in in mbl's
fortunes for sure yeah absolutely
absolutely so if I if I be correctly
assessing that he absolutely does not
have to take the repetition but not
finding uh the absolute best sequence
there in MBL uh potentially escaping
with it today potentially Queen C3 by
levonne is when we left it we have the
d8 setting up that little trick of
Bishop takes D2 uh trickery Knight F7
Bishop D1 somehow this bishop on A2 and
okay four Rook A4 is such a cute move
Rook A4 is basically saying uh saying to
live on we're playing in a singfield cup
uh there is this thing on our graphic
which says no draws allowed right would
you like to play Bishop D1 or K5 Ah
that's what the a professional a
profession a muted a draw offer you
think yeah would you would you like to
play Bishop D100 K5 maybe because nobody
is really going anywhere here no says
Lavon I want to play G4
lash out and you're crazy
the black position is just so hot so
solid like I If you if you actually
break open in the center I feel like you
will be breaking open very very much in
Black's favor like if you push for a
four an F4 happens and black replies by
EF and then F6 F5 somehow you just start
hating life with the Vengeance with wise
so I have a confession to make I like
Bug House Bug House and I love it good
[ __ ] house position this is a good
podcast position for sure like I'm
absolutely terrible back doesn't even
like him recognize that you know some
flow has been achieved by this bear
Alejandra will be my partner he'll he'll
gnash at me keep your king safe I said
look he goes okay good job
although although born to H6 even here I
mean we take it that's kind of like it's
actually a very safe very nice set up
yeah
um we've only
which I think is a I think is a good
move I'm sorry which has been found by
only yeah he played queen of five
instead exactly The Rook dates of the
world exactly and I like this move a lot
because it just does yeah it keeps a lot
on everything yeah so it was the only
move pardon it was the only move
it was the only yeah everything else
lost just lost lost yeah straight up so
Rook d8 how do we lose 38 Bishop E5
we've been losing Queen G5 let's take
take D7 I'll take six okay so they just
lost end of game yeah okay yeah it makes
sense Bishop guess the G7 we resign yeah
I can understand that I can I can get
behind that one as well sorry we didn't
recognize that uh Bishop E5 D7 very
consequently wins the game the queen
very good
and now it's not that easy to make
progress for white right because we
we're now prepared to start blockading
the the g-pawn and then perhaps like my
ideal setup remains like Rook on D7 Rook
on E6
oh absolutely and then you can maybe
even start talking about yeah yeah
um to everything you just said put your
Rooks on D7 E6 I would say put your
pawns on C5 so that Bishop is never and
it just crossed my mind in a in a
flitter that uh this is actually a
pretty funny way of trapping your own
Bishop
there can be one chick
exactly yeah you can't do that so no
Bishop E5 for Hans and can Ali Reza
start thinking that maybe the worst is
over Alejandro the worst is certainly
over according to the engines it does
they do think it's about zeros right now
now why it's not worse do you have a
powerful Pawn on D6 but without a light
squared Bishop how do you rip apart
light Square blockades now you like to
play D7 now and then follow it up with
Bishop C7 but you're not on time that's
very clear that after Rook 88 you just
don't have the time to hold on to
everything you'd love to play Queen G4
to defend the spawn be asked straight
but D3 is always going to be hanging
right right so you don't have the time
to do that you can start playing like
something like C4 trying to get C5 in
maybe distract the queen but Black's
counter play starts right once this Rook
gets to E1 and this queen maybe to B1
your star thinking this is a three
result game they're just thinking of
course that I played a stupid move
apparently with Rook FEA because of Rook
F3 but that's why they're engines uh
instead after C4 maybe they prefer to
move Rook 88 it's still a complicated
position white has so much space that
they must have a sufficient compensation
and remember that there's also the
possibility of switching to a King side
attack the moment to many pieces leave
so still I think it's a fascinating game
I don't think that aliex is fully uh
breathing a sigh of relief because I
feel that he's still under some pressure
even if the engines think that his
position has improved considerably right
it feels to me too Peter that The Rook
on D3 is just woeful uh if I were just
to play Rook D2 with ideas of Bishop E3
and swinging around and or D7 and
because now I would like to play D7 and
queen G4 I think I have to invest the
tempo in rookie 88 here okay probably
right right
and okay Queen G4 you take and you've
got Rook d78 even yeah because I will
have a G7 rookie seven there right very
good let me just show that so if we
think that this is all play on one go
we're gonna go D7 and we're gonna go
Bishop C7 Peter just pointed out that
rookie 8 D7 Rook E7 is in time
okay so can I go backwards now to set up
our Dream position you could try of once
again I'm not that impressed by that
setup I think even Rook FEA Bishop b657
is not that horrible for black I think
and or yeah we could also include this
yeah and as uh Ali Hansen I'm not in
love with this this is I think this is
just one chance just one just Queen G4
and like why why have we invested so
much effort into giving this one check
the king will be okay on G3 but just
playing Rook D7 rookie six and just
uh staying uh Rook this right here in
the meantime Hans has already made a
move and it's sort of what we've
discussed very much instead of all that
he played Queen G3 E3 in reply to Queen
F5 I'm guessing trying to get it to G2
and then perhaps there is some hint of
Bishop takes H6 ideas in some positions
which might really be a draw for so
Queen yeah
Queen J2 okay okay G8 and we can take on
H6 in this position but I think it's
just a draw right or maybe not even a
draw
um meanwhile I think that linear Domingo
yeah there it is yeah and yes and they
are repeating a very Solid Rock Solid
game right that levonne brought this
anti-sicilian all the pawns got locked
in the center and nothing much happened
here right
yeah we didn't see the bishop D1 uh
tentative yeah but they they found they
found a different one yeah they found a
nice little repetition there at the end
well
this setup against the Sicilian what you
said Peter sort of you're abdicating
your opening Advantage but you're trying
to get a game uh I think it was born I
think it was born out by event exactly I
think this is what we've witnessed and
King G8 found by by mvl and wealth has
actually been defending once he uh
clearly misstepped 576 but from that
moment on I think he found some of his
moves were like absolutely strictly the
only ones but whenever there was a
choice he I think he's been navigating
this very very admirably and has decent
decent chances to uh to save the game
now including and up to the move a king
G8 it's move 34 5B is done for 16
minutes but it's 16 minutes for six
moves so it's not really any kind of a
particular problem
hmm just no no no I I'm
H5 Queen F4 uh maybe even FG is my issue
H5 takes G4 and if you play F the hd4
you've lost the queen D3 chat and yeah
there's a really good from either one
side or the other yeah yeah it looks
like Queen E3 it could be a very very
lengthy game in store there let's just
jump back we didn't discuss Queen E3 why
not
no particular reason so it's a move as
you know as as good as any other I don't
think there's much wrong with it and we
do expect this yeah for instance this
and this and enroll kg8 and I was
wondering if we can take one H6 here but
honestly I'm not even sure we have
Perpetual I can take
uh Queen takes H6 of course I do not
play King G8 because your G3 is painful
so I play Queen H7 exactly uh you give a
check from F6 and queen G7 Queen H4
queen queen H7 is an immediate draw but
my question is can I can I go queen of
16 G8
well we do get Rook G3 in that case
right queen of six King James Queen up
on me right here excuse me
King G8 yeah and then and then to f8 it
looks very awkward but I am up a rook
you know so Roxy Rook like my moves are
I'm not sure what my next move is maybe
Rook G4 Rook H4 here actually works
right yeah like I I can actually spend
the tempo here on on an awkward move
like Ruby G4 and maybe there is really
no good defense against Rook H4 because
of how stuck everything is the D3
workout earlier or it's not working
because like Brooke is hanging I
apologize uh Alejandro this out here
just doesn't work right after King Jade
I was wondering G7 yeah you take on D3 I
can take one D3 I don't think it does
anything yeah it does anything okay
um yeah it's just uh it's just true but
that final position it looks scary for
black you get to f8 and then suddenly
you realize none of your none of your
things can move right yes you have
rookie one check but even after rookie
one checking H2 now your other Rook is
once again hanging exactly you can't
really support rookie one check with any
kind of an attack and Rook H4 continues
coming in every single position there is
a cute draw there maybe Rook H4 rookie 6
right ah it's not enough it's you know
you need to include rookie one check
okay uh Rook D7 yeah yeah
very good King H2 King H2 rookie six
rookie six yeah Queen takes a six Queen
takes H4 and I have a Perpetual wire
take the queen oh you have you you have
you have a fee here what do I do 26 F
takes a cheeks uh everything suddenly
got connected uh
Peter it's about harmony with your
pieces yes yes the thing is I create
Harmony and then don't recognize it okay
nice yeah like I'm capable of doing it
accidentally but not on purpose
apparently
um
Alejandro we're having too much fun uh
be the party pooper that we all know you
to be uh Bishop takes H6 is just a draw
yes yeah oh okay you know thanks for
invoking me here there's also Rook d8
immediately you don't actually have to
play Rook fv8 but somehow the engines
don't like this because of G4 crazy
stuff G yeah yeah I know uh Rick Affair
I think is the most logical move Queen
d2roke ad uh this looks like something I
would do we're coming to D7 at some
point means that's a stop to the pawn
and after Bishop takes we'll go down
these lines again because they're very
critical check there's no choice here
King G7 check and the engines I think
this will should end in a draw If
instead I play the move King G8 then
okay oh no oh no God plus five plus five
yes rookie three plus five five
yeah I don't know how you see this from
afar very nice attacking move there yeah
you got there buddy let's let's trade
some Rooks yeah but the threat of Rook
takes is E8 and d67 is just crushing
yeah yeah it's not remarkable yes you
can even start with D7 actually
no 23 what I mean here yeah yeah yeah
like but I mean even King f8 doesn't
stop Rook takes E8 because queen king
king takes Queen E7 is made and Rook
takes D7 we're just a we have a very
very winning uh touristic moment just a
moment right here instead of King G8
rookie three you've missed Rook E3 yeah
and by the way if you don't find rookie
three if you don't find this move you're
busted you're busted like none of these
things work this doesn't work
this didn't come close to working
because of what you guys mentioned right
and Rook E6 just evicting the queen
right so you don't have time to take
only six as we mentioned you have to
foresee Rook E3 winning
to go into this variation uh now you
could argue that you don't have to take
on H6 that's a much better argument in
my opinion you can just play Bishop E3
and continue trying to exploit the fact
that you have a pass Pawn try to get
this bishop to B6 and maybe even take on
A5 on a good day maybe play C4 C5 try to
get you to play C5 so that I can attack
that pawn and win it I understand that
Bishop H6 is tough and Rook fe8 played
Queen D2 played there is no choice but
Rook a d8 according to 67 is now a huge
threat of course you you cannot be you
cannot be allowed to play the seven
missions to seven you don't have the
time you have to play Rook 88 in this
position and if he plays Bishop H6 it's
because he saw the entire sequence
otherwise I would think Bishop E3 is
still a very normal looking move to make
it here but for the rest on the other
hand like there is a even yeah like he
doesn't need to go King Jade there has a
very very comfortable draw with Queen G7
Queen H7 no risk uh so uh yeah even if
he doesn't see the entire uh the entire
variation there he doesn't realize what
danger he's in he he at least definitely
knows he has a backup plan right exactly
King G8 is not required King James is a
winning attempt Alejandra I'd like to
ask you a question on behalf of the
audience for just a moment because you
were saying my stockfish 15 I would like
a second opinion about this attacking
position because there are some
positions where maybe one engine uh a
Lila attacks better than another engine
could you dig down a little bit and
explain what you meant by the second
opinion right now we have the two
strongest engines in the world are
stockfish and Leela there are some
others that are worth mentioning that I
do play with the big boys but right now
I think in commercial use those are the
most common ones used by Grand Masters
and there are certain positions that are
certain variations especially certain
openings in which you tend to agree with
Leela a little bit more than you tend to
agree with stockfish at least at lower
depths and since I'm not using a super
super engine here on the back I would
like to have sometimes a second
especially when it comes to long-term
strategical compensation for material I
found that even though stockfish has
gotten much better in previous in the
latest editions I still sometimes want
to see what Leela thinks about positions
and uh during the world championship
match it was important for us to be
using both engines at every position
thank you for that uh Alejandra how
about you Peter I mean you're not a
professional as you were in the past and
maybe you didn't work or maybe you did
work with a lot of uh engines did you
have a preference one way or another uh
I think in recent times in particular
since I started like my my serious chest
work in the last couple of years was
pretty much always connected with the
the this kind of interminable candidates
tournament in the echosarinburg which
lasted 400 Days and when working with a
team which basically like if you I think
that Alexander team uh if you took any
two other players on the team their age
would be lower where the Mind combined
right I'm almost not kidding and they
taught me a few things I mean I was
aware of the concept prior to uh to
working with those guys but they very
much were you know they instilled this
idea in me that if if the position is
not simple and doesn't really require a
second opinion you always want to to
have them running in parallel because
they do provide
at times shockingly different
perspectives on seemingly a pretty
straightforward position wonderful thank
you for that Peter and by the way we
haven't guessed uh we have in studio a
special guest with Alejandro lavon's in
the building Alejandro of course Levon
aronia welcome to the show
tell us a little bit about your approach
countering the Sicilian we've seen you
use this in Rapid but how well did it
work in uh classical chess
I just thought that you know just to
play just to see how it goes you know
just to
uh come up with some ideas so this was
my uh approach today because uh linear
is a great theoretical player I mean he
I mean he's a great player but he also
knows the theory very well so I thought
no I just should just play regular chess
did you feel you know him better as a
player now that you were teammates in
the recent Olympiad
um I generally know him quite well not
as a just as a teammate but also as a
dear friend
someone host company I
enjoy very much whose family I consider
to be one of the closest families to my
family excellent so take us a little bit
through some of the key moments you
think that perhaps where uh interesting
here in this game
yeah I thought this rugby one is a is an
interesting try you know just to get
some
kind of stub black from immediately
equalizing with D5
and so B5 I thought Knight B8 was a good
move here B5 instead of retreating uh
yeah yeah because Knight A5 I think is
strategically risky with the night so
offside yeah and 95 is also kind of
strategically risky because they just
take and play Knight Knight G3 you know
rookie one Knight F1 93. once I
established this dominance over the C4
square and even when the knights are off
uh the bishop is is not a
happy bunny not so much right this one
in B7 yeah yeah so he countered this
properly by playing the Knight to biota
a counter developing move and it seemed
that after the movie A6 he was pretty
much equal yeah I think he played quite
well here and then I think uh
I took a bit of a risk when I went for
all of this I thought C3 you know it's
it's a
it's a very double-edged position if
that goes you know for night of Faith
with the idea Knight C7 you know trying
to take the pawn 98-97 yeah because 1984
let's say yes 97
it gets extremely sharp I mean you might
just lose the pawn right yeah yeah
because you can close it with C4 but
then I get my play on the king side so I
was kind of getting excited and then 95
I think was a strong move right if I
just shutting this down right yeah
because now uh I will have to put the
pawn on C4 I think right I try to by
Quincy too but then yeah what I did I
thought made sense you mean you're
trying not to put the Pono C4
but somehow I can't work this uh I can't
make this nice C4 work on move 34.
uh 24 sorry 24 here I have 94. somehow
Rook B5 and it seems that everything is
covered for him right now it seemed to
me that I might have this good play with
Rook A1 Knight C4 Bishop C4 okay five
takes takes and no all those weaknesses
but the Rook protects
DFI phone the bishop protects the C5
phone and he just comes out so it's it's
an equal position all right so at the
end you decided to agree to a draw here
it did seem about equal too close for
the position
yeah I mean if I exchange the Rooks then
how I'm going to win and if I don't
exchange the Rooks you will always have
a counter play so it's tiny bit better
for white because I can
I mean I have the chances to play on but
uh I didn't see a way I can progress in
this position yeah it's difficult for
sure we thought this was a very safe
construction even in buckhouse
absolutely the one I have to ask you
what was your thought process and
reaction seeing uh the world champion
Magnus Carlsen not show up for today's
game
um I don't know maybe his uh sick I
don't know it happens he has withdrawn
from the tournament we are told it is
not health related but we haven't been
given a full explanation just yet we'll
definitely update it a little bit of
buzzing going around for the players
afterwards
I think uh it's quite often happens when
young players play very well there is
all this acquisition towards them I've
I'm in all of my colleagues are pretty
much paranoid and quite often I was the
one telling them come on guys
I mean I know myself I'm an idiot and
I'm a good player I mean I I always
think that young players can play very
well I mean there is no reason for them
not to play well so I never have this
kind of feeling I mean oh my opponent is
uh you know he's over performing because
and at the same time I mean if the young
players are not playing very well or not
occasionally beating us then what can we
learn from them you know and it also
shows that we haven't taught them
anything
[Laughter]
and I personally I've played against
Magnus when he was very young and I have
learned for him a great deal of course
one of the more traditional Powerhouse
mattress that we've had in the last
decade a decade and a half and therefore
I mean if I was sitting there and
thinking that his you know there's
something suspicious about how strong he
plays
it I I don't think it would be very
beneficial for me I could never learn
from him I would always think that now
his there is something wrong with his
player yeah yeah did you feel that
you've learned from your encounters here
at the same Phil cup absolutely
yesterday I've learned a great deal I
think I
underestimated the attack of my opponent
and uh
I really underestimated this movie three
in my preparation and I think he played
very very well so as upsetting it is you
know
it's an opportunity to learn and improve
you know
there is uh that that's what motivates
me in life
you can always learn about Chess and
about life from Leon thank you for
joining us here and well good luck in
the rest of your games thank you thank
you uh Lavon for sure and our we
strongly Echo that it's uh when Lavon is
playing well life is yeah just much more
yeah funny in general yeah it's it's
always worth listening to him but uh
it's uh the challenge there is to
somehow you know learn to not just
listen to him but to take what he says
to heart you know exactly so
um that's that's the hard part there
that's the
what would be the struggle for me for
instance exactly uh Bobby uh MBL has
not in any sense rescued himself but he
has struggled to a uh Queen and partner
end game uh one Pawn down uh this is
going to be a long long yeah we're going
to keep us here for a while yeah exactly
cancel dinner cancel the Opera
you cannot take on H4 obviously or on A2
right now because because of Queen EA
check you could maybe like mate for a
second there I thought maybe there's an
argument to be made for playing king of
Fate but king of Fate just straight up
loses immediately the queen of three
check and suddenly you find yourself
agreeing to a queen trade via either the
E2 square or the B3 square if you go
back to G8 right and that should never
ever I think be any good for black
um so king of faith is unplayable I
think Queen D5 is the best yeah
sorry to interrupt you Peter I agree
with what you're saying anything maybe
maybe we're I didn't realize it's a race
yeah it's actually a race right yeah the
king and pawn end game should be avoided
I agree wholeheartedly but this might
not be one of those that it's just oh
it's so true actually yeah we're Queen
at the same time right yeah we ba G1
happens or BH which one yeah let me
interrupt you for a second do you do
that do you go one two three four five
six seven
you've asked me you've asked me sort of
in time close enough to the process of
me just finishing to do that yeah it
actually kind of happens I don't I don't
count uh from the start I actually just
calculate the variation in my head just
King yeah what about you yeah sir uh I
do king king king move by move I had
always surprised me when I've read these
endgame books where they've advised that
kind of like I've met people that do
that you have yeah I don't know how they
do that I think they're I think they're
just crazy
they'll tell us what you really think
yeah don't hold back
we're not going to see a queen trade
what are we going to see I think you can
keep giving Chucks I mean the engine
does like the move Queen D5 check just
to force the king back
it doesn't have good hiding squares on
this side of the board thank you C3
maybe yes you could play King C3 but
then I keep giving checks and this is
kind of the point if you go this way
because I have access to B5 thanks to A6
you're not hiding oh yeah it's so yeah
give me five Queen A5 yeah yeah so you
just keep going that way so I actually
if I really want to get out of these
checks I have to go to A1
eventually you have to you have to agree
to this okay and then uh after Queen F1
check here check the checks finally die
but you've not made a lot of progress in
the position King's deeply stuck uh in
the in the cave on A1 there yeah again
uh cancel your dinner uh plans folks
because that's going to be a very very
long game you feel that with the extra
Pawn you're fappy and you're a Fab
you've got to play I mean you probably
think you're going to end up drawing but
yeah I've actually uh uh kind of the
needle got moved for me uh in these
types of end games I played I believe I
maybe even mentioned it during the uh
the broadcast this summer I had this
game against uh uh
piano in the I believe the uh World Cup
if I'm not mistaken uh where I made a
kind of a horrendous mistake out of the
opening just blunder something very very
simple
and was pretty much lost but you can
continue fighting he didn't like it for
me I didn't have to resign immediately
and then uh in in mutual time travel
Jitter did not put the game completely
away and we exited the the time travel
uh with me having to defend the three
against two queen ending with the white
king ditters king seemingly pretty safe
and just an outside passer I think on
the C file it was and my assumption was
I will eventually lose this but I am
definitely going to put up a fight
because like it's a green ending right
and I drew it relatively easily and then
I came back home to my room switched the
uh the broadcast on and it just has
zeros it doesn't even work why does a
healthy Pawn up it just says zeros wow
it doesn't give what was you know 0.50
or anything it just says draw right do
not do not fret you will make a draw
here and and that's kind of sort of
educated me on on how those things are
are generally evaluated because yeah the
margins are very wide in between endings
let's just uh interrupt you for a moment
there Peter catch up on this game as we
go to break Hans Neiman did play the
move Bishop E3 he did provoke the move
C5
G4S yeah and they ended up trading the
C6 Pawn for the eight I'm not in love
with this I think four for white yeah
with white I think this is uh
potentially a wrong direction because
once again g67 maybe he thought D7 just
wins because Bishop B6 is coming but
after rookie 6 all of the squares the
bishop can attack the uh the Rooker
covered by the rookanis Yeah and then
eventually you know you start attacking
the bishop you play Queen six you play
B6 and uh watch out yeah the the apology
seven is very vulnerable and he already
has played something else together he
played Bishop Bishop D4 attacking the uh
the pawn on H6 of course
and I mean both rookie 6 and King G8
appear to be very healthy just don't
obviously we're not taking on D6 here to
blunder Bishop takes G7 would be
extremely careless yes but but both of
the very very obvious non-rook takes D6
moves in this position appear to be
quite quite reasonable rookie 6 or King
G8 I don't know which one is stronger I
like your Rook E6 where we're gonna take
a break but we have two exciting games
still ongoing we will see you on the
other side of our break stay tuned
foreign
[Music]
capital of the United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays hosts to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame Cutting Edge exhibitions feature
rare historic chess artifacts paired
with world-class art Innovative
programming explores the intersection of
Chess art and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to round four of the single
cup there are still two interesting
games in progress but before we get back
into the action uh Alejandra is in the
studio with the executive director of
the Saint Louis chess club Tony Rich
Tony welcome to the show we have you on
because everybody wants to know what is
going on in this tournament why did
Magnus withdraw what is the scoop yeah
you know it's the the little story from
today uh Magnus Carlson did indeed
decide to withdraw after round three of
the singfield cup
um magnus's decision to withdraw from
the event or his personal decisions and
until he makes a public statement on the
matter uh we feel it's best to honor his
wishes and and
um we've accepted the fact that he's
withdrawn from the event as well but he
didn't give us any direct reason on why
he did so I think ultimately it's
magnus's decision to come out and give
his reasons I don't want to put words in
his mouth so I'll let him speak on his
own behalf we've noticed that today we
have some Advanced security measures
when it comes to the players tell us a
little bit about that sure I spoke with
Chief tour Arbiter David Sedgwick today
and
um you know the grand chess tour has
prided itself over the past what five or
six years now on on making sure that we
are at the the front Forefront of the
game technologically with regards to our
broadcast and and with regards to our
fair play measures that we Implement in
all of our events whether that happens
to be the Super bet chess classic in
Romania the rapid and Blitz events in
Europe rapid and Blitz events here in St
Louis or even the singfield cup so these
additional security measures were
recommended by David Sedgwick as yet
another way that we can ensure the
Integrity of the game uh tell us about
magnus's future participations both in
the GCC GCT and the St Louis chess club
do you expect them to be coming back
sometime soon yeah absolutely you know
Magnus made it very clear to us that
this was no
um uh reflection on his opinion of the
chess club in fact I think his tweet
said something about he loves to play in
St Louis
um so yeah we're happy to have him back
as well and and hopefully under better
circumstances well thank you Tony for
joining us and giving us that
information lastly just to confirm
what's going to happen with Magnus
results in the tournament so far great
question so since the since Magnus made
the decision to withdraw before the
halfway point of the tournament his
results in the previous games will be
annulled and his results against future
opponents the games just won't occur so
it's in essence this is a tournament of
nine players and the results will be out
of out of eight points total so each day
one player whoever would have faced
Magnus will have a buy a 0.5 for the
round and at the end we will see who the
Victor is based out of eight games
absolutely well thank you for joining us
Tony as we seem to be having a result
here in the game between Hans Neiman and
alireza ferrugia they have drawn their
game via threefold repetition and we
hope to have them in studio for an
interview shortly thank you Tony for
joining us my pleasure thanks Alejandro
thank you Tony for coming out and
publicly addressing the elephant in the
room here uh Peter yeah I it wasn't
something that needed needed to be I
needed to be done and uh exactly thanks
once again for uh to the club for
providing Clarity where Clarity is
available and indeed uh just as we saw
there on the camera a draw by three move
repetition draw Perpetual check for a
very intriguing game and much of the
Intrigue was behind the curtain yeah it
it was left it was left behind the
scenes uh to to a great degree there
yeah there were a couple of very
important turning points a very very
interesting sacrifice on move 17 by Hans
we let's jump eventually it was not
accepted by a biology Reza clearly felt
that this 19 not 17 eyeball he apologize
but after Queen G3 GTA xc4 at least at
the you know I wouldn't call it a
cursory glance we spent some time helped
by engines trying to go there but you
can I'm sure you can dig in even deeper
uh it does appear to be very very
playable for white but perhaps
defensible for black but alireza clearly
felt that engaging with this was a bit
too dangerous played King h8 was I think
objectively in trouble after 96 but Hans
did not capitalize to I think the
fullest extent in particular you have to
question the decision of playing Bishop
D3 here which I think was based on a
miscalculation I would assume that of
course he saw bushed by five but he
thought Bishop 5 was losing to something
right and once the Bishops came off the
board the play just becomes a lot
simpler but then came this extraordinary
opportunity again this whole sacrifice
that we could have achieved in this one
with Queen check that was that was also
a crazy fun yes and so we would have had
sacrifice at Galore as it turns out
it was a well-played game it wasn't a
very very interesting game but uh it
could have been truly spectacular if
some of the options that that were left
left uh unspoken for had been explored
it had been explored over the board but
yeah very very interesting game and I
believe uh we're going to jump over to
you
at some point but not just yet exactly
so so that leaves us pardon me uh with
the one remaining game this is the queen
and pawn ending that oh boy we're again
I think we're going to be here for a
while unless we experience just when we
thought we were done yeah they pull us
back in exactly and this is very much
one of one of those positions which uh
unless Fabi stumbles into a three-fold
somewhere I expect to go on
well forever is not not the right way to
describe it because there is a limit but
uh yeah I assume eventually as Alejandro
has been explaining like you cannot hide
in the center you cannot really hide on
the king side but uh of course uh
Fabiano appreciates that he always can
go for that line
and all the way to A1 he clearly doesn't
want to because it's not how you play
the Queen endings right but if
everything else is a Perpetual whoa
okay just when we thought the checks
were okay that is very surprising to me
uh we thought the checks were going to
come fast and furious for the next 10 20
moves whatever suddenly age six yeah
what is that that looks terrible
that looks I mean the move itself is
understandable you do want to give
yourself perhaps additional Loop to the
king because we were we saw some
positions in which Queen E8 was just
made because H7 is unavailable for the
black king and of course generally
speaking black is very much in favor of
reducing the number of Pawns on the
board but it gives white this hugely
important Tempo to do something for
instance B3 as Yasser is indicating I
mean even if you get well hold on you I
was I was trying to get you oh yeah
Queen takes H4 yeah we've blundered the
A2 Pawn here right then maybe and then I
was going to Checkmate you with Queen E8
and G6 mate oh good thank you I
blundered the A2 pawn and then hd5 and
maybe we can take one A2 next move right
oh hg5 hg5 first yeah
I it didn't fall off the the truck no uh
recently huh Jesus well I mean I have
but in the meantime I did learn how to
avoids
although honestly like HG Queen A2 G6 is
there a Perpetual is there because oh we
do it oh my gosh instantly uh the table
base appeared on my screen looks like
this is because I mean it gives all the
moves as equal and one the first move on
the screen is a6a5 which allows me than
one
is the best side
yeah
I think I think if if A5 and green A1
check lead to the same outcome I pretty
pretty much know what that outcome is I
gotcha gotcha very nice yeah oh my
goodness uh so again are we ready not
ready no now let's let's continue
talking about the screen ending apart
from B3 what else do we like uh well I
was initially drawn to the idea of maybe
giving some checks here to improve the
position of the queen but I don't like
for wide but I don't know what I'm
improving it too like that's the ideal
Square E5 maybe you know it's really
funny but in these Queen endings I
always had that as a general rule the
setting the more centralized better so
E5 D4 D5 those were always the prime
squares yeah and uh
honestly like I was interested in the
idea of just playing ghgh and perhaps
playing Queen D4 but the line that they
have just shown has kind of opened my
eyes to the idea that keeping the pawns
on G5 and G7 favorable for white
actually in some positions still allows
us to develop a very very strong attack
on the king side if we if we get to play
G5 V6 so maybe I'm not sure I'm not sure
but I I still don't like H6 but I think
what it comes down to if we go to move
39 and they have time there I don't
think mvl was an ink out of time travel
move 39 specifically before
um yeah where is it yeah
even further back you know like one one
playback yeah here yeah we've worked on
them so and we all had this position
right and he thought for I think quite a
while and shows specifically the chat
from before not the check from D5 which
would have been everybody's check which
which Alejandro was suggesting was the
strongest but he clearly did not like
something about Queen D5 check and 5v1
again has gone to G2 nmvl once again did
not give a check from if I played h7h6
just now so I think the decision to go
H6 is connected more than anything else
with the fact that he dislikes something
about the position of the queen D5 check
quite intensely
and if you don't have 25 check in this
position maybe you actually play H6
because you just don't like Queen D5 and
nothing else works let me interrupt you
for just a moment uh Peter to say that
in studio with only 100 we have Hans
Neiman
Hans a tough game here against alireza
ferrugia you seem a bit concerned do you
think you missed a chance of course I
missed a chance
doesn't take a genius to figure that out
tell us a little bit through some of
these variations you played this great
move Queen G3 what were you expecting
from here okay this entire game was just
brilliant for me up until Bishop D3 like
Queen G3 and okay let's say King h8 he
played King of [ __ ] no what if he takes
Bishop page six uh-huh
okay let's say G6
okay I don't even need to show
variations you just look at the position
like okay let's say okay only reason
Bishop G5 isn't working immediately
because maybe F6 works right F6 so
fine not this year but just F4 like I
don't like simply F4 and then what is
black going to play F4 or where instead
of Bishop B5 just F4 like what what
what's happening okay
my pieces are literally perfect his
pieces are just terrible I have Bishop
G5 next
except to go like H4 H5 like I'm come on
it has to be lost
like I don't understand what Universe
this is not completely lost for example
let's say King H7 Bishop G5 Queen 8 Rook
D7 Queen D7 Queen H4 Bishop G5 k27 Queen
H4 Bishop six for example so if King
seven does not move then then okay
what's the move uh Queen E7 to go to C5
and then what are you gonna do
how there's absolutely zero way like
this side of the board's cut off like
okay let's say Bishop G5 okay you don't
definitely not let's say queen C5 King
H2 I can't play F6 here
F6 I guess you take the C4 eventually so
let's say queen T5 okay
King H2 for example okay
what are you playing uh yeah I just did
not believe in the position for black
like I just don't see any Universe where
this is a holdable really after like
bishop d8 or something like this okay so
many moves it's not like uh
instinctively I'm like okay what is this
there's no way there's just zero chance
zero chance zero I just don't believe it
dude okay uh so he didn't go before that
he went for King did you expecting a
chain instead of course yes
most the more I expect mostly after 96
okay 95s
okay obviously a bad move
um okay let's let's I can show some
variations there's actually really a
nice variation
let's say instead of um
what was it
instead of
uh okay there's G5 let's say instead of
1995 G5 here yeah G5 so I thought that
either he goes G5 and tries to do
something concrete or it's just very bad
so here uh Even Rick even H4 is a move
here
okay and let's say uh take
you have to go King G7
yes and Rook D3
Rook h8 is the only move I guess
and here I wasn't sure
um here I thought that it maybe wasn't
enough
um
if you go back Peter's asking about H4
Bishop takes D6 first oh yeah this was a
this was a problem yeah no yes just
because you take take exactly maybe I
was trying to make something like this
work but again there was just Bishop E3
simply
ah yes of course Bishop
here I was like okay this is this is
obviously very bad yeah before coming
and you haven't sacrificed material
exactly and uh so he plays Knight T5
which you did not think was a good move
before yeah yeah Rook D4 okay now take
tank yeah 94 of course it's all correct
take take okay and cure Bishop D3
I missed um
uh let's say Bishop five yeah Bishop E5
Queen G5 Rook G4 yeah and I thought I'm
so smart because Bishop G4 F4 right
Queen H5 HD queen d8 queen G4 rigid
Queen F5 but then he has Queen C1 yes
and here I was still King H2
Bishop G4 and then Oh I thought maybe
bishop takes G7 but he just goes back to
G5 I thought I even considered a four
here I considered Queen G4 but it just
wasn't working
uh so then I this was just a very should
have been more
disciplined there with my thought
process but but and okay let's say just
instead of Bishop B3 let's say Bishop E3
yeah Bishop B3 in this position we let's
just game over again
basically right like it's just pure
domination yeah it's a very strong
position for a while you have the pawn
and the power bishop's still strong so
it was based on a miscalculation that
you played Bishop D3 we had a feeling
that you had missed Queen C1 yeah it's
the sort of Queens you want back to G5
it's a weird idea but yeah no I missed
it
I paid the price
well you still managed to hold on to a
draw did you ever feel that you were in
danger I wouldn't say hold on definitely
I wasn't doing holding on uh even after
uh let's say what did I play Rook E3 I
still should have some Advantage right
uh without the Bishops we weren't as
sure I definitely don't think I'm ever
worse here so I think holding on would
not hear for sure yeah for sure for sure
no I was never in any danger
that's for sure I don't think how could
I ever be in danger when I have the D6
Pawn like uh there perhaps I could have
been more precise like
I don't know this this G4 moment maybe
it was a bit hasty
but uh here okay let's say I don't
pledge you for it let's say I play like
of course I'm I should have an advantage
here because
let's say I sit and let's say I go pitch
before okay maybe it's not a huge
Advantage but
I think I have a slight Edge because
this is such a passive position
and then I thought B6
work B3 Rook B8 B3 yes
I wasn't sure I thought maybe bishop
before
but that was a bit and you know always I
always have Bishop take their six ideas
or looming maybe this was the way to
proceed but I definitely think I have an
advantage I just
I didn't use it the right way I'm
curious what is the computer say in this
position yeah what is it I'm just
curious uh this position it gives about
zeros okay so pushing can we go back
just like let's say right after
right after Rook to to E3 Rook to E3
yeah just I'm just curious okay it's
equal well interesting and Bishop E3
what is the evaluation it's like plus
1.5
oh yeah let it think a little bit higher
depth it's probably going to be like
plus two well yeah it's okay Ricky then
Bishop D3 is that's also the only move
wow yes
yeah okay maybe I shouldn't be that
upset but uh
like I felt like I played the opening
really well and uh the the I felt like
the play was flowing quite well but just
it didn't it's similar with aronia whole
game I feel like I'm out playing and
then the the the killer blow wasn't
quite there right Hans we got to ask you
what are the players feeling uh seeing
that Magnus Carlsen didn't show up
before the game today yeah actually it
really uh I was I was like struggling to
even like Focus I was thinking about it
the entire game I was like I've never
ever in my life uh
heard of a top player forfeiting game in
even the world champion okay I don't
know if he said he wasn't going to play
before or after the game but for me to
like see him forfeit the game especially
the first time in his career yeah
it's like like it's just a very very uh
I don't know what's going through your
mind well
I'm speechless to be honest it's like
it's very weird yeah
first he gives up the title which I
thought was first I certainly
was surprised and then now this is okay
I don't want to draw any conclusions but
it's very strange
but at least I got to beat him before he
left that's that's the good thing
absolutely well I mean you must be happy
with this game and certainly with the
quality of your play in this tournament
so far
well who cares about the quality results
is what people remember so uh I uh this
game against the irony in here I think I
should have won both of these games
considering
um the opening chances I got and the
mistakes they made but you know
converting is is a skill and uh at least
I can play decent chess
we're currently on two points out of
three so your Elite has a beautiful
you're on two out of three all of Magnus
Carlson's results will be annulled and I
get the rating right you do get the
ratings
really yes oh that's pretty ridiculous
but wow so oh two okay
yeah I see I guess he just didn't want
me to win the tournament so he had to
leave you know yeah he knew that that
would happen yeah I guess that was the
only reason yes you can't think of
anything else
well Hans uh you think that he has some
kind of personal thing against you why'd
you mention that no I have no idea it
was just that was it's obviously
sarcastic comment yeah because okay like
out of the the four games you know he's
like helping nepo because he lost you
know okay I have no idea
about the anything it's just it's uh
of course I would prefer for the win to
count let's just leave it at that well
accounts for your rating you're still
over 2700 and you're still putting on a
impressive tournament here at the
Springfield cup uh it's okay it's okay
considering my current rating you guys
might think it's impressive but
I'm always striving for more okay well
Hans thanks for joining us here in the
studio certainly we look forward to the
remainder of your games and good luck on
that thank you indeed Hans uh good luck
and thank you for today's very
entertaining uh game uh I guess uh what
we were looking at these whole lines
with Rook G4 hanza from what he
expressed uh he just kind of confirmed
our suspicions yeah but he stopped and
he didn't go any further when he got to
here he didn't really uh consider where
we were just kind of we're we're picking
up the gauntlet and carrying it all the
way down the track and running away with
it I think if we had shown this position
to Hans he would have said oh yeah yeah
yeah
uh let me play for that one as it stands
uh we've got one game remaining here in
this round four and it's this queen
ending but before we get there I think
we have another interview uh so
Alejandra with alireza firoja thank you
guys I'm here with alares of surely a
little bit of the analysis was spoiled
but I was hoping that you could take us
through some deeper lines I was
particularly interested what was your
thought process and your psychological
reaction when he plays Queen G3 it must
have been a move that shocked you
yeah Queen G3 is insane
um I mean he played it also very quickly
I think five minutes maybe he thought
about it
and it is just insane so
um I immediately understood that if I
take this was my plan originally but I
understood that he wants to take
and just play H4 so or F4 H4 and I was
just scared so
it is because some somebody giving them
peace like this then and he there is no
immediate mate then I it means I don't
understand this position so
um I didn't go for this so let me pull
you back you didn't understand the
position and you still felt that you
were too scared to go into a peace up
yeah I just I just trusted him so
um I just wanted to make more play a bit
more so you know this is amazing idea
yeah we've seen through the rapid and
Blitz of that when strong players gave
you pieces or pawns you just took them
what caused you to trust your opponent
today oh yeah he's in a very good shape
so
what can I say I mean he's playing very
good so but I played Knight C5 I think I
am a bit worse okay at least I'm playing
at least here so
um I was happy that he doesn't have
Bishop H6 at least yeah so
um how do you feel about the position
before it's a great move also yeah takes
takes on his exactly exchange is amazing
and Queen F6 yeah he just played quickly
Bishop D3 I didn't understand why I mean
Bishop E3 looked very
very reasonable like very logical I
think everybody will play Visual History
yeah that you get to listen to his
explanation on what he missed yeah
listen um yeah this idea he had it was
weird but uh
um yeah obviously he planted Queen C1 so
yeah which he got in advance right yeah
um so yeah after Bishop Bistro he seems
just equal maybe I was better at some
point they just did give you a little
bit of an edge all the way down when I
think you took an A4 here because after
Bishop before rookie six here here
Bishop C7 they did not like so much
Queen C6 but maybe Chuck and rookie one
and start attacking yes yeah it was a
bit in the shock of Queen G3 I wanted to
make draw and go home so and goal
achieved how do you feel you played in
this game I think I played well but okay
still I was I think much worse so
um I felt that I played very solidly at
least so I I'm happy with my play until
now otherwise I just seem to be in great
shape another game maybe not exactly
perfect for you but you defend it very
well you still think that you're in
great shape yeah I think I'm in a good
shape
um yesterday I played a good game but
nipple also when I lost he played a very
good game so I cannot be very sad about
that so I'm I am happy how these things
going and there are many more rounds to
go so absolutely well thank you for
joining us here in the show we still
have one Queen end game guys so don't go
anywhere we'll be here another five or
six hours but thank you for joining us
in the show alireza I have a question
for you please uh if you don't mind and
you mentioned also the queen C1 I'd just
like to ask your your opinion if uh he
had tested you in this position with
Bishop E5 and Rook G4 this whole line
because Peter and I we just went down
this rabbit Hall and we want to share
our analysis says just wonder what your
opinion was on this outcome like 24
specifically like this position Queenie
four or five Queen D4 did you did you
consider it and if you did what did you
think this was like no it didn't I
didn't see anything I mean during the
game I didn't even see the idea of Rook
G4 F4 so
really yeah it's it's very tough to see
I mean it's not very logical no I mean
Rook G4 takes F4 it's not a common
common stuff so when did when did you
notice it no I never noticed anything he
told me after the game
an honest man okay this answers our
question I guess
thank you alireza and very good luck to
you and your remaining games be very
hard to put the band to the test and I
didn't even see F4 very very nice uh
anyway we had a lot of fun at least
analyzing that we hope you enjoyed our
analysis because Rook G4 that's a very
unusual double exchange sacrifice we do
have one game remaining and as
Alejandro was saying we may be here for
a few hours but uh with the with this
inclusion at age six I feel like mvl has
given Fabi chances I think white will
stabilize and then this becomes a very
very difficult ending because if you if
you can't drive the king back like even
if that King gets to A5 well that's just
a dream why just why just wins even if
the entire King side disappears like I
remember I was very happy with myself
now I probably would assume that it's a
very easy technical Victory but uh in an
important Junior tournament I once won
an Ending game like this with like two
against one on one side in the black
king somewhere in the center I think it
was even close like maybe around f77
squares okay and I was I managed not to
allow it to get any further and I kind
of very slowly got my king to A5 and
collected the uh the a pawn and one from
there so those are extremely annoying
and The King The King side hasn't even
disappeared entirely yet exactly uh so
yeah I think I think 5b's favorite from
here for sure uh and like a win for
white is favorite over a draw obviously
fabi's favorite he's a born-up exactly
what I mean is even two wonderful now
yeah but what I mean is I I think you
win more of these than you draw exactly
but none of that is a foregone
conclusion of course this is this is
still a queen ending which you you can
definitely misplay it and uh Alejandro
the computer is probably going to make
fools of uh both Peter and I with the
claims what's going on
1.4 says cancel your dinner
uh because we're gonna be here a while I
mean there's a lot of checks there's a
lot of time for both players we're past
move 40 vaccine with 45 minutes 5A with
21 minutes and remember they get an
extra 30 seconds every move so you could
give a check here you could give a check
here you could give a check on G6 they
all seem to not lose immediately uh this
one looks like the most logical to me
um you could go forward you could go to
B3 they're about the same you kind of
run out of checks quickly in this
position
for example if you could check this way
I can go up if you go check this way
then I start hiding on A3 and because I
have the extra resource of B4 or queen
B4 yeah it's a huge big difference
before then now I can hide in this
position but you know you can still just
take on H6 and force me to prove the
pawn which is going to be very long you
have to create a pass ball and you have
to make sure that your king doesn't get
caught in Perpetual checks so it's still
it's still quite a while now for the
time being there are options you can
also play the move Queen E4 check as you
guys mentioned
terms to analyze in this position right
but it's all at some point gonna start
looking the same
very good and we do have the human move
yeah 36 chosen yeah and uh yeah there's
a lot of play left and both of them
still have plenty of time and VL on a
you know whopping 44 minutes by move 45.
uh it's it's going to take a while for
us to reach any kind of a conclusion but
I feel like it's just a very very
dispiriting defense in front of
and uh
anything to be said in this even though
King B3 King D3 was clearly indicated by
the chess engine as Alejandro was
speaking there I must say that for
myself I would find myself drawn to the
move Queen C3 if solely for the reason
I'm threatening mate yeah I think it
might be useful for us to actually
provoke G7 takes H6 so I'm not sure I'm
in love with the idea of allowing Queen
takes which I think probably happens
here because everything else looks
potentially amazing yeah I'm not saying
I'm not saying white is suddenly not
better or anything right no but I think
in general I would probably prefer the
forest black to take with the pawn
because it gives like the black king
really feels very very fair yeah yeah
less of a shield yeah and and having
sort of additional checks to the black
king along the way allows us sort of
further down the line it allows us for
an easier way let's say to optimize Our
Queen position by giving those like
stairwell checks and yeah and getting to
the squares that we want to get to very
very useful we possibly I'm entirely
wrong it's very impossible no I I think
in the queen endings
um having these as you say the the
latter checks that allow us to
reposition Our Queen with a gain of
tempo involves taking away the the pawn
Shield there so you're absolutely right
G7 takes H6 I don't hate Queen C3 at all
I think 3 is a very logical move as well
but uh you had to choose I'm probably
choosing the ones that Allah will force
GH exactly exactly okay again and uh and
as Alejandro was saying
um
be prepared for a very long yeah and I
remember once again my my worst fate
ever as a commentator was this Vicon Zay
where Anish giri the Dutch Grand Master
was leading the tournament he was
playing against Wesley so it was the
only game in the playing Hall they've
been playing for six and a half hours
big audience we couldn't say good night
and go on at the dinner it was a queen
ending
and Anish was enjoying the extra Pawn
so there I was trying to explain explain
and then I said I just I just give up
turned on the engine and it was -47.
the move was made and it was Triple
zeros another move was made it was minus
47. they just threw this back and forth
and I couldn't even explain why one one
move made it minus 47 in the other maybe
I think that was maybe last year when we
were doing it from the from the previous
video maybe in May uh I think we had
this discussion with you and we came to
a very important conclusion which I want
to repeat for our audience here because
maybe you haven't been watching then so
the trick about learning how to you know
the way to approach the queen endings is
not to play them I think you remember we
got to this game right it's very very
important to just not play them if you
don't want to feel like an idiot right
because I think the absolute best chess
players in the world in particular
unlimited time are going to make
consistent fools of themselves right in
complicated win endings because it's
just like there's no terrain you feel
comfortable with like unless it's
completely winning from the get-go
completely drawn from the get-go it's
just so difficult to figure out what you
should be striving for like which
squares are better like how to construct
situation where you can avoid perpetuals
whereas the computer will just
immediately tell you yeah you can go on
this like 25 move long maneuver which
ends with with black running out of
checks so either don't play them or if
you do play them just completely ignore
the fact that you've made like 25
game-changing mistakes in the last 27
years because you will have exactly by
the way we do see Queen C3 Queen C4
let's just refresh for everybody our
current standings Peter with uh well the
uh three results uh shall we say after
the forfeit yes so far acquired I mean
nothing nothing like having a new report
yeah like I I just completely stopped
there you know the idea that there has
been a quiet day yeah
uneventful uh yeah an interesting game a
day but in terms of Chess results there
was this very exciting game between Hans
Neiman but the rest so far has been uh
very beautiful levon's game did not
really take off at any point and Jan's
game while extremely important to the
theory of the Catalan absolutely
finished in 20 minutes yeah as both
players showed incredible homework in
that particular game we are now in this
uh what we might call the fourth phase
of the game these Queen endings and what
I mean by that
I read books which basically said
there's the opening phase of the game it
was the middle game phase there's the
end game phase and then there are queen
and pawn end games the fourth phase
where a lot of the things that you
learned about the first three phases you
just have to throw out and I remember
the two volume book by Alexandra alakaim
best games he explains that he's uh
three pawns down and this queen ending
and he's losing but no it is much worse
in an ending uh Queen and ending he
sacrifices one pawn and then he's got
some chances two pawns this has proved
his chances and three pawns down now
finally it's a draw
yeah it's like what
it was uh in the meantime uh
it appears that the engines start
disliking this very very dramatically
and in fact I think your queen C3 Queen
C4 and mvl sorry and Fabiano's frequency
for I think I'm I I can maybe now
explain why he chose this yes but it's
very specifically because he has this
Quincy for check which he's already
played right and now he's defending it's
a very very useful Square on C4 which
allows us to prevent any kinds of I mean
a lot of the checking squares have now
been covered exactly and we're also very
very firmly controlling the H4 Pawn
meaning that there's really no counter
play there's no way to blunder our uh
our Pawn on the other side and it
appears that the engines are beginning
to take a bit of a dive here after the
move exactly between before so Fabi is
doing this right and now somewhat
shockingly I just want to play King B3
King A4 King A5 and take on A6 not so
shocking yeah and it's it's difficult to
stop because the queen on C4 will take
away so many of the checks right that
black generally has available it really
is is uh controlling as you say so many
of the checking squares and doesn't
allow any of this counter play stuff I
mean if the King was on H5 we might be
talking about a race but you're never
getting your king to H5 and as you say
in the meant meanwhile I have a very
straightforward idea yeah it's a king
goes to the A6 Pawn Yeah and uh weirdly
the more I tried to calculate this the
more I came to the conclusion that sort
of regardless of where you start from we
are pretty much going to get the
following position let's just make some
moves quickly six all right
I go B3 you give me a check the only one
in the position I go to E4 you give me a
check the only one in the position you
actually drive me to A5 yeah and then
you go Queen d8 check and weirdly after
King takes A6 Queen A8 check okay it's
somewhat difficult uh uh and uh it looks
like it might just be a draw now judging
by what I see on my screen because King
if I clean EA check I think Queen I
don't know what this doesn't do this
doesn't work that's Queen C6 there right
yes I was I thought I thought this was
very clear I thought I can play Queen E8
and prevent you from reaching the A4
Square
and Aha and then let's say if you play
King A5 I give another check from A8
okay you play Queen A6 and I give a
check from D5 okay and I thought maybe
this is smart but once again on my
screen there I can see that Queen D5 is
exactly the same in quality as G7 G6 so
it is uh and and I want to refer I want
to refer our viewers to up my previous
statement about queen king queen endings
I have already made a complete fool of
myself in like every single sentence I
saw that I said during this speech I
support you all right yeah like it's
just uh I don't like this last move
though even before or King E7 before
push the pawns baby but push seven goes
against some of the things that I was
taught at King and games which is the
closer your king is to the center which
is usually great the harder it is for
you to give checks because you will
always have to worry about a counter
check right it feels unnatural to me to
put the king further into the center
actually I was going through those
variations uh the computers wanted to
force you to go all the way to the pawn
hunt actually starting with the move
Queen G6 anyway but that's because
they're computers and they can see far
far away that it's going to be difficult
for white to make progress they weren't
giving zeros by any stretch of the
imagination even after capturing on A6
but this is so beyond human
you take so they want the engines are
defending this by forcing you to take
the A6 yeah but I think that's because
you haven't actually forced them to get
there because once you get there as I
said like at some point you interpose
with the queen and the engine says
blundering a queen in one and making any
other move are all the same I think that
position is lost I think it's just that
we haven't gotten there yet and once you
force the engine to calculate it just
says no perpetual
I'm sort of pretty sure pretty sure
about it because I once again I I can
see the table base on my screen pretty
much so
I think this is done I don't understand
why it's done but it appears to be
completely dead like if you if you and
and a VL appears to be agreeing like
he's trying something with the King
closer to uh closer to the pawn but that
will just make it much harder for him to
give checks I think this is a worse try
a worse try for Emma yeah I think my
bringing is the the king over to the
queen side I don't think this works yeah
I'm not really sure where he's going
either
yeah where the King on D7 is extremely
vulnerable to a counter Chuck yeah right
I think his idea maybe he actually is
after King A4 to play uh Queen H5
uh as the engine seemed to suggest uh at
least stopping King A5 but yeah you have
to assume that after Queen takes A6 you
lose
um because I don't think you're getting
like Queen H4 and yes we know now that
if the king gets the B8 that will be a
draw yes but
is it yeah should be possible so we
haven't we have a table base so we don't
have to look like fools for the rest of
the day right this one is winning yeah
this one's winning but let's play Queen
B7 Check Yes uh King G8
Queen takes G7 and King C8 is it still
waiting yes okay okay still winning with
most moves I think the draw and for I
know it's a difficult thing to believe
but if you start with this King on A1
this part on A3 and this Pawn on B2 this
king is already on B8 that's actually
just a draw it's surprisingly difficult
for white to push both spawns even
though they're too connected extra pass
Pawns in an end game it's very difficult
for white to advance without leaving the
king undefended
but in this particular position I guess
because of the particular positioning of
the pieces you're just not on time as
black and this is exactly where we're
going Queen H5 already on the board we
know that Queen A6 is winning
particularly here
but I would assume it's not the only
winning attempt that being said it's the
most direct right yeah you can you can
wait for a while because black cannot
really defend against Queen takes A6
we've established that if you put the
queen on back on the sixth rank King A5
oh we know we know it's stable base
winning the thing is I the reason I know
that A and B free connected past pawns
Queen end game is a draw because Favi
told me yeah so that's how I know that I
didn't give us a draw right I was like
Bobby's very well aware that sometimes
those positions are drawn he might not
want to test if that particular position
is a draw or not right very fair yeah I
think I think he would be quite quite
worried but the thing is you you do at
some point have to make progress and uh
you're also a bit stuck here with white
because if you allow the the king to
cross to B7 uh you're going to be very
unhappy about that like if if the king
actually gets to B7 your winning chances
I think uh do take a bit of a hit
um so happy or not I think he will end
up just deciding to take the plunge here
take on A6 take on G7 and go from there
and uh
take the yeah you you've given yeah
yesterday I gave a check from A7 and
suddenly it's a draft between takes you
seven
which is a kind of a shocker right it's
it's the same position one tempo down
you played Queen A7 King C8 Queen takes
G7 and then I could have played Queen B7
King d8 yeah and here if you don't take
27 you're still winning if you take on
G7 here
apparently Queen H2 Queen C4 and queen
E4 now hold everything else loses but
three moves now hold so the margins what
we were also telling our audience the
margins are unbelievably unbelievably
just as demonstrated inadvertently I
might uh I might add uh demonstrated by
yours truly wow uh
but after Queen takes if I don't go upon
grabbing with Queen takes G7 humanly
humanly it's very difficult not to take
that pawn because then it becomes a race
and what should I sorry what what what
should I be doing no you should be
taking but you should be starting with
Queen B7 uh that's just the whole yeah
it's it's hugely important to have that
King further away from the coroner not
on C8 but on d8 and that makes and now
none of those moves for some reason none
of those moves are helping they were
helping earlier but they're not now and
that's why we have the great coach
Alejandro Ramirez in studio to explain
to us all about these green endings yeah
A and B versus King Ollie uh what's that
no a student came up to me and said I
wanted to learn uh how to win queen
versus Rook against an engine right I
looked at my student
saw that we had an hour's lesson
scheduled and I just said let's go to
lunch
engine yeah
it was explained to me yes I can show
the critical position and I can show the
winning move right but even from there I
suspect I will occasionally still fail
to beat the engine despite knowing
there's a very specific position for
those of you uh in our audience who can
because we can't really organize it we
don't have a rook on the board and it
will be difficult for us to artificially
organize it on the board at some point
it gets to the position where you have a
king on G5 and the Queen on F7 right
with a stronger side yeah and black has
a king on d8 and The Rook on B6 yeah and
in that position
the way to win is to play Queen F7 F4
and nothing like everything else also
wins but slower and eventually you'll
have to play Crazy Fast yes and after
Queen F4 somehow this is a Tuk Swang and
whatever black does this coordination
between the King on G8 and Rook on B6 is
broken and everything falls apart
but if you don't know of the move Queen
F4 against an engine which will never
blunder a rook against you right you
might never make any progress exactly
and I personally have once failed to win
rook and Rook against sir queen against
stroke I had a very very nice round of
form in that end game in 2001 and 2002.
in 2001 I failed to win it on the
strongest side against Boris girlfriend
in the World Cup uh quarter-final and in
some point boys actually blundered The
Rook against me and I didn't find the
check which one
we were on seconds like in my slide
defense or playing on increment for 50
moves by that point uh and then in 2022
I played in the Prague Eurotel trophy
the the tournament organized by Bessel
called right and I lost from this from
the weaker side I lost it then game to
tapalov in like 10 most so I I perfect
result with no efforts yeah perfect
results half a point out of two and
never never looked remotely convincing
from either side like I I still remember
that particular sequence of yeah
oh boy you got a queen H5 uh it's
storytelling time your story there uh
Alejandro about your students saying
please teach me coach about the queen
versus Rook reminds me of uh the story
of Miguel quinteros
so Miguel quinteros uh is playing in the
tournament of Buenas iris is a knock on
the door it's noon and it's his good
buddy uh Sergio rubinetti they've been
the closest of friends since
um Elementary School they grew up
together they did everything together
and rubenetti comes he says miguelito
You must help me you must help me
prepare me at three o'clock I have a
game with Bobby Fischer tell me what I
have to do how do I defend against Bobby
Fischer with the black pieces
and what did Brother miguelito say to
him look
Sergio there is nothing I can do to help
you let me take you to lunch let's have
a nice leisurely lunch together and
later this evening you can tell me how
close you came to making a draw
what are brothers for right Alejandro
where's the lie though
it was the truth and it happened exactly
like that Sergio came really close
really close
it's funny it's funny because it's true
it's often the case so we're waiting for
Queen takes A6 uh Alejandro hasn't been
played yet on five years down to eight
minutes and these are the final minutes
he will have he will get his allotted
half a minute 30 seconds for each move
that they made but he is down on the
clock and mvl is actually now that we've
established this is what he wants this
is actually quite clever uh the idea of
bringing the king over and then just
forcing you to play that two against nil
uh position you know position even if
it's lost you know your opponent will be
freaked out by the prospect of you know
stepping accidentally walking into a
table basement and he's not playing
Queen takes A6 to play the move A3 I was
actually thinking about this move simply
to pass see what black does and perhaps
uh one of his pieces will fall into a
worse position right because at this
moment you actually have to decide what
to do
king theater King E8 seemed to be the
moves otherwise because the queen is
Canada it has to keep attacking the pot
on H4 so I don't take here and at the
same time it has to keep my king from
Crossing on the fifth rank so the queen
is perfectly pleased uh hang on nothing
that doesn't make any sense right that
allows queenga check both of those moves
King d8 allows Queen G8 check yes that
is true oh oops that doesn't make any
sense right and like and the engine
doesn't play Queen GH check on my screen
it doesn't play Queen j8 check on my
screen either because it thinks that
this is just more difficult to win
what what on Earth I mean what oh come
on oh come on
you got a free day he could have come
and joined us in the comments exactly
hey good God now that each player is
going to have a free day there you go it
can be a guest commentator
hey we got to talk to Tony about this
but change the contract so this is not
good how do you not play not play Queen
G8 checking Queen takes G7 but also
black never allows it like imagine being
black in this position and actually
giving up the pawn on G7 with check no
like I would never allow impossible
right right imagine I'm playing G6 in a
heart but everything else is worth oh
sorry worse yeah
it's okay yeah he's gone
yeah he's gone G6 Queen G6 is apparently
much stronger because the greenlandish 4
is completely locked out and you will
get mated I hate Queen end games yeah
yeah I just just don't just don't be
here like just don't get there yeah just
never ever get there Queen 167 King B5
now and the point is to keep the queen
is so completely out of play that we can
we can actually go for like mating
constructions oh my goodness yeah
yeah I mean no no no like come on how is
houseking d8 the strongest move in the
position there's like you you can't do
that truly yeah G7 G6 you cannot do that
Ben Stokes as the crow goes yeah for
those of you who who didn't follow a
broadcast that Peter and I had a
Bucharest it was just the most wonderful
wonderful wonderful interview with
Shakira memedarov after his game with
nepo where he came in and he said oh I
played a wonderful game I'm so Cloud uh
you know all I want to do is play good
chess that's what I live for good chess
I don't care about too much but good
chess and then one after another he
overlooked this he overlooked that I
mean finally after one of the last you
know major oversights come on
come on
come on it should be available as a gift
to all the chess lovers like absolutely
it has to be a kind of a service
provided by somebody just just make this
into a gif and distribute it as widely
as possible because it's one of the one
of the most I heard myself wonderful one
of the most wonderful moments of all of
my years yes broadcasting now that
you've mentioned it I I have a couple of
good ones uh what was your worst moment
oh I think it was when you played with
Lawrence Trent I remember yeah
that was made into a viral video Even
and you have to understand like the
depth of our bond with Lawrence to just
fully appreciate the pain of office
politics being what they are yes the
pain of what happened there I can only
imagine I can only imagine uh your worst
uh moments as a commentator Alejandra
where are you getting everything wrong
it all goes bad it all goes out oh that
that's happened many many years like
adamant about a move I'm trying to think
though like a specific moment
um I'll come back to you with this one
okay
in a way I can actually it will be
slightly from from left field but uh the
absolute worst moment in terms of like
quality of broadcast
wasn't even necessarily our fault I was
commentating on the first uh Carlson uh
no the second castle in Sochi with uh
Sophie Lee yeah and uh that was a
reasonably polished broadcast we had a
whole production team in a separate room
close to us but in a separate room and
we had like you know ad rolls running
every hour or so and then you remember
the game everybody remembers that game
the game that could have turned the
match when the when the score was level
and King yeah and Magnus played King D2
and there was this like a minute and a
half during which Richard was thinking
about a 584 right and we were on an
outbreak we were we were the only stream
in the world at the moment which
actually went went on an ad break before
Magnus played King D2 and then I saw
King G2 it took me like 20 seconds to
realize that this is a game-changing
blunder oh no and I started like waving
my hands around like we need to stop the
ads but no the entire role played and
when we came back on air yeah it's gone
it's gone it's just gone yeah but in the
meantime we are uh I mean G6 has been
played Fabi did collect a couple of
Pawns and he has played King B5 as well
maybe not yet maybe he has no sorry not
yet but he will I mean nobody not plays
King B5 okay nice that's just uh that
that's funny um you know my queen G1 in
this position one of the five winning
moves one of the five is Queen G1 no way
that's a winning move oh wouldn't even
come anywhere near me
no no yeah but I mean yeah I mean all
the winning moves you can sort of
understand that maybe Queen F7 and queen
G7 are not spoiling very much they don't
but you always play but you're always
blinking before yeah you're always
playing I mean if you can move the king
forward start creating those threats and
not a single check needs to be
calculated right that's the one you pick
like you you just know it's correct yeah
you know it's winning it can be fine uh
my worst moment uh uh actually it's a
hilariously funny uh worst moment as a
broadcaster I was doing commentary for
the Vikings
and it was a game between uh Jehovah and
Vasily ivanchak Jehovah was just
completely crushing him and somehow
vasili was just holding on grimly got
himself into an equalish Rook ending
that was better for Jehovah Jehovah
offered a trade of Brooks to go into a
king and pawn ending which
is looking at it what why would you
trade Rooks is this winning
and while I was trying to determine
whether or not this was a good decision
it came that uh vasil he took the rook
and drove uh immediately resigned
I think I don't know I don't remember
the position but I remember this
happened what do you mean you resign you
recapture The Rook you resign later but
he resigned immediately and I was trying
to figure out why he resigned
immediately and there suddenly was a
Vizio
so vasil comes in
Cecil could you show us again man when
the pieces are in front of him Yvonne
Chuck is like a dolphin in water yes
everything makes perfect sense thank you
very much because
could you explain for our audience
why he resigned and he went
13 move variation
and I said okay the seal for our
audience could you do it move by move he
said okay talk talk talk talk talk talk
talk talk
two bridesmaids you can't protect wins
any good Grandmaster would have seen it
instantly
oh thank you very much missile so I say
I'm gonna go to on break while I'll take
the sword out but it's just been planted
in my stomach in the meantime Yvonne
sokolov is watching the show he's dying
and with hilarity at my distress the
next day at breakfast Yvonne sarage came
to Yvonne sokoloff and said well why did
jevova
resigned right away
so it had a ripple it was very very good
did he play King B5 of course yeah go
move there wow now we have Maxine deep
in thought but the engines well not the
engines the table base I don't have to
ask the engines anymore say this is uh
winning already for the white side we do
know that sometimes when the king
Heights on B8 against these two points
it's a draw the reason it's a draw is
because the queen gets in time in
certain structures to harass the king
just in the right way and if you
sometimes Force the B Pawn to go ahead
of the a pawn then you start getting
checks like for example if I could give
you a check here on D5 force you to go
King A4 Queen D1 King A5 Queen D5 B5
then go Queen D2 sometimes those
positions are drawn depending on where
the king is especially if it's on the a
or b files but right now you can't get
there without getting mated so this is
probably not a difficult win for Fabi
because if you get the queen 2b6 and cut
the king out then that's easily winning
you never get any of those constructions
uh let's pick a move Queen F4 uh just
throw throw it out there and show me how
white is going to advance and combine
the checks and the pawns so this one in
particular yeah this is also an
important moment you could go check and
check back and drive the king away but
you can also start like this because in
this particular one yeah if you go here
you have Queen A6 right yeah King A6 yes
and we just kind of give them a yeah and
if you're a passive you just get made it
there are no stale Matrix
um which is also important uh and any
check on
yeah so I check on F1 yeah
sorry sorry so I have to go Queen F7 now
yeah but now you're too passive and now
you just start pushing the Pawns yeah
there is no immediate way to to trade
queens or win but you can even play
three a four and yeah there's only one
check on A7 and you'll have to go away
again yeah I see you're just not winning
yeah it is winning
oh my and from the grand chest tour uh
perspective again it's a fantasy game
for Fabi exactly Fabi needs a huge win
to get to the podium and for mvl who is
actually the grand Chester standings and
there we have it and this is what we're
talking about 26 and a half points for
mvl again we know the winner gets 13 and
12 and all that rest Ali Reza at that
draw today uh important for him levonne
Wesley Wesley by the way having a result
yeah he's a plus one he's diaper first
yeah and also one thing that we have to
mention uh is that Magnus is out of the
tournament exactly so you have to assume
quite a lot of points you returned sort
of returned into the system there
because Magnus seemed to be in uh in in
decent shape in this tournament and that
would have finished I would assume
somewhat some as well and there you saw
the therapy score of 20 and a half so
again he needs a first or second yes and
he needs to see Ali Reza and mvl getting
third fourth and lower uh for him to
really have a chance at the Grand chess
tour uh championship
five when are the players going to be on
an increment well actually they already
are but he's down to five minutes but
it's from this point onwards I think uh
his play will be uh reasonably
understandable so he can he can actually
amass a mass sometimes yeah and bl has
played uh queenbee's sorry uh 77.
with that and uh
yeah I I instantly start you know being
very interested in trying to win the
game on the sport with mates right with
mates like Queen six and then King A6
and try to calculate that to the end
Queen C6 yeah let's let's try it let's
just check if you go King B8 yes I think
I can play King A6 I don't see yeah it's
just the good anyway you can play Queen
E7 but 27 actually probably does allow
some kind of a queen trade right Queen
B5 Check Yes and again I think I want
only Square correct King oh actually
even here I can't trade Queens yeah well
you can't force the trade yeah that's
what I meant yeah yeah I I don't seem to
be able to triangulate in a way that
would trade Queens but we know this is
winning we can once again we can play uh
A3 A4 somewhere and uh April right now
yeah but he also played A4 straight away
he he is very satisfied with the
situation where the queen is on H4 uh
having having no chance to give exactly
uh so yeah he is just continuing to push
Phil feels absolutely no need to
to do anything forcing just yet there's
a funny line I've just calculated please
Peter Queen E7 yeah it looks Flex placed
well let's play Queen B6 check okay uh
King A8 and I think again yes
that's Bart okay I wanted to go King A6
here and then I thought Queen takes
before
Queen A7 made okay uh okay I'm I'm
rescued there for a second there because
I thought this is cute this is cute I
thought okay Queen C6 check
uh can be a green B5 check
and then King A8 yeah and then the King
goes back yeah because the pawn ending
is uh the pawn ending is losing losing
but yeah but here actually I have made
here I have Queen E8 Queen C6 it was
such a nice uh attempt yeah okay nothing
works yeah yeah you can actually win
like this I think after a for Queen E7
Queen B6 A4 on the board Queen e 277
yeah that's our analysis board
um you're in mvl shoes uh Alejandra
what's the trickiest line what can you
do to make your opponent's life that
much more difficult and miserable
there's not a tricky line you just play
a move and hope that your opponent
blunders at this point because there's
no setups right there's nothing that you
can do to your position that will
improve your chances just pick a random
Central position for the kick for the
queen to go to where it's not getting
traded immediately right right because
that's what you want to do you want to
avoid the trade that's why Queen E7 is
clever that's why I think uh Queenie
blonde maybe one the engine was saying
Queen H2 or something just move the
queen somewhere you cannot be traded
right and then hope your opponent
blunders into a stalemate this is the
only way that you can fight right now
right I mean a desirable move like
centralizing your queen is one of the
problems that we can we force the
traders to this and then we give a check
from C5 from the game ends or what
you're showing yeah
it isn't uh so bad either all of those
things yeah yeah Queen C King A7 Queen
C5 check so uh
unfortunately bringing your queen into a
centralized square like D4 and that's
why you're saying Alejandra just pick a
let's say from uh from afar go go go go
go do it just some Galaxy just let me
check this for a second Queen H2 yeah
only basically only the moves that
produce a check win like if you make a
quiet move here you're no longer winning
I mean nobody makes a quiet movement but
just to illustrate this is yeah 26 is a
draw now for whatever reason win H5 and
yeah once the checks start like once you
once you've allowed the black queen to
start producing checks without pushing
the king back to the back rank
you you you're no longer winning but
obviously nobody nobody plays queenies
not only Queen H5 you put the queen E6
move on the board
there's something smarter
I mean there's more than one draw yeah
somehow clearly the move Queen D2 guys
come on
how are you missing this verse obviously
Queen D2 is a drug quiet room is met by
another quiet move yes I have no idea
why this would be a draw right but like
why yeah
but it is it's just this yeah so once
again this is just illustrating just how
poorly the queen is placed on H4 because
all of these positions yeah like if you
could play Queen T2 here once again
maybe Queen H4 G2 right now is a draw
because I don't think it's you know I
don't think the White Queen is worse
placed on E6 than it is on G6 and you're
absolutely correct if if black could
teleport that Queen to D2 right now it
would be a Droid it's just a draw
it's it's such a cruel game chess yeah
this is just a draw this is a drawer I
couldn't draw
thank you for coming yeah
I remember the new and chess article by
uh Dr John Nunn where he was using the
table bases to express how two versus
one in the queen ending and I just I
remember my jaw just dropping on the
table this cannot be true
shout out to Mr not a doctor not
actually what an influence what a great
attacking player and I learned a lot
from all of his books agreed but I did
make the mistake of buying one
particular book
oh that was a challenge
no it was Secrets
my God 400 page tomb I bet you gained
rating points for having stress I don't
remember any of those positions not a
single one of those positions so I
remember
I bought it like an 11 or 12 year old
kid oh Queen seems to be on the board in
the meantime no he played Queen 77 Queen
C6 can be it already oh okay all of that
has been sorry Let me refresh
there was a plan
yeah and once again now some Quiet Moves
actually do when yeah 95 I think he
played which is winning it gives some
space to the king as well you have to be
careful not to play something like King
four because Queen A7 is just a
repetition well King V6 yeah four is
also an issue
um just a quick question for yourselves
uh advancing the pawns uh is undesirable
a move like A4 A5 is A5 is a draw yeah
it's a draw it's a draw just a draw yes
of course obviously
my brain Hurts by my beard yeah if I
couldn't check and we just we just never
run out of no King B6 Queen E7 quiet
move ah okay all that all that all that
all done I got to get this again
I suggested the move A5 that I've been
told that this was a draw because after
queen king B6 and the only move between
the seven only move and that
only move yeah only move absolutely only
move Queen E7 so I get in the advanced
A5 I get in the advanced B6 and I've
thrown away my win I haven't done that
yes correct
next question next question yes next
next question moving moving swiftly on
both of you are off my Christmas
your Christmas cardless both I I advise
you to make it up with Mr stockfish
but instead genius that he is yeah
Queen D5 and this is one of the winners
yes this is one of the winners
[Laughter]
no I think I think I can explain it I
think I think the point is we're passing
the move and we're also somewhat
improving the situation of our King so
that uh we will have checks from the
back like if you play I don't know we
need to check here for instance okay I
have I play queen king B6 King B6 you
don't hide on A5 you think I think I
play King B6 so play Queen F2 check here
okay and
okay I'm confused because everything is
winning but not not in the way I thought
my point was more that my point was
completely nonsense let me just stop
you you had me uh convinced right after
this very moment that you started I I
had a point and then was gone I believe
I I held my breath and anticipate
you guys have the exact same type of
ways I have no I I mean I I need you to
put it into words Alejandra what is
white trying to achieve what is black
college okay so white is trying to make
he's trying to make a queen
excellent if he doesn't make a queen he
can't win Checkmate his opponent
he can't win well you can win by
checkmating his opponent oh excellent
yes those are the two plants okay two
plants yes yes black yes sorry not to
get checkmated
those are the plans there is no strategy
anymore this is why this is such a
difficult game to navigate for us right
right because it just comes down to
sheer absolute calculation move by move
and compared to engines well we suck at
it so yeah and I I want to say the more
I look at this and the more I look at
the winning lines on my screen the more
I think this is far from over no no no
we're not we're not I don't think at any
point we've called that five is for sure
winning this we know it's winning but at
some point I thought it was like why it
had enough coordination to prevent any
kind of uh like immediate stability for
black and we'll just win in the next
five moves by giving mate or trading
Queens but exactly that doesn't seem to
be the case it's still a kind of a long
and tortuous process and uh
but it's so difficult from the Black
Point of View also to avoid uh allowing
these kind of mating ideas you can't you
can't just throw your queen for example
the E2 check and uh if you
go back there will be some sequence that
allows a force trade of uh yeah my point
here the one that I meant and the one
that I almost tried explaining to you
and then realized I'm an idiot we need
to be sick yes first of all I blunted
queen F2 so I thought Queen E3 okay and
my idea was to play King A6 very cool
and if you give a check from me too I
can play Queen B5 for B5 whatever we we
saw that yeah whatever along the way
there is Queen H6 check here which
drives my king back again or the screen
A7 check and the king is driven back
again uh so
um I haven't thrown the win away
apparently because my screen tells me so
right but I hope you didn't make the
progress but I also made zero progress
exactly
but we all thought Queen D5 was a
marvelous centralizing move and uh yeah
Queen and we all think played Queenie
age judging by the the release movement
yeah this eye yeah I think it's all the
same because King B6 Queen E3 we're
still not making any significant
programs but excuse me why aren't I just
hiding my king I think we should be yeah
and the engine is very much in favor of
actually just pushing it on A5 and then
perhaps playing before B5 and some
positions and making progress that way
well just a moment I do have this
massive threat of trading queens and
probably I'm provoking you to move your
queen back to E7 or or down to E3
um yeah you need to do something about
the community pardon me Queen E3 loses
on the spot yeah this this is unplayable
because we get to trade Queen straight
away via one of those squares so yeah
queen queen E7 or queen E1 maybe or
somewhere we need one maybe
yeah hold on and now King A6 is winning
King A6 because then I have my queen oh
no 28 is also yeah why do I try to be
clear I just just shut up no I like I
liked your advice don't get into
agreement you know as a good as a good
coach you know uh coach what do I do in
this queen ending don't get there
uh remember and yeah I thinking A5
played by by 5B
no he played King B6 like trying to
judge from that overview is difficult
also winning well of course also winning
everybody I think it's time that we take
a little break for ourselves and uh
we're feeling a little loopy in this
queen of power and game but we will be
back for uh the finish of this round
four please stay tuned absolutely
thank you
[Music]
hey St Louis the Ascension Charity
Classic presented by Emerson is back
this September don't miss the excitement
when the PGA toured Champions best
compete again all for charity September
9th through the 11th at Norwood Hills
Country Club Pro-Am spots Hospitality
packages VIP tickets and more available
now at Ascension charityclassic.com
if you have kids you already know St
Louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at St
Louis Union Station with a new Mirror
Maze light shows and the 20-story high
St Louis wheel it's enough to make any
parent feel like a star
St Lou is always exploring
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to uh our final game of the
day uh an eventful day in general and a
very very interesting and somewhat
educational end gaming process in in the
game between Fabiano and
maximoshkelegrav and honestly I'm very
impressed with how 5B is treating this
um he's doing a very good I think he's
doing a very very good job and I think
for the first time in the last maybe 10
minutes I really do think this is done
because I think your next move is King
A6 against most like it's very difficult
to not allow uh King A6 that's Saga
Queen E1 yeah I think A6 here and and I
think at this point I will start making
progress that is so significant that
wind becomes uh straightforward because
I'm I have mating threads I have threats
of driving the king away from the corner
with checks and then I can just put my
own King on B7 and start pushing so are
there mating threats though uh actually
uh yeah actually yeah 24 is is annoying
me a little bit but I get the feeling
there has to be a way to
no I actually have to go back oh I
thought this was still winning some I
mean it's winning but right but in the
way where you thought now we are really
really up against the wall yeah
I have an interesting idea here can I
can we take a look at something in this
in this position we're discussing
Queen E4 correct can I play can I I
actually do blunder uh stalemate here I
wanted to play Queen D6 check very nice
I probably have to go to ca yes and I
wanted to play B5 here
Queen takes a 4 King B6 and claim that
we're winning because threatening mate
in one and I would be winning if not for
the fact that yeah Queen A6 or queen A7
actually
this happened in a candidates tournament
between Sultan ribley and the Boris
basket result on rible is completely
winning and he allowed precisely this
kind of and he just slumped at the board
yeah
stalemate so even here if mvl keeps his
head and continues asking those
questions because I think once the king
gets to A6 and you don't give a check to
it I think you're entitled to really
feel dejected and feel that your defense
probably will not succeed but if you
keep your if you keep your eyes uh keep
your eyes on the prize and you keep on
finding those only moves which don't
lose immediately there is still very
very possible ways for why to throw away
their advantage yeah exactly Jump Right
In Alejandro uh we think Fab is doing a
splendid job we know that from our table
base but at the same time it doesn't
just go four move combination win but
you're starting to find them right you
start to see these combinations
adjustment for example Queenie one yeah
King a61 but Queen D6 Chuck is much more
accurate why if you go to C8 then I have
King B6 it's very similar but you don't
have checks on this side
so and again there's no immediate way to
give up the queen
for stalemate and if you go to the other
direction if you go up I give you a
check I do this and then I go King A6
what is the difference any check here I
have Queen B5 nice and anything else I'm
just giving you made in a couple of
moves so this one wins almost
instantaneously and again when you think
about eye on the price you were saying
trying not to lose instantly you're
having trouble coming up with moves that
don't win don't lose just right away uh
Queen E1 is one of them it just loses to
Queen D6 the engine says Made in 16
because it can already foresee the trade
of Queens coming promoting the other
display Queen F7 Queen F7 has been
played which is uh not immediate made
but there's no checks on E1 right now
yeah and we can we can actually start
pushing yeah we can start pushing and I
think it is time to start pushing with
B5 yes uh before now the point is uh
that if you allow King A6 and you don't
have a check specifically from the B7
Square yeah you will just get swept off
the board and yeah your options kind of
diminish before your eyes here with
black Europe you're running lower and
lower on on resources in terms of
available checks right and yeah this
does start looking very very lost even
you know from a purely human perspective
fiber is really low on time he he went
down to below two minutes prior to
playing Queen C5 but he's now above the
minutes again uh will yeah two two in a
bit against 21 and a half for for mvl
mvl has all the time in the world
considering what the position is but
here seems to be you know he is
balancing on this on this Edge where
it's not a lot of time but he doesn't
really let it run to I don't know 30
seconds where it becomes unnerving right
when you have to start playing an
increment
he might win this position even an
increment considering it's a 30 second
could you like that yeah but you want
you want that cushion of like a couple
of minutes at least so that you can stop
and your hands are not shaking by the
way Peter I gotta say uh
sharp eyes on that clock you were able
to just discern uh the two minutes not
so uh easy you've been eating your
carrots
Like Bugs Bunny a queen C6 no B5 uh
admirable restraint uh I have to say you
know the old carrots I eat a lot of
spinach and yet look at me like
absolutely no change absolutely no
change whatsoever Queen C6 you like
those apples uh it's a strange move it's
a bizarre move but as long as the table
base says it's winning
that's always
I find it hard to resist B5 myself I
just I think I would have played before
though wow okay and if I'm not playing
B5 I'm probably playing a check uh maybe
I'm messing things up with Queen D6 Jack
and then playing B5 but Queen C6
it's a bit of a strange church I don't
quite understand what that achieves like
what are we preparing that we are now
better prepared for compared to the
previous position like Queen A7 check
been played I guess he wants King B5 and
then ask MBL which Square do you like
anything to recommend for Queen A6
um
you can't give me yeah he goes to F7 or
G7 no no Queen A6 Queen C7 ah there's
that thing ah that is so beautiful yeah
let me show that Queen A6 Queen C7 check
and you think oh I've got this all in
hand Queen B6 and then comes the cold
shower
yeah oh my goodness so there are still
plenty of five you did not fall for it
he played King B5 and Bill instantly
replies with Queen E7 yeah we're we're
still winning but Ashley Queen C5 was a
very good move earlier and I think from
what I've seen see five appears to be
maybe the best Square here before Queen
on the board because he can play Queen
C5 then you put your King on A5 and that
pretty much removes all the checks
because they all allow Queen B6 with a
with a queen trade right and then you
can start pushing but he was already
there and he abandoned it for this
somewhat uh difficult to explain move
Queen six so we're sort of back to the
drawing board we've had this position
actually he played Queen D5 in it right
we had this a bit before yeah he we yeah
we definitely had this once before
and he played Queen D5 in it that was
about nine moves ago so this is If he if
he plays Queen D5 again that's a second
fold repetition yeah a twofold second
folder yeah yeah I mean it's been a long
day I understood one minute minutes and
counting down versus is that 21 yeah 21.
technically has made no progress in
eight moves right nine moves
well I mean he actually gave it away by
not playing B5 he made a ton of progress
I thought and then for some reason chose
to play Queen C6 and now it's back to I
mean he's we know he's still winning but
uh he is running way lower on time now
and yeah he is still not really
progressing
it's getting nervy time suddenly again
yeah so Queen B6 she's just giving a
Chuck King A8 will be played whatever
wait a second if he plays King A8 yeah
and he plays King C6 Queen C6
there's no repetition because the king
is on a different Square Peter yeah I
don't think C5 was necessarily uh even
such a landmine Square in terms of
repetitions it's on C6 but it's drawn
it's drawn oh
table based draw
Queen B7 Queen B7 the only move to draw
because no why because Queen C7 check
King A5 Queen C7 check
King A5 Queen C7 check which is
something that we had actually just
pointed out a moment ago
oh my
but also Queen D7 apparently yeah also
27 but yeah uh yeah so but everything
else loses mvl has to play Queen B7 here
and go from there
oh my
God oh my and again for the grand
Chester points this is huge but you just
feel this will be this will be just just
so heartbreaking he was completely
winning against the year played a really
nice game against linear did not win uh
then lost that that game to Wesley
yesterday and he found it his father
guys
yeah wow
well I have to give a hat tip to mvl
that whole when is with this King on G8
to March as king all the way across the
board to A8 and and Avail himself of
this opportunity that that's very very
skillful
yeah he he he gave himself out so it's
using using the the related parlance he
he played to his outs and uh there they
are yeah
oh my
we kind of stunned here we we've we've
had a stunning day
I mean for those of you who are joining
us late of course I'm referring to the
fact that uh world champion Magnus
Carlson forfeited his game earlier in
the day and withdrew from the sinkfield
cup we're going to wait for Magnus to
explain uh his reasons for doing so
and then we've had these types of
experiences today as well Peter uh
by Hans and uh this one too um
you know Fabi yeah King A5 played and
I'm pretty sure well yeah he just
blitzed it out Queen C7 I mean queen D7
apparently is a draw but nobody does
that if you sequence the seven you play
Queen C7 exactly and somewhere around
here Fabi will have this kind of a
horrible horrible realization that uh
things explode yeah things have not gone
according to plan at all Queen B6 Queen
E5 is just a straight up Perpetual you
can't avoid that kind of a pendulum
mechanism there help me on this one
because I'm
Community frequency Queen C3 Queen C8
absolutely there there it is yeah gosh I
was looking at Queenie one yeah he's
played King B5 but we've been there uh
we've been there already
oh my God this is going to be
devastating right yeah
yeah and after King C4 I think it's
still possible to misplay this yeah
there's
like only the the the the the moves that
you would expect to be drawing are
drawing but they they all do draw like
24 Checkers the draw Queen A6 Checkers
draw and as a kind of opponents option
you can still play Queen C7 which is so
disgusting like how is a quiet move in
this position still a draw but there
will be seven but there's no immediate
draw right yeah there's no immediate
draw there's not like a Perpetual that
white can't escape you give me a bunches
there might be I have a feeling Queen E6
might might actually be a Perpetual
Queen Asics yes
I think that this this might actually be
a Perpetual he played Queen E4 the most
uh yeah then I assume Queen D4 will be
played exactly right then let's say
queen C2 Chuck right team B5 Queen E2
check yeah King A5
okay oh we've run out of checks yeah the
only good move is Queen E6 oh
and that's good news for babies fans
yeah because because every all can still
uh make a mess that one up yeah right
Queen E6 is far from obvious no yeah
exactly
this is what I meant about that whole
Anish Gary Wesley so game where with the
the table base is going minus 47 and
triple zeros
uh with each uh yeah but this is this is
you know if we assume that mvl holds
from here which I think is actually a
favorite outcome with Fabio on a minute
but I was blundering Queen D4 actually
Queen C6 is an easier draw
sorry it's gone yeah
instead of Queenie two of course because
maybe first attacked yeah it could be
three and then we continue no Queen H1
it's a like Queen H1 is the only no not
the only but like the checks will run
out after queen of three Queen C3 I go
to A3 the checks run out it's just that
this is a draw yeah we just know this is
a draw because it's a draw but like a
good explanation
but that's all our knowledge of this
position really yeah pretty much WoW
we know it's a draw because it's because
what else can I say we we've given our
speeches by this point exactly we are
actually for a change being Vindicated
alive on there you just just don't play
these end games because I mean these are
two incredible players right and they're
making a I mean they're passing the
heart honestly and VL actually isn't
making a hash of it and VL is producing
Perfect Defense so far he was losing for
much of it because the position was lost
but so far very very little criticism
can be found I think of the way MBL has
been treating this end game exactly but
Fabi yeah missing the B5 moment I
remember the great way quote by
um this one I thought Anand after he
defeated Boris gelf and in the tie
breaks to win the World Championship
match he said I won because I won
I mean it was such a it was such a close
match yeah
King C3 so he's going to hide his King
on A3 I guess yeah what else and then
it's going to be two pawns and then it's
a draw because it's a draw but okay but
then game game kind of restarts and he
can also I guess win some time giving
random checks on like the eighth and the
seventh rank so that he could go from
like a minute to four minutes right and
start thinking again but he will know
that me too yeah he will know that
uh he may have missed or probably just
already missed an actual winning
position and now it's it's just
searching for chances
as opposed to converting let me ask you
this question Peter do you think
that I mean obviously the players are
aware of the whole Dr John Nunn uh
article that this is uh but do you think
they are both aware that at this point
they know the game is a table based role
I think so I think this position is the
one that we've all uh were kind of
introduced to when when the whole
concept of this not being winning was
brought up was exactly this case like
pawns on I don't know G4 and H4 or A4
and B4 the king specifically in the
coroner and the white king behind the
Pawns
and yeah I think by this point people
are aware that as long as you don't
blunder into a queen trade exactly you
always have enough checks if you if you
calculate cleanly
uh which is I mean all of those are
rather large use right you know
calculating cleanly is uh
not a given after you know six hours of
this for sure but yeah I think they know
I think I think both of them by this
point have recognized that market
Improvement has been achieved by black
at this point when I think about uh the
classical chess no Germans uh possible
anymore uh I think of a
I don't know how to say it a marathon
the players are getting exhausted we're
getting exhausted and we're just calling
the action we've got engines uh they've
been thinking and and
ferociously over each and every decision
a decision that could cost them the
point just like that aren't they getting
exhausted I mean it just is uh I mean
the the answer is very simply yes but
they're both uh I think sort of uh it is
very well understood by this point that
chess among other things is an endurance
game and you have to be fit well I'm
thinking classical chess in particular
no honestly actually no I think the
chasing principle whether it be Blitz or
Rapid or well the point about Blitz and
Rapid is that major events in particular
singfield Cup in that respect is maybe
slightly more leisurely than some of the
other competitions because in the
singfield not I mean the the rapid and
Blitz tournament during the GCC I didn't
mean right uh you play three rapid games
per day or nine Blitz Games per day
that's a lot it's tough but compared to
the world record and Blitz which is
four or sometimes even five rapid games
per day and the 15 round Blitz Swiss
like you play 15 and then 15. yeah or I
mean no this is short right this is it's
I think it's 12 and 9 maybe okay I think
it's 21 rounds these days I think it's
11 and 10. but yeah yeah but yeah it
used to be longer it used to be at some
point it was definitely a 15 15 round
day that is definitely the endurance
content yeah like if you don't need
endurance for this try it once actually
the original Grand chest tours used to
be uh four rapid games one day five
rapid games the other right and the
actually it was the the players that
told us uh how about no exactly I
thought it was the commentators that
said how about no how about uh I mean it
was the commentators but they didn't
listen to us so we threw the players
into the mix
nicely done Alejandra the
the union objectives to those working
out the queen of seven is one of the
moves that was drawn that is drawn okay
why this is drawn whereas uh for example
the move Queen F1 was losing a bit of a
mystery but it is what it is this one is
still preserves the draw
again Alejandro I know it's a challenge
but in words obviously we're trying to
Checkmate obviously we're trying to win
a pawn but
what is the um
how do I put it
what are we trying to achieve with white
yeah we're trying to get some kind of a
setup which would allow us to play five
King A4 and start pushing without
running into some kind of an immediate
kind of a pendulum so why didn't we play
A5 immediately
I don't know we I guess we chose to put
the queen of the light Square so that
perhaps we control some of the checks
from like uh because the way the way the
way you get checked I think is very
often exactly using the D1 Square once
you go King A4 the check from G1 becomes
maybe incredibly crucial so he goes
Queen D3 to control to control that
square and to perhaps you know hope to
uh to start pushing with A5
um and and we push with A5 and not B5
because we push with B5 we're exposing
it I think we're exposing our King more
to the elements compared compared to A5
makes sense but it's uh I think it's an
incredibly uh you know uh
let me play just some bad moves for just
a moment if you don't mind okay I'll
play another this one yeah
don't play be fine so we do we shouldn't
be playing for A5 and B5 yeah we play A5
and then if blood doesn't react properly
now for some reason uh all the checks
are winning
I still don't know why but all the
checks are now winning wow yeah it's
still it's still extremely possible to
misplay this as black of course easily
for both sides and we do have A5 on the
board and once again three minutes now
350 against 19 and a half very good so
if I did gain some time as we expected
like he got the king into the corner
checks ran out he he gained some time by
shuffling okay and now he has a bit of a
buffer and importantly we restart the
counter
oh yeah and yeah and that as well the 50
move rules we're actually halfway we
were 24 moves in wow I didn't even
realize we had gone that far for the 50
move rule spans any exchange or trade of
anything uh and the 50 move counter
starts again as it does with any pawn
move so we were up to 24. in this
position five moves draw
loses if you want to give this check you
lose and that's an easy check to fall
yeah after all it's a check why would
this because apparently we've lost we've
lost balance we need to return the queen
to good squares from which it can give
checks okay so weirdly uh as I
understand it and once again trying to
make sense of how the computer
approaches these positions is a very
very ungrateful task but what I'm
getting from what I see on my screen is
that the queen has to be on the sixth
it likes F6 E6 and also it likes the C6
Square so in the current position Queen
E6 is a draw Queen C6 is a draw or you
can make any move with the King right
actually just passing with the king move
doesn't lose but removing the queen from
the optimal squares and there are three
optimal squares on the board so far
available to that Queen if you if you
sex C6 and c6s yeah with the queen on D3
I assume with the queen on C3 it would
be like E6 D6 and something a change of
cards yeah uh but
it's it's very very difficult to try and
put into words uh What uh what they were
trying to achieve yeah
with this move A5 I mean I'm assuming we
were threatening to play King A4 that's
why I would yeah I I would be attracted
to the C6 Square for these two reasons
yeah and then the whole point is we're
not well at this point Queen C6 is
supposedly drawn we're not trying to
achieve P5 Peter you will you will
really enjoy the fact that in this
position you can go back to F6 and it's
still a drone
because people you will really enjoy
this I'm sure yes
fun was a draw I mean any any any
personal kind of
normal persuasion will play Quincy one
check here right but you can actually
just go back to F6 it really likes the
queen on F6 the engine well really
really likes it yeah okay I know it's
getting late but why is Queen C1 check
address actually I was absolutely like I
should take back my my uh the queen F6
yeah because Quincy one can be three
there are no more but are we trying to
do this are we trying to play A5 B5 A6
King A4 and creepy crawly and yes but
yeah it's it's just not are we Wolford
yes
you know and the question is are we
bothered and apparently the answer is no
if you're black here and if we're also a
machine
so A5 those two conditions are met we
are not bothered in the slightness but
uh
it's gonna be fun to watch yeah it's
it's definitely going to be fun to watch
because so far in VL as as we keep on
mentioning uh MBL has not committed
a single
sort of result changing mistake where
Fabi committed one I think
ooh Queen A1 check he's gone Queen A1
check we've established this somehow
loses we have no idea why
like why after King B3 Queen F6 here we
have lost like it was a draw with the
Poland B5 and white it didn't go yeah
one Queen E1 and now he's lost this is
lost but once again like do we know why
do we understand why according to we've
got five moves that win Queen D5 check
is a winner
Queen A6 check is a winner yeah Queen
DHS is also a winner and also King C4
important King C4 I can understand
because there's no not that many
comfortable checks right yeah you have
to start giving poor checks yeah you
can't you can't give good checks from E6
so you have to start giving poor checks
and the King starts making progress yeah
this I can relate to King C formula
makes perfect sense this move I would
find very very attractive yes as well as
maybe Queen D5 but once I say King C4
Queen E6 check and the interference
check check then I'm very excited by
King C4
um
so let's let's actually try to keep
count please and for our viewers we're
not doing this as a criticism no but
just as a way to keep us awake here so
the current the the count currently is
one one I think right right the change
of the evaluation from win to draw
happened once on each side so far and if
am I right in saying Queen D7 is also
somehow Queen to seven is also winning
yeah there we go the most natural move
uh King C4 okay so we're back to White
being completely winning and now we're
waiting for uh you know yeah if the
mistake comes it it comes from fabi's
side now right because mvl's choices
against perfect play no longer matter
from here on out exactly
okay and
from mbl's point of view
I can imagine Queen H4 check is designed
yeah I think cooking C5 there would be
quite annoying right
because you cannot give a check from the
teeth you can check from E7 I'll play
Queen D6 I'm sure I've already blundered
into a draw like what what I'm saying is
probably completely incorrect it's
probably finish for Community four
actually why are we giving you uh
opportunities to give more checks right
uh true true that through that
uh chime in on this one Alejandro we've
seen the potato past by both players now
once once a piece
well yeah yeah
okay what's the over and under for
what's what's gonna happen next
I think will Fabi play perfectly from
this point and re-establish it look at
you what's a second floor what a trainer
you are a man who stands with his it's
just so hard this thing games are so
hard even if he plays well yeah he wins
no a bunch of moves are winning
including such gems as Queen G6 and
queen of five
Queen F5 and queen G6 is winning now I
mean that would not be on my agenda at
all please tell me that Queen D6 check
is winning because that's the move I
find yes the most attractive yeah Queen
D6 is good okay good yeah most logical
moves here I think are good is King B5
winning Kingdom five is not winning
actually yeah never mind not every logic
because that kind of is a logical King
B5 is a draw but King C5 is winning yeah
King C5 wins but not King B5 because
because I think along with you from E8
specifically is very important uh well
that yes that yeah that makes perfect
sense I just played something he's play
Queen to six check I'm pretty sure yeah
yeah so he is still still good it's it's
the most human move still very good yeah
it looks so logical to to reap we we
talked about those ladder checks and the
reposition of the uh the queen Peter is
a perfect example of getting the queen
in better
I'm currently
having you know fever dreams of getting
Fabi here and getting him to explain
like yeah
the book about anything that preceded
the queen ending yeah just show him the
queen ending and tell him to explain why
this move was chosen over that move
right I think that's what he badly needs
in his life after this be prepared to
run out of Studio
I mean he's very fit but he's also small
I think I think I can take it okay
okay oh
boy okay uh King B8 what's the trickiest
how does mvl Trick into some of this
stalemate uh that we have seen
previously uh Alejandro how can he how
can he lay a trap or can he well not
right now because now when we come
closer maybe yeah we'll take a look
because right now everyone's winning
yeah every logical move is winning wow
okay for me the most logical move is
Queen D4 check uh just so that when I
start to position my king up the board
with King C5 I would like once again my
my idea here would be to play Maybe king
queen D7 and yeah he's played Queen
before I play it before he was preparing
he's preparing to start marching forward
exactly exactly I think you have to go
to B7 I think if you don't go to B7 you
might be like in more trouble but I mean
it's all very very uh subjective here
the position as we know is just lost now
but I think B7 is the most logical
Choice uh to you know offer some kind of
protection against King B5 King B6
you have something to meet King B5
exactly
King A8 just just hanging in the corner
I mean they're all the same thing eight
and King B7 are the best defenses and he
has chosen your king B7 people
enough obvious back to uh you know
trying to figure out exactly how to make
progress King B5 Queen E8 I suspect is
just yeah like apart from the queen
checks the only move that wins now is
King C4 D5
which you can sort of understand why it
doesn't throw anything away but he also
I thought I don't think you're making
much progress right yeah there is a
check from H1 but I guess
coffee yeah we have discoverers right so
yeah you can understand why Kingdom 5 is
not not stupid but it's also not a move
that you look at yeah kind of cute
because you are beginning to set up uh
submitting patterns down to two and a
half again for Fabi against 15.
yeah D7 check I think uh MBL will play
King B8 very very quickly
uh I think anything else would be kind
of strange although there is no real
difference between B8 and A8 both of
them are
uh on the same
and after King B8 the moves of the king
forward
are all the draw now
you you again do it you have to you have
to reposition the queen again yeah and
then for example after King B7 now you
can play A6 now you can play A6 check
and it's mating in a bit yeah that is
very very important these patterns they
should just be hardwired into the brain
so I guess after 26 check we are
sidestepping this we're playing between
let's say let's say we play King A8
exactly and
shockingly it seems like the winning
plan now is in a lot of positions
actually just to play 5a6
and to create mating threads and somehow
black runs out of checks but I mean how
confident can you be that the black
action does run out to be a little bit
worried that uh by advancing my pawns to
ahead of the the head of the guards so
to speak that I could be spoiling yeah
very very legitimate Warrior here for a
while we do it too early you you throw
things away easily I'm just going to
refresh my board everybody apologies for
that but we do have Queen D7
slowly slowly uh mbl's time is also I
mean he was up 20 40 minutes whatever he
had when he started is now down to okay
still a comfortable
13 is it am I seeing that right yeah
King ba played we we have to assume five
he goes Queen to six because it's a it's
a very useful check it's one of the best
squares on the board
generates threats also supports the idea
of a 506 in a bunch of positions which
should be quite useful I think even from
Common Sense point of view uh so yeah I
like Queen six I think 26 is likely to
happen from what I've seen uh if I'll be
doing this end game and then yeah then
he will at some point just have to start
uh getting it pushing you know pushing
putting finishing touches on it
exactly in this position Peter how many
uh winning moves does white have uh
seven all the checks and some of The
Quiet Moves not all the checks well I
mean the checks that don't land over the
queen yes right yeah yeah nice nicely
played because you know it it brings
back warm memories of me making such
statements in the presence of gustier he
never lets them go
whenever whenever I try to make a
generalization like this he's a real
charmer
no these are the three exceptions to the
statement you just made Peter yes thank
you very much Christy
nice okay and you know despite years of
that treatment I still as we've just
seen I I still stumble into it I was
about to say whispered
whoa Queen D4 well it's also winning I
don't get it but it's winning good move
but why like
the the commentary here has to be I mean
just as good as any other move right but
why this square and not some other
Square also King B7 is a repetition ah
yeah we've been there she's been there
King B7 now is a is a two-fold yes
oh dear
I feel like one of those uh moments
where you know the tension
is so high and you just
you you you're screaming for a break
it's like you know like absolutely and
we adjourn and what we've just seen on
the board on the screen there is I mean
it's a maybe it's a minor point to a
degree but uh I've honestly lost track
of time can somebody tell me what time
it is right now wait a 6 15. so they've
been playing for a five hours and a
quarter and Fabi has been playing on a
bottom like between a minute and three
for the past I think 30 moves
which means which means that if he
actually does need to get up it's It's
Tricky right It's Tricky so the last
hour is basically stuck at the table as
well true and uh what we mean to say uh
and we saw their mvl arriving in the bot
at the board with a bottle of water yeah
I don't think it's an it's a it's an
option for Fabian no I don't think you
want to be taking any of the goods
not at this moment no
um okay once again Ed come on guys do
your best for our audience put into
words what white is trying to achieve he
wants to bring his King forwards to
protect himself from checks from behind
as well as in the in the front so he
wants his King
I think it's been safety it's kind of
okay on C4 in a lot of cases because the
checks aren't that great the closest
I've come to you know moves that taken
together constitute a winning plan was
this idea of placing the queen on D6 and
then I think in a lot of positions just
playing A6 and generating uh legitimate
mating threads which is what we've had
so 27 this is a this is a twofold again
24 is actual draw now we will obviously
not play that right he has plenty of
options I think he gives a check from D6
now and asks the question and like one
thing I didn't really like about Queen
D4
is that
you're not asking a strict enough
question with the move Queen 74 without
the check I think you should always
start with Queen D6 and just sort of
pass past the uh the decision onto oh
okay A6 is this is a draw right that is
a draw that is a draw why is this a draw
well first of all I can pick up the pawn
and the pawn end game is it's a draw
it's a draw right so this is just a draw
with Queen oh Queen I think he wants
queen of fun Queen D3 but I guess uh
it's not working but I mean once you
play Queen E3 the checks just restart
right yes uh
that Fabi has thrown away the the the
the win with the move has he could he
actually have missed the fact that after
let's say queen F1 checking C5 Queen
takes A6 uh could be five Checkers on
twinning because takes takes on King B7
and we're just in time to establish the
opposition I'm even after five and a
half hours and yeah very unlikely like
Fabi doesn't miss this right no the
thing is sometimes you just you you stop
right
like any Queen trade is winning and you
realize in the back of your mind that no
that's not true I need to check those
but you've been playing for so long and
calculating so much random stuff that it
is incredibly possible to misfire
something basically like that no I think
by this point he's probably realized it
so he will play Queen D3 but then the
checks start yeah but then you've broken
up the chain you've given the black king
potentially a very safe Square on A7 and
the checks just restart like Queen D3 we
go I guess Queen F7
and we'll start giving checks from
everywhere
yeah
yes all the draw somehow Community six
also Queen C6 now is a drop Queen which
is really rubbing it in like oh my
goodness I didn't expect that to be the
case in general going backwards I can't
be
yeah once you once you start getting
shifted backwards like you're just
inviting before B5 here with black
because once before B5 happens and it
looks like eventually because A6 is
quite I mean I need to protect it and
now your king really has no cover so
like all perpetuals are a draw and
shockingly even Queen Steve like 56 I
understand it's a draw but even Queen C5
is a draw in this position wow just a
shocker yeah like truly yeah wow uh I
must say at this moment when the King
was on D4 just prior to I just love this
move King B5 King D5 I like that idea of
you checking on H1 and getting but uh
some misfiring going on here I'm just
going to refresh my board everybody
Queen E2 Queen D3 on the board yep
yeah
probably never actually and now Queen E7
whoa Queen E6 check is losing Queen E6
check is losing because
because it's losing
why why are you asking me this I guess
King C5 when you run out of checks I
think it's very simple actually I think
I think C5 is maybe the best Square on
the board so the drawing move the
screening to E7 only everything else
I think we're about to see a 2-2 yeah
extremely impressive you just tip your
hat and say Well done young man that is
just amazing I think a lot of us would
go Queen E6 check in a in a but actually
it's game Queenie six check out how do
you proceed after King C5
Queen C8 check
oh
uh King B5 I'm just trying to make sure
I think we're hiding on A5 so Queen E6
Channel C5 forces you to go to C8 it
forces me to go to see it the moment you
see this check is so awkward and then we
go King B5 King A5 and actually at that
point the checks have run out yeah Queen
E8 King A5 and you can no longer give a
sensible check or really a check of any
kind yeah with this configuration I'm
going to trade Queens by force yeah and
and this looks losing now this really
does look completely completely lost
um
I just love these assertions that I
you know but here I can trade Queens I
can go Queen B5 Queen B7 yeah Queen B
Queen B5 Queen B7 yeah we no longer have
to think anymore very nice that's what
I'm looking for is an opportunity to bed
and say I've got this and nailed down to
single digits and it has to find Queen
East happens yeah as only moves go it's
it's a tough one I think right it's a
very very tough decision to come to
oh my word
because it allows you know all the
things that white generally wants to
play like Queen D5 or I don't know
queen of three I had one Queen ending
like this the game that couldn't devour
China uh had like five okay two two
let's see let's see King C5 only winning
move okay but that one actually that's
an easy one yeah I think I think that
one is fine yeah because we're ready to
meet Queen E7 check with a check of her
not that I understand why King B5
wouldn't be
I think uh don't go there
queen king C5 on the board
so we're back in in business as Judith
Polgar would say
so if I if I pay one there or something
yeah
here we have Queen D5 I'm pretty sure
right
um yeah that's the difference yeah I'm
talking to to Alejandro there without
really us seeing the board which is yeah
the question was the difference the
difference is that on Queen E5 check
like for example he plays 25 check right
now Queen D5 is the only winning move
but it's sufficient yeah it's a goodie
yeah and that is the difference between
King C5 and King B5 after King B5 Queen
E5 check would have would have would
have held because because you you you
can't really get anything in the way and
King A4 Queen A1 restarts the no King A7
here Queen A1 is losing again King A7
unfair all of this is just so unfair
very good but the difference is that
that Fabi did make the good choice of
King C5 so that after he's ready he's
now ready and prepared to uh block a
queen check with Queen D5 yeah and and
after Queen C8 as as we've established
we go uh B5 A5 the checks run out and
once again once it lands on A5 here
the last of the checks is met by the
inter posing
Queen B5 check yeah and it's almost but
not quite the staleness if the King goes
to the a file and we take on E5 and the
ba square is gone right but the other A7
is you know yeah A7 A8 is still here we
go 25
quite quickly I think it's by far the
most natural decision here
also even without knowing it's the only
move that wins I think exactly but just
the fact that Queen B5 will also
establish a threat of our own
um
and it will win next but pretty much
next move because let's say
yeah after 27 the checks run out after
Queen C3 the checks run out he can check
from E7 but once again I can go be 5a5
and the checks run out check from E3
yeah King E5 I assume
E2 A5 and there's no check from it the
dominating Queen on D5 that is pretty
right that is very pretty I mean the
geometry orbit is very very clean yeah
yeah we we want to stop the check but we
also want to deliver a mate
yes
so we do have Queen D5 on the board and
it looks like the count will stop it too
frankly I I don't want to drink spot
people from here I think from two to two
from here the calculations become like a
three move very very straightforward
calculations which you
uh very very relieved probably should
take it home from here exactly
where we see our Deputy Arbiter keeping
an eye
making sure the clock and equipment is
all working you ever had that uh where
you know obviously we have these
electronic clocks they are battery
they're not some of them now are
hardwired so they go into an electric
socket but you you you your clock just
explodes because the battery died and
nobody explodes no but there was a very
very famous incident which sort of went
into into the chess lore very much that
you know potentially you can maybe even
argue produce ripples that change chess
history altogether
there was the candidates matches in
Kazan In
2011 I want to say maybe that was the
one Lavon defeated no they've all lost
in round one to to Sasha but he defeated
in one candidate uh now 2009 Magnus uh
that was true that was a different one
okay pardon me yeah uh and in the first
round of that Vladimir kramnik was
playing against Raja above
I think they drew all six of their
classical games and I think they maybe
even have drawn the first two rappers
I'm less sure on that topic
and then I think in the first Blitz uh
Tamor had an absolutely winning position
and then the clock actually did die and
now after yeah A7 check now wins I think
this this is yeah this is findable yeah
right yeah that's A7 check now is pretty
good uh pretty yeah this this works King
A7 Queen C5 and we are finally done with
this home and dry so I can go back to my
pointless yes a wonderful story yes and
I'm enthralled Midway through that game
the battery in the clock died
and the game had to be stopped obviously
it was not restarted I mean it was
restarted from the same position it's
not like they started from scratch
but the incident and the pause kind of
interrupted tamer's flow so much that uh
he did not win that game and ended up
losing the match
and uh
suffice it to say he was not very happy
right
and uh perhaps some some grudges were
born ah
for future not future not not Vladimir's
fault though I mean it just happens at
the the battery uh does it like do we
really have to discuss the sort of the
nature of grudges how they don't really
conform
not not always logical at all A7 the
winning move and he found it with a
minute and 90 seconds on his clock yep
wow and that's it and that's it
what a relief for Fabi as he gets on the
scoreboard and pulls down a very
important uh grandchester arrival
oh that was a huge result for the
tournament huge Smiles by the players
but my gosh uh for Fabby he needed this
one yeah he really did this yeah and
yeah at some point it
almost deleted his grasp I mean arguably
his grasp and then you know Hallelujah
looted it yeah
and uh
there we see uh Leonard our photographer
and on Anastasia anxious to ask the
players to come into studio so that we
could torture them with our Queen ending
questions only yeah are we are we
actually doing this no I don't think we
are
I hope not for family's sake but I do
like the idea of just bringing him in
bringing them into those two moments and
say are you aware that you blew it
terribly with this I'm pretty sure the
answer I'm pretty sure the answer will
be yes I'm pretty sure he will uh
I knew like maybe he doesn't know
exactly where it went from a win to a
draw but I'm pretty sure he's aware that
this wasn't uh uh an entirely Mis you
know mistake free conversion I'm sure
let's take a look with this Victory our
current standings Peter absolutely and
once again we have to take into account
that uh some people play more games than
others yeah but uh as things stand it is
Wesley so on top and two and a half out
of four Fabiano caruana is on uh two out
of three
am I
no no no that's not right five is
actually on two out of four but correct
he got 50 thanks to his victory today
alireza is also on two out of four yeah
and two out of three we probably should
at some point introduce
maybe the number of rounds played in
Brackets because we can still keep it
and keep it in mind now but by round six
everything will get completely scrambled
uh years and years and 50 yeah
is I believe actually in the minus now
this is actually
um and the remaining three players are
all on minus one just from a different
number okay exactly and let's just take
a look at that peek at what we can
expect tomorrow's games uh Peter yeah
let's be honors let's take a look at
this
plays against the victor of this really
really difficult green ending uh
Marathon yeah
Dominguez is White against Hans Neiman
uh is always White against the one or
onion our mvl will aim to bounce back
from this loss in a wide game against
it will get a free day yeah a new part
of our graphic there will be there will
be one co-commentator per day exactly
we're just gonna you know
usurp him yeah write this into the
contract Midway through the tournament
that the player who is not playing has
to you know do a do a stint in the
studio right schooling us on the
I can't wait for you to give us uh the
your final thoughts of a very very
eventful day and how you're going to
phrase it all Alejandro you're prepared
to wrap up our show for today and
prepare for father to start walking this
way oh no he will have to go through
security by the way uh as he leaves the
plane
David Sedgwick had called for additional
security measures including leaving uh
so what do you think I mean what a day
guys yeah I mean it's not every day you
see I mean it's the first time ever
Magnus Carlsen just doesn't show up for
a game and this is going to have
everybody talking about it we got some
interesting games of Chess I mean Lavon
and Lanier played some interesting game
of chess but it's definitely not going
to make the headlines uh NEPA and Wesley
got out of there pretty quickly and we
had two epic matches I mean I thought
that Hans Perugia game
it was fantastic it had it had a lot of
content right absolutely let's put it
that way and then well this one had two
this one had 92 moves of content guys
yes that was a lot that was a lot of fun
uh always this queen on gets very tricky
but well they uh they want to keep the
commentators on their toes and here we
are they did they did
achieved achieved well once again I mean
history in the making as I've never seen
Magnus uh step away from uh it's a game
uh forfeit I mean we're in very very
unknown territory here but um
perhaps this situation will will get you
know there will be some development some
some further statements by uh by perhaps
sure we're going to hear a lot of them
uh let me just inform that we do have
upcoming events as well absolutely after
the Sinclair cup we have the ultimate
moves the trash talking challenge that
takes place after the singtel cup it's
it's very nice bring bring your A
quibitses absolutely and it's a kind of
a lighter light or chest related entity
always welcome here then we have three
days of fisherendum uh Slash chess 9lx
right with a lot of very illustrous
players playing in that and and that is
a small break in proceedings here
followed up by another Marquee event of
the year of course uh the US Open and
the U.S women's Chess Championship
starting on October the 3rd right the
national championships are so strong
Peter it's just fantastic and what can I
say but we have to take a look at our
prophecies our commentators Bay who's
going to win the sinkfield cup uh
I don't know about my man you look good
through round one I mean I gotta tell
you something boy well maybe maybe we
should allow him to repeat you know we
should be like I don't know this is
three rounds can I re-pick it okay can
somebody show me my standings I mean you
got to buy in I got to tell you
something if this is not for us mature
what is I mean
I don't I don't think of this as an act
of God if you're going to call this an
act of God we've got issues but buy-ins
are yeah and you know it goes into a
pool goes into a kitchen yeah exactly
okay we're gonna allow you a buy-in it's
a thousand dollar buy-in thank you thank
you appreciate it friends friends what
are they for exactly nobody knows nobody
the questions the answer to that
question a question for you are we
waiting for Fabi to join is that what we
are no he is on his way and uh I haven't
been mic'd up I think I can hear him I
can see him guys
and we'll pounce on him the moment we
get this queen ending and we'll get our
table bases ready and we'll ask him
every question Under the Sun I really
feel like we should commit to the bib
what we want
just pound him into the table that's
what I like three degree and we're gonna
jump immediately
as Hobbies in fabby's in studio
Karana nice short game here take us
through every single move of the queen
end game if you could where you thought
you had an advantage and where you
thought it was a draw I can't tell if
you're joking or not
[Laughter]
I love this
when we saw a lot of
um correspondence games we know that you
use those very often for your
preparation when and how did you come up
with this move well I I um realized
something which is that I mean even
though I play pretty awfully recently I
do destroy one opening which is the
night or all my wins are in this one
opening yes maybe maybe you shouldn't
tell that to your opponents you have a
lot of them coming up well Maxime is uh
is one of the few nighter players
remaining so um yeah it works even with
an idea uh from from the candidate's
preparation
uh I expected him to know what to do but
even if you know it you know you you
might not remember all the details and
it remains very very difficult he played
the first move correctly and then after
Queen E4 uh well rookie five is the most
natural move but rookie is the best move
I mean it is a four straw
but it's a very very complicated four
straw and so yeah he couldn't remember
and he came up with his rookie 5 F6
which looks terrible
but I couldn't find the reputation and
also used terrible I mean okay now I see
Queen D4 but it's not Queen D4 is not
even a move I considered like
if you let it run a little bit longer it
does think we need to even stronger but
Queen D2 FG I didn't see the way here
mg in this position we just take
yeah but take Queen D6 isn't this bishop
C1 Bishop d3m Bishop C1 Bishop D3
because it's made on f8 at the end for
some reason I thought
that with the Rook on E5 this would hold
for black but with the Rook on C it
doesn't matter Rook on C5 or E5 like I
was trying to get this with the Rook on
C5 and uh The Rook over here yeah
yeah because I thought like
I thought Bishop H6 Queen E5 BC like I
this is the line I was looking at
and I thought I need my queen on C5 so I
have Bishop C4 check and okay now I see
Queen D5 Queen E4 here
um
well like this this idea of Queen E4 and
with a pin didn't like enter my mind
um this is like why I why I um rejected
it and I thought Queen H2 was strong but
after Rook C5
you have to go back basically yeah I can
play Queen E2 rookie five Queen D2 but I
still didn't see this I was kind of
convinced that I need this position with
the Rook on C5 that's why I played Queen
D2 immediately after repeating once and
yeah King agent was kind of what I
thought he should play
um
I thought I would have a big Advantage
here but he was defending like this
whole rookie 5d5 was a remarkably good
idea yeah especially considering that
after F4 he still can take the bishop
what's that considering that after F4 he
can still take on C4 yeah yeah I I
thought that it would be a very bad end
game after DC but like I didn't have
another option because D5 Bishop A6
Queen F4 and he like it just turns into
a mess if I take on A6 instead of f4 ah
okay yes like it's kind of the the first
but then Queen F4 and like it's a big
mess his King is no longer in danger
yeah I can play this bishop B5 I was
thinking about it but my pawns are
moving slowly and
I don't know like I didn't think I would
be able to keep control of this
situation
and then eventually you got to this
queen end game and we are not going to
talk about it
okay so generally with like the two
pawns up it's
there's a lot of positions which are
drawn yes and a lot of positions which
are winning and they all kind of look
the same yes but after G6 I just didn't
see what else to do no you you were
playing perfectly until very late
winning but I just didn't like find the
way to do it we just kept the tally the
tally was two to two
sometimes you give up the win and two
times he gave up the draw but it was
just not too bad considering that the
complexity of the end game well once my
king had was forced back then it's a
draw yes yes but I mean this I figured
but I had no choice because um he just
like has a Perpetual right but I I
yeah I assume that like at some point I
play A5 A6 in this configuration but I
just couldn't find the moment to do it
and I was kind of trying to like play
some moves to gain time on the clock and
wait around a bit which is I guess why I
also missed um the win yeah really the
only confusing moment everything else is
very explicable but the only confusing
moment was move 64 I think
uh very very specifically where we
thought you played perfectly until that
moment like every single decision was
absolutely spot on but before B5 here we
assumed what must have been very
attractive and we thought this was yeah
if I was my first intention and then
after like King King B7 I couldn't like
find I don't know and I was worried that
I'm you know pushing the beep on is is
not the right way normally you push the
a pawn but uh
but I I just didn't see the wind here so
and I thought okay he's going to play
King B7 immediately and I have to find a
win with two minutes and now my king is
a bit more open so that's why I didn't
go for this
and and I had this idea that okay maybe
I should be a kind of patient and wait
around a bit longer
um but yeah I guess it's winning some
higher probably a big victory for you
for the standings not only of the
tournament but the grand chess tour in
general how are you feeling after this
Marathon game no I mean this was great
this was exactly what I needed after
yesterday
um playing two very difficult games in a
row so I am quite tired as well I know
that it was already a while ago but you
must have noticed a sort of Magnus
Carlson missing in the playing Hall
today uh your thoughts
well
um I mean I guess there's a lot of
rumors already
and I assume he hasn't given the reason
yet why he decided not to play but
probably some people have a decent idea
of what he's alluding to
or what he has a problem with I don't
know but I I'm not going to to say
anything else about it sounds good well
Fabio was a long day so we want you to
get out of here so we can get out of
here congratulations on your win thank
you
indeed a very very important victory for
Fabi uh you know sometimes you just go
through these periods where you know
things aren't going your way and then
suddenly it's sort of like somebody
turned a light switch and that's what
happened for Fabi today important
important Victory uh people yeah let's
listen he absolutely needed that uh the
tournament really wasn't going his way
some opportunities were missed and then
Wesley played a really really good game
against him yesterday but this should
restore at least some of the confidence
because I mean the mistakes he made in
the green in the green ending really
don't count yeah you know to a large
degree they don't come yeah and of
course we can't uh Overlook the fact
that social media must be exploding uh
with what has happened uh in today and
Anastasia is with Alejandro to give her
give her perspective over to you
Anastasia yeah you are absolutely all
right yes sir social media is talking of
course only about Magnus and his
withdrawal from the tournament many
comments people who keep talking about
it they say it's a drama a single cup
will be never forgotten this one for
sure and of course I mean this day
started like a normal day so Magnus
today with his family with his mom and
dad and Peter honey Nielsen working
nearby Chase hotel we couldn't even
imagine something like this would happen
today so of course everybody is talking
about it all players also gave their
comments we can you can find those
interviews in our social media you can
check St Louis chess club you can check
grantchester I highly recommend everyone
to follow our accounts for more news for
more backstage content so welcome to our
accounts don't forget
thank you for that um now is the time I
would say your job just exploded
you you went from being very very nice
happy quiet to suddenly you know your
next 24 hours is going to be overload
we'll get you on national news in no
time absolutely interviews Galore coming
up well for us I think it's a very good
moment to sign off Peter you were great
all the way through the screen ending
it was a it was a challenge as long as
you say up front that you're an idiot
you're yes you're kind of okay yeah I
think it's very important to lay the
ground rules as early as early as
possible you're off the hook thank you
everybody for joining us tell your
friends where you're hanging out and
we'll see you all tomorrow see you then
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited